Hilfe geht die in Formen des
black-hubschraubers hinter mir zu sehen
ist oder auch Panzer auf der anderen
Seite des Heldenplatz wichtig ist auch
der Fokus der heurigen leistungsschuh
der auf der Zusammenarbeit von
zivilpersonenuniform also Miliz Soldaten
und dem Bundesheer liegt
abnehmen
ja genau drinnen
[Musik]
okay
Test 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
ja
Hubschrauber den das Bundesheer besitzt
ja ein komisches Gefühl wenn man sich
denkt dieser Hubschrauber ist
normalerweise mit 360 km/h mit bis zu
360 km/h in 4000 Meter Höhe unterwegs
aber er gilt als besonders crashsicher
und ich steige jetzt auf weil die ersten
Besucherinnen und Besuchern hier im
Heldenplatz bereits hinten in den Black
Hawk Hubschrauber einsteigen wollen
der Black Hawk kommt beim Bundesheer
besonders für die ja Entschuldigung
ja genau der Black Hawk Hubschrauber der
kommt beim Bundesheer vor allem für die
Katastrophenhilfe zum Einsatz also bei
Naturkatastrophen und großen Unglücken
so war letztes Jahr zum Beispiel bei den
Waldbränden in hirschenwang oder auch
bei den Hochwassern in Einsatz er gilt
als besonders gebirgstauglich und er ist
vor allem kann er bei schlechten
Wetterverhältnissen gut fliegen und
deswegen gilt da auch als besonders
crashsicher was noch ist er kann hier
bis zu 20 Personen können hinten in den
Black Hawk
einsteigen und er kann eine Last von bis
zu vier Tonnen an Material
transportieren und damit übergebe ich
schon an Visa wie auf der anderen Seite
des Heldenplatz zu meinem Kollegen
Andreas mayr-bosch
ja die Panzer sind vielleicht weniger
schicker als die Hubschrauber aber dafür
eignen sie sich gut zum herum klettern
darauf und das wird auch von den
Menschen hier gerne angenommen die
Panzer sind immer ein Publikumsmagnet
bei jeder Ausstellung hinter uns da
steht sozusagen die Speerspitze im
Gefecht ein deutscher Leopard 2 also in
Deutschland produziert dieses Riesending
wird schon seit 40 Jahren gebaut hat 62
Tonnen Stahl verbaut und eine 12 cm
Kanone also eine massive Feuerkraft und
mit 1500 PS kann man dieses Monsterteil
auf bis zu 70 km/h beschleunigen wozu
braucht das österreichische Bundesheer
überhaupt noch Panzer lange Zeit hat man
ja gedacht Panzerschlachten wird es
nicht mehr geben seit dem Krieg in der
Ukraine wissen wir ein konventioneller
Krieg ist ohne Panzer eigentlich nicht
zu führen und auch das österreichische
Bundesheer verfügt hier über 50 Leopard
Panzer und die werden dann im Falle
eines Gefechts begleitet von den
leichteren Schützenpanzern steht hier
drüben das ist ein Ulan ein
österreichisches Produkt auch mit einer
Kette kann sich also in jedem Gelände
sehr gut bewegen auch beim Matsch und
Schnee und in diesen Schützenpanzern
wird dann die Mannschaft transportiert
also da haben bis zu acht Personen Platz
und im Idealfall ist halt vorne der
große
Kampfpanzer und hinten Nachkommen dann
die Schützenpanzer österreich hat 50
Kampfpanzer und 112 Schützenpanzer das
ist im Vergleich zur Schweiz nur recht
wenig aber dank des größeren Budgets
jetzt werden auch die Panzer in
Österreich massiv aufgerüstet technisch
modernisiert damit man im Notfall dann
auch wirklich gerüstet ist
[Musik]
ja der Nationalfeiertag der steht ja
auch als Tag der Bewegung und da ist
Bewegung nicht nur für Soldaten wichtig
sondern für uns alle und deswegen geben
wir jetzt einen Trainer der Nation viele
bällek zwei drei vier fünf sechs eins
zwei drei vier fünf sechs sehr schön das
ist die zweite es kommt darauf vor wie
lange drauf sind ja okay sag mal schon
drauf oder was meine Damen und Herren
einen wunderschönen guten Morgen
Österreich recht herzlich willkommen wir
sind mitten drinnen im täglichen
Bewegungsprogramm und es sind alle
eingeladen bei uns mit dabei zu sein ich
habe jetzt noch mal kurz gezeigt warum
es bei uns geht wir sind an meinem Stand
unterwegs genau aufrechte Körperhaltung
worauf achten wir dann Nagel zieht
Richtung Wirbelsäule aufrecht genau und
jetzt marschieren wir mal dahin und das
Schöne ist wenn man sich einmal hier
umblickt wir haben
herrensportlerinnen wir haben Damen und
Herren die jeden Tag egal welche
Altersklasse bei uns kann jeder
mitmachen aber niemand muss sehr schön
meine Damen und Herren was machen wir
setzen unser Lächeln auf okay so und
jetzt werden wir ein bisschen höher das
heißt wir versuchen genau mit unseren
Knien Richtung Handflächen zu kommen
sehr schön nach oben ziehen Einsteiger
beginnen da unten genau setzen wir es
Lächeln
sehr schön ja die Synchronschwimmerinnen
die kennen das genau sehr schön okay so
jetzt locker mal aus jetzt machen wir
die Übung mit den Handflächen was man
gesagt haben auch zu Hause Handflächen
liegen an und jetzt 1 Fingerspitzen
Richtung Schultern
Ellbogen sind noch um zwei dann nach
oben Handflächen dreht sich aus wir
kommen retours nach unten und jetzt
genau
wirkt es dann schon eine Dynamik ja das
gefällt mir das ist schön und auch zu
Hause seid ihr eingeladen bei uns mit zu
turnen
nach unten genau
Rhythmus sehr schön und wieder nach
unten ja und nach oben Lächeln aufsetzen
das ganze nennt man angelenks
Mobilisation die Frau sich schon super
aus ja Lächeln aufsetzen genau nach oben
gehen sehr schön und wieder ja da
bleiben wir dran einmal geht's noch
einmal gehen wir noch nach oben kommen
wieder nach unten genau und locker nass
so nächste Geschichte wir geben unsere
Fingerspitzen Richtung Schulter und
jetzt Körpermitte stabil beginnen einmal
nach links
einmal nach rechts
ja ganz locker zunächst einmal und ich
darf auch die Damen und Herren bieten
jetzt genau zu uns gestoßen sind damit
zu machen genau rechts links
Mobilisation Schultergürtel ganzer coole
Geschichte Lächeln aufsetzen ja das tut
gut
rechts links
Mobilisation hat ganz wichtiger Faktor
ja auch beim Bundesheer grüß Gott
und rechts links genau ja so und dann
nächste Schritt immer machen ist wir
drehen uns einmal in eine Richtung und
jetzt versuchen wir unseren Daumen
nachzublicken mit der Einatmung kann man
mit der Ausatmung wieder nach vorne und
zunächst einmal hier Schultergürtel dann
machen wir auf Einatmen komme wieder
zurück nach vorne gehen genauso sehr gut
und nach hinten wie gesagt das ist nur
ein kleiner Auszug aus dem was wir
täglich tun und kurz nach neuen in ORF 2
wie gesagt bei uns kann jeder und jede
mitmachen und ich freue mich sehr Sie
heute hier mit den heeressportlerinnen
und Sportler gemeinsam tun kleinen
kurzen sportlichen ersten Einheit
schalten wir zurück auf den
orf-königinalpark ins Studio zu sein
sondern von rechts nach links genau auf
[Musik]
wir machen so
der Bundespräsident wird jetzt die Front
der angetretenen Truppe abschreiten die
Ehrenkompanie besteht aus der
aus der Musik in dem Fall ist das die
Gardemusik zu erkennen schön an den
fangschnüren das sind diese an der
Uniform außen angebrachten Silber-
[Musik]
des Weiteren sehen wir dann einen
insignientrupp mit der Fahne der Garde
der Bundespräsidenten für
Bundesministerin und Generalstabschef
bleiben vor der Fahne stehen um ihr die
Erde zu bezeugen und dann
wird die Front abgeschnitten 60 Rekruten
der vierten Garde Komponistin
[Musik]
das sind alles grundbediener bis auf den
kompaniekommandanten und die
Zugskommandanten wo es sich um
Unteroffiziere handelt das Gewehr wird
präsentiert und jetzt meldet sich der
Kompaniekommandant ab Hauptmann
Lichtenegger meldet sich ab
und jetzt geht es zur
kanzleren
Überlegung im weiraum wir sehen hier
weitere Garde Soldaten in ihrer Rolle
als sag als
kranzsträger bzw ehrenspalier
und während die Soldaten des muss man
auch betonen das sind auch
Rekruten die im Sommer eingerückt sind
die diese hohe Aufgabe jetzt bereits
hier erfüllen und der Bundespräsident
tritt jetzt vor und richtet als
Staatsoberhaupt die Schleife
und dann hören wir einen Choral
[Musik]
der angetretene Truppe hier sehen wir
das ehrenspalier präsentiert die Waffe
zu diesem Staatsakt
[Musik]
und jetzt erfolgt dann
jetzt erfolgt die das weitere Befehle
durch den kompaniekommandanten
und während der Bundespräsident mein
Kleidung des generalstoffchefs und der
Frau Bundesministerin jetzt den
Heldenplatz wieder verlassen Richtung
seiner Amtsräume
wird unter präsentiert recht schaut und
gesenkter Flagge
der Herr Bundespräsident quasi von der
Garde Kompanie verabschiedet und
[Musik]
somit hat dieser erste Teil des
staatsakts ein
Ende
Sicherheitspolitik Hans Bürger der
Nationalfeiertag vor allem auch ein
politischer Tag wir feiern die
Neutralität Österreichs welche Bedeutung
hat er denn vor für die Politik nämlich
vor allem jetzt eben im Ukraine gekrieg
wo auch die Neutralität Österreichs so
viel diskutiert wird also dieser 24
Februar 2022 hat sicherheitspolitisch in
Österreich sehr sehr viel verändert
jeglicherweise sogar mehr als der
EU-Beitritt natürlich nicht was die
Fakten betrifft aber was die Einstellung
der Österreicherinnen und Österreicher
zur Bundesheer zur Neutralität zur
Sicherheitspolitik zu Europäischen Union
betrifft wir kennen neue Umfragen auch
zur Europäischen Union wo es ein
bisschen skeptischer ausschaut als noch
in den letzten Monaten und Jahren
an einem halten aber die
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher fest
das ist die Neutralität die
Zustimmungsrate ist enorm hoch mit über
70 Prozent und wenn man bedenkt dass
zwei andere Neut Länder wie viel Land
und Schweden der NATO beitreten wollen
und werden ist das bei uns offenbar
überhaupt kein Thema die letzte Umfrage
gezeigt dass rund 16 Prozent nur der
österreichischen Bevölkerung und also
derer alle die hier leben
für einen NATO-Beitritt wäre das ist
extrem wenig und deshalb wird sich
wahrscheinlich in nächster Zeit in
diesem Thema auch nichts tun aber man
darf nicht vergessen dass durch den
EU-Beitritt das habe ich zuerst
angedeutet letztlich die Neutralität
schon extrem ausgehöhlt worden ist also
wenn wir da ins Detail gehen würden
beistandsklausel und so weiter was
Österreich alles tun müsste und könnte
wenn es tatsächlich zu einer
militärischen Situation kommt dass die
Europäische Union angegriffen wird dann
ist das extrem viel und ob wir uns dann
noch neutral verhalten können im Sinne
der Neutralität das wird eine ganz große
Diskussion werden denn politisch
sind wir ja nicht neutral aber dann wird
es auch mit der militärischen
Neutralität schwierig werden obwohl wir
will nicht zu lange Reden dieses
Instrument der konstruktiven Stimmen
Enthaltung schon seit dem Vertrag von
Amsterdam und jetzt auch im neuen
Vertrag Lissabon haben das heißt wir
können sagen macht ruhig aber wir tun
nicht mit wir können es aber nicht
blockieren also wir haben da schon eine
sehr sehr ja interessante Rolle eben wie
sie gerade gesagt haben militärisch
neutral nicht neutral beim Militär
neutrale politisch nicht kann man das so
durchziehen das ist ja auch ein
schwieriger eine schwierige
Gratwanderung eigentlich auch für die
Politiker also der Bundeskanzlerin hat
das klar deutlich festgestellt er hat
gesagt wir sind natürlich politisch
nicht neutral wir sind gegen den
Aggressor wir sind da eindeutig auf der
Seite der Ukraine wir sind auch
Teilnehmer am Sanktionen an den
Sanktionen Paketen der Europäischen
Union militärisch sind wir neutral naja
was heißt das das heißt natürlich dass
wir
Wahnsinn keiner Weise militärisch an
möglichen Aktionen beteiligen aber da
gibt es natürlich schon jetzt viele die
sagen ja was ist dann mit den Ausgaben
die die Europäische Union im Budget
vorsieht zum Beispiel für für
Waffenkäufe für die Ukraine finanziert
dann nicht indirekt Österreich dass
dieses Budget mit ja natürlich es gehört
hat kamashall also das ist schon eine
extrem heikle Diskussion und sie wird
noch viel stärker werden nämlich an denn
die Einstellung der Österreicher und
Österreich und Therapie hier leben zur
Neutralität beziehungsweise vor allem
auch zu den Sanktionen gegen Russland da
beginnt etwas zu bröckeln das wird
sicher ein großes riesiges politisches
Thema im Herbst und in den nächsten
Monaten werden weil man ja befürchten
muss dass dieser Krieg noch sehr lange
dauern wird da gibt es vor allem eine
Partei eine Parlaments bei der die SPD
gegen die Sanktionen ist
naja als vielleicht ist der Vergleich
nicht zutreffend aber mir kommt es ein
bisschen schon so vor wie in der
corona-zeit wie in der Pandemie als am
Anfang alle gesagt haben die Maßnahmen
sind gut und dann aber relativ bald vor
allem auch die FPÖ und dann ja auch
diese neue Partei MFG begonnen haben die
diese Maßnahmen in Frage zu stellen und
natürlich ein Gefühl der Bevölkerung
ausgenutzt haben die gesagt haben es
reicht uns mit diesen Maßnahmen und wenn
man sieht was Sanktionen für Folgen
haben Sanktionen gegen Russland das sind
jetzt bei den Energiepreisen dann kann
es schon sein falls es ein kalter Winter
wird wenn es tatsächlich zu
Wohnungen kommt die nicht mehr
ordentlich beheizt werden können dass
die Stimmung gegen die Sanktionen extrem
ansteigen wird also das wird eine sehr
heikle Situation und man muss schon
davon ausgehen dass sich die
Freiheitlichen auf genau dieses Thema
drauf werfen werden und
dass wir den interessantes 2023 auch
politisch heikel Herr generalmaier wie
wichtig ist dann die militärische
Landesverteidigung in Österreich obwohl
wir ein neutrales Land sind
ich würde sagen gerade weil werden
neutrales Land sein weil ich denke
wir haben mit dem Staatsvertrag ein
klares commitment abgegeben einen eine
Grundfeste geschaffen wofür Österreich
steht und das ist natürlich auch eine
Neutralität die mit militärischen
Mitteln notfalls zu verteidigen ist
wir sollten uns da doch ein sehr gutes
Beispiel an der Schweiz nehmen was sagen
ja immer wir sind nach dem Schweizer
Vorbild neutral die betreibt das in
einer klaren Art und Weise wo
auch die militärische Landesverteidigung
logischerweise ein großes Thema ist und
was ich besonders bedeuten
betonen möchte ist eben das
Landesverteidigung gerade die Ukraine
zeigt das ja sehr deutlich jetzt und die
ganzen wirtschaftlichen Maßnahmen die
jetzt unser Land in der einen oder
anderen Art treffen dass es hier nicht
nur Militär geht sondern es geht auch
ganz stark um eine umfassende
Landesverteidigung
die bereits in den Zeiten des Kalten
Krieges ein großes Thema für war für
Österreich denken Sie nur an die
Tanklager die angelegt wurden das auch
wirtschaftlich man sich verteidigen kann
wenn man wenn man die Dinge nicht mehr
bekommt das ist eine zivile und eine
geistige Einstellung gibt dass eben die
Werte für die Österreich steht
verteidigungswürdig sind und das ist
natürlich etwas wo das Bundesheer nur
ein äußerer Repräsentant dafür ist wofür
eigentlich die ganze Nation stehen
sollte vielen Dank fürs Erste und sie
beide
sie sind Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
Uniform die milizsoldatinnen und milit
Soldaten und das ist auch der
Schwerpunkt der heurigen Leistungsschau
der österreichische Regisseur und Oskar
Preisträger stefan rusowitzky hat dazu
für das Bundesheer vier Kurzfilme
gemacht die wir im Laufe dieser Sendung
sehen werden im ersten Kurzfilm wird
eine Übung von Milizsoldaten
Berufssoldaten und Grundwehrdienern
beobachtet wir lassen auch einige
minizoldaten zu Wort kommen und Fragen
sie warum sie sich freiwillig zur Miliz
gemeldet haben und wie sehr der
ukrainekrieg ihre Haltung zu Krieg und
Landesverteidigung auf den Prüfstand
gestellt hat
[Musik]
trainieren panzerkannt
wie sie die verteidigen und wären und
die haben natürlich auch gut
für euch ist aber für mich alleine durch
diesen Konflikt ist die Übung jetzt eine
ganz andere durch den Konflikt druckt
ist dass man Blitzerdaten haben
bei mir auch war dass ich die Motivation
und die Einstellung um 180 Grad gedreht
hat weil ich einfach sehe dass die reale
Bedrohungen wirklich vorhanden sind
jetzt genug
in Europa klären es lang also kleiner
fühlt wie eine wie Russland und die
haben tatsächlich Kinder verteidigt bei
mir im Bekanntenkreis waren jetzt
erstaunlicherweise einige Leute die
vorher absolut pazifistisch eingestellt
waren im Sinne überhaupt kein
Kriegsgerät bedeutet überhaupt kein
Krieg die ihre Meinung jetzt sehr stark
geändert haben
[Musik]
kämpfen können und nicht kämpfen zu
müssen
[Musik]
die ganze Zeit in der jeder von uns auf
der Welt ist und in Österreich lebt wir
leben in einer Demokratie jeder darf
sagen was er für richtig hält ja jeder
hat er freie Meinung das ist bei uns
möglich und das ist auch das ist auch
wert also das ist riesen riesen Luxus
wir haben und das Keller beschützt
gehört also beschützt auch um das
Bundesheer muss man sich kümmern nämlich
in Form von mehr Geld und das passiert
jetzt eben auch im Budget 2023 sind wir
haben es gehört 680 Millionen mehr für
Landesverteidigung vorgesehen wir haben
bereits darüber gesprochen seit Februar
hat sich die geopolitische Lage sehr
verändert deshalb wird also wieder mehr
auf die eigentlichen Aufgaben des Heeres
nämlich die Landesverteidigung geschaut
aber mit dem frischen Geld soll nicht
nur neues Gerät angeschafft und die
Ausbildung verbessert sondern auch
Altlasten beseitigt werden
beispielsweise werden beispielsweise
werden Kasernen modernisiert Klaus
Bruckmann hat sich umgehört
die Zustimmung zum Bundesheer ist immer
sehr hoch wenn es um die Militärmusik
und den Katastropheneinsatz geht nun ist
aber Landesverteidigung wieder in den
Mittelpunkt gerückt vor knapp drei
Wochen in Wiener Neustadt 75 junge
Männer und Frauen haben Ihr Studium an
der Militärakademie abgeschlossen und
sieht nun Bachelor und Leutnant quasi
als Abschlussgeschenk erfahren die
jungen Führungskräfte dass es mehr Geld
für das Bundesheer geben wird
diese Forderung nach einem höheren
Anteil der Landesverteidigung am Budget
gibt es seit Jahrzehnten vorbei 20
Jahren wurde der frühere Wiener
Bürgermeister Helmut Zilk Vorsitzender
einer Reformkommission damals beklagte
er
tut das Sozialproduktes die ausländische
Militär der Chefs die halten sollen im
Bauch und lassen sich schief ne das sind
die verschlusslichter und wann war er
Prozent Anteil als vielleicht
wünschenswert oder vielleicht möglich
das haben wir immer noch die letzten
danach sankte Anteil sogar auf 0,6
Prozent zu Silvester 2018 bemängelte der
Bundespräsident dass das Bundesheer
seine verfassungsmäßigen Aufgaben nicht
mehr erfüllen können
2019 stellte der damalige
Verteidigungsminister Thomas Starlinger
in einem Bericht da was das Bundesheer
bei fortgesetzt zu wenig Geld alles
nicht mehr leisten kann
nun gibt es mehr Geld ist stalinger mit
der Wende der Wertigkeit der
Landesverteidigung im Budget zufrieden
wir haben in unserem Plan damals
verschiedene Bereiche aufgezeigt was
notwendig ist zu investieren das war
Mobilität
soldatenausrüstung Digitalisierung und
Cyber drohnenabwehr
aufklärungsfähigkeit und es entspricht
da den Bereichen die jetzt seitens des
Bundesministeriums in Angriff genommen
werden kann man sagen sie haben damals
den Anstoß gegeben
durchaus so Berichte sehen ja
nun mit dem neuen dem höheren Budget
zeigt sich der Oberbefehlshaber des
Bundesheeres zufrieden
seit Beginn meiner Amtszeit habe ich
eindringlich darauf hingewiesen dass es
unabdingbar ist das österreichische
Bundesheer mit der notwendigen
Ausrüstung und der entsprechenden
Infrastruktur auszustatten denn wir
müssen die militärische
Landesverteidigung sicherstellen ich
glaube
insgesamt stehen dem Bundesheer in den
nächsten zehn Jahren 16 Milliarden Euro
zur Verfügung nahezu alles soll
modernisiert werden die Mobilität der
Einsatzkräfte
Bewaffnung und Schutz der Soldaten
Aufklärung und cyberabwehr Folgen
automatisch Luftwaffe und Luftabwehr
das finanzrahmengesetz und ein
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
sollen das Sicherstellen auch die
Opposition hat Zustimmung signalisiert
und damit erreichen dass das Heer auch
für die Landesverteidigung und nicht nur
für den Katastrophenschutz und die
Militärmusik gerüstet ist
gerüstet für die Landesverteidigung wäre
also wichtig ja wir wollen das Thema
heeresbudget noch ein wenig vertiefen
und gehen dazu live zum Heldenplatz
wieder zu meinem Kollegen Andreas Mayr
bohuschte einen hochkarätigen
interview-gast neben sich hat
der Generalmajor hammeseder sie sind
Miliz Beauftragter der Bundesministerin
seit vielen Jahren für das Bundesheer
aktiv jetzt im Wesentlichen besteht das
österreichische Bundesheer aus drei
Teilen den Berufssoldaten den
Grundwehrdienern und natürlich der Miliz
manchmal hat man das Gefühl dass gerade
dieser Teil die Miliz etwas
vernachlässigt wird warum das war in der
Vergangenheit leider so wir konnten da
von einer zwei
Klassengesellschaft beim Militär
sprechen aber das hat sich Gott sei Dank
in jüngste Zeit massiv geändert denn von
der Gesamtstärke des österreichischen
Bundesheeres von 55.000 Soldaten sind
36.000 Angehörige der Miliz und diese
milizangehörigen bringen ihr ziviles
Wissen in ihre militärische Funktion mit
ein und das ist etwas besonderes und
daher muss es eine Gleichbehandlung
geben und ich sage dazu ganz klar dieser
Weg ist beschritten
wir haben vor wenigen Jahren am
Höhepunkt der corona-pandemie ein
historisches
Erlebnis gehabt bei der Miliz nämlich
die Aufbietung also zum ersten Mal in
der Zweiten Republik wurden
Milizsoldaten in großer Zahl einberufen
wie waren da die Erfahrungen was hat man
daraus gelernt was hat funktioniert oder
nicht funktioniert
wir waren uns und ich war als Miliz
beauftragter sehr froh ich war da auch
frühzeitig eingebunden in diese
Planungen und es war eine historische
Entscheidung der Frau Bundesminister bzw
auch der österreichischen
Bundesregierung erstmalig
milizangehörige für einen
Assistenzeinsatz im Inneren aufzubieten
das ist etwas ganz besonderes und es gab
jede Menge lessons learnt wir haben
gelernt wie lange bevor man Soldaten in
den Einsatz schicken kann aus der Miliz
braucht man eine Miliz eine Vorbereitung
wir haben auch gesehen wo ist das Fehlen
Ausrüstung wo ist das fehl an Übungen
und daraus wurde ein großer Plan
entwickelt es hat ein eigenes Projekt
dazu gegeben dieses Projekt ist
mittlerweile abgeschlossen und wir sind
mittlerweile soweit dass wir ziemlich
genau wissen wie eine zukünftige
aufbindung noch besser Funktion wird
jetzt gibt es seitens der Wirtschaft
immer wieder auch Kritik die
allermeisten militsoldaten sind in einem
Zivilberuf aktiv und da klagen dann die
Arbeitgeber wir können auf unsere
Mitarbeiter nicht verzichten sie sind
selbst oberster Bankchef wie
funktioniert es bei Ihnen warum klagt
der die Wirtschaft so oft wenn jemand
für das Bundesheer einrücken soll ja
leider ist es so dass durch das
Abschaffen der verpflichtenden
milizübungen die Last dieser
freiwilligen Meldung auf den einzelnen
abgegeben wurde als Soldat und
milizbeauftragter stehe ich natürlich
sehr dafür dass wir wieder
verpflichtende milizübungen haben aber
derzeit ist das und so realistisch muss
man sein politisch nicht der umsetzbar
persönlich bin ich überzeugt dass in den
nächsten Jahren man ableiten wird müssen
dass wir wieder zu einer
miliz-übungsverpflichtung kommen wird
aus der Wirtschaft heraus ganz klar
gesprochen wir fördern und ich
persönlich fördere milizangelegenheit
Miliz Angehörige weil das militärische
wissen ein besonderes wissen ist dass
man in der Wirtschaft sehr gut auch
verwenden kann es wird ein Mehrwert
mitgebracht von diesen Soldaten die
Basis für eine funktionierende Miliz ist
ja der Grundwehrdienst dort lernen die
jungen Männer auch Frauen dann
vielleicht freiwillige das Bundesheer
kennen wie wichtig werde noch eine
Aufwertung des Grundwehrdienstes damit
es dann mit der Miliz überhaupt
funktioniert
grundwertdienste überhaupt die Basis das
Fundament damit sich junge Menschen
überhaupt für die Miliz interessieren
können jetzt wurde ein ganz wichtiger
Schritt gesetzt das wurde auch die
Entlohnung der Grundwehrdiener deutlich
angehoben durch eine Entscheidung der
Frau bundesministerinnen und der
Bundesregierung Geld ist aber nicht
alles sondern Kameradschaft die jungen
Menschen lernen
Krisenfestigkeit sie werden resiliente
sie werden gefestigt da in ihrer persön
Möglichkeit und jene
grundwehrdienerinnen und runde dienen
die eine hervorragende Ausbildung
genossen haben die melden sich in der
Regel auch für die Miliz danke Herr
generalm vielen Dank
vielen Dank Andreas Mayer bohuschke und
in diesen Minuten ist dann auch die
macht sie auch die Regierung am Weg zum
äußeren Burgtor zur Kranzniederlegung
sie werden schon wie zuvor
Bundespräsident Alexander von der Bellen
durch die
Kastanienallee schreiten
noch sehen wir sie nicht
ja die Regierung
zuvor hatten wir den Bundespräsidenten
gesehen bei Graz Niederlegung was ist
denn der Unterschied jetzt zu Regierung
der wesentliche Unterschied ist dass
natürlich der Bundespräsident als
Oberbefehlshaber des Militärs diesen
Staatsakt vornimmt
die
die Bundesregierung hat ja hier eine
etwas andere Rolle hier geht es wirklich
um die um die Verneigung quasi der
gesamten Staatsführung der
Bundesregierung vor den Opfern derer für
die für die Freiheit Österreichs
gestorben sind
und
was hier auch zu beachten ist ist ja der
Sonnensystem bei uns im in Österreich
der Bundeskanzler
nicht in der Befehlskette zum Militär
ist es ist der Bundespräsident der
oberwelthilzhaber
das Verfügungsrecht über das
bundesheerub liegt der Bundesministerin
ist zum Beispiel ein Unterschied im in
Deutschland ist der Bundeskanzler der
Oberbefehlshaber im Einsatzfall über die
Bundeswehr die richtigen Deutschland ist
das anders warum ist das in Deutschland
so dass der Bundeskanzler den
oberbefehlern in Österreich ist das der
Bundespräsident gibt es einen Grund
dafür das hat alles sehr sehr stark mit
den verfassungsmäßigen Bestimmungen zu
tun die wie wir in Österreich das
geregelt haben und wie die wie die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland das mit dem
staatskunstgesetz geregelt hat
offensichtlich wollte man hier den
deutschen Bundeskanzler ist direkt
gewählten Vertreter des Volkes nehmen
weil der Bundespräsident in Deutschland
wird ja nicht vom Volk sondern von der
von von der von der
Volksvertretung gewählt
Hans Bürger jetzt gab es vorhin einen
Ministerrat es gab aber kein Foyer es
wurde auch nichts beschlossen das ist ja
eigentlich wir haben es zwar vorher
schon mit besprochen vielleicht noch mal
ganz kurz was ist denn der üblich es
gibt einen sonderminister oder
Nationalfeiertag wird der üblicherweise
was beschlossen oder eben nicht
üblicherweise wird nichts beschlossen
aber es wird eine Erklärung abgegeben
oder wie ich eben recherchiert habe ein
Zuschauer hat mir eben geschrieben ich
soll nicht Handy spielen während einer
Live-Sendung dabei habe ich aber
recherchiert
eine Information zu bekommen die ich
auch bekommen habe es wird ein kommuni
unterzeichnet werden zu Sicherheit und
Unabhängigkeit wobei die Unabhängigkeit
sich auf die Energie bezieht und jetzt
sehen wir die Regierung aus dem
Bundeskanzleramt kommen Herr Bürger wenn
sehen wir denn da aller ja wir sehen
Claudia Danner die Verteidigungsminister
dann den Vizekanzler Kogler und dann den
Bundeskanzler nehammer und ja es ist
jetzt ja genau dann den Chef des
Bundesheer wenn man sozusagen generell
[Musik]
Generalstabschef also ich habe noch
immer GTI im Hinterkopf früher hat er
Kaisten general truppeninspektor glaube
ich informiert bin ja und wie gesagt
vielleicht darf ich das noch kurz
ausführen also es wird eine Erklärung
geben das wird ein kommilit verkündet
werden von Vizekanzler Kogler und
Bundeskanzler nehammer wo sie sich
deutlich noch einmal zu den Aufgaben des
österreichischen Bundesheeres bekennen
werden zur Landesverteidigung zum neuen
Blickwinkel seit eben dieser Krieg in
Europa stattfindet in der Ukraine und
großes Thema wird die Unabhängigkeit von
fossilen Energieträgern sein man will ja
da einen sehr ehrgeiziges Ziel haben und
grundsätzlich auch von Russland völlig
unabhängig werden das wird heute im
Detail vorgestellt aber tatsächlich
beschlossen wird am Nationalfeiertag
eigentlich
nicht
Herr general Mallorca wird jetzt die
gehen jetzt auch Richtung Kranz
Niederlegung was ist da jetzt von
protokollarisch anders wir werden
einzelne kleine Unterschiede sehen die
sich darauf beziehen das eben der die
Bundesregierung eine andere Stelle hat
Stellung hat als der Herr
Bundespräsident des oberbefehls haben
und Staatsoberhaupt somit gibt es ein
etwas anderes
ankündigungssignal und ist das kürzer
oder ein etwas kürzeres
ankündigungssignal und
wenn man das nicht weiß dann wird es
einem eigentlich auch nicht auffallen
aber das auch diese diese Fragen sind
alle ganz klar protokollarisch geregelt
wir sehen wieder dass der Herr
Bundeskanzler und der Vizekanzler
begleitet werden durch die Frau
Bundesministerin und den Chef des
Generalstabes dahinter der Rest der
Bundesregierung und wieder als quasi
Hausherr militärischer Hausherr in Wien
der Wiener Militärkommandant direkt
hinter dem Herrn Bundeskanzler
jetzt ist noch ein Stückchen des Weges
zur absolvieren am Volksgarten vorbei
Richtung
heldentor
[Musik]
und wir werden dann wieder hören
das ankündigungssignal das durch den
Trompeter
gespielt wird
das können sie noch ein bisschen was zu
dem ankündigungssignal also das ist
kürzer auf jeden Fall aber
es ist
das ankündigungssignal ist ist Teil von
verschiedensten militärischen
Signalen die gespielt worden sind das
ist ein ein traditionelles gut weil im
Frühjahr wie man noch nicht über Funk
geführt hat wurde eben das jemals den
Trompeter der Gardemusik wurde eben über
Signale
kommandiert und somit hat Zeichen geben
für Angriff Rückzug
vergatterung Tagwache ist ein sehr
bekanntes Symbol und eben in diesem Fall
bei so militärischen Festakten gibt es
immer als fixen Bestandteil wenn der
höchst anwesende eintrifft dass das
ankündigungssignal gespielt wird
jetzt müsste gleich die Trompete kommen
hat schon gewartet ja jetzt
kriegt er ein Zeichen oder
bekommt ein Zeichen Warner zu spielen
hat es gibt da im Hintergrund einen
arzttermemonienmeister der das ganze
ablaufen lässt
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt die Meldung durch den
Ehrenkompanie der hat jetzt wieder über
präsentiert recht schaut die
Ehrenkompanie so hergestellt dass sie
die erbbietung Richtung Herrn
Bundeskanzler gibt
die vierte klare Company ist hier
eingesetzt die Garde ist ja am Standort
Wien in der Maria theresien-kaserne
untergebracht wir sind in
kompaniekommandanten
mit dem
hauptformation der Garde zur
grenzenderlegung
heute im Großeinsatz erkenntlich auch
die Garde sehr gut
an dem scharlachroten bereit
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt sehr schön gesehen die
Garde Fahne im Bild und jetzt schreitet
der Bundeskanzler im Begleitung des
Vizekanzlers der Frau Bundesministerium
des generalstoffs auch gesehen dass ein
Ortswechsel des kanalstabschefs
stattgefunden hat weil der höchst
anwesende immer am nächsten zu Truppe
die Front abschaltet
Ehrenbezeugung vor der vor den Insignien
das Abschalten davon ist ja auch ein
traditioneller traditionelle Sache hier
geht es grundsätzlich darum die
Einsatzbereitschaft und die Ausrüstung
[Musik]
darzustellen dass eben die Truppe hier
an ordentlich angetreten ist
der Ehrenkompanie Kommandant meldet sich
ab
gerade spielt ja eigentlich eine große
Rolle
hat hier eine
sehr entscheidende Rolle und diesem Tag
es ist für jede Garde Kompanie ein
Großkampftag der 26 Oktober wollen
entsprechend auch
klar ist dass wir das hier tatsächlich
ein unmittelbarer Einsatz stattfindet
wenn man steht im Lampenlicht
was auch für die Motivation der
kundenbediener immer sehr gut ist weil
wer kann sowas schon erleben
an solchen Akten teilzunehmen der
Bundeskanzler jetzt in der im weiraum
bei der ganzen überlegen
[Musik]
nach dem Ende des Chorals
wird jetzt ihren Kompanie
wieder hergestellt so nennt man das
und das erfolgt dann wieder die Meldung
an den Herrn Bundeskanzler der hier ja
Protokoll ist der höchst anwesende ist
auch wenn er nicht
ein weiterer Befehle
grundsätzlich nicht
also das war jetzt genau der Unterschied
auf den über den wir schon gesprochen
hatten während der Ehrenkompanie kommen
an sich beim Bundespräsidenten nicht
abmeldet sondern weitere Befehle bietet
haben wir jetzt die Situation gehabt
dass er sich beim Bundespräsidenten beim
Bundeskanzler abmeldet und
das begründet sich einfach dadurch dass
es keine Befehlsgewalt des
Bundeskanzlers über das Bundesheer gibt
was hier auch
protokollarisch quasi dann seine
Niederschlag findet in der
militärischen
Art und Weise diesen Festtag zu Beginn
wir sehen es doch von oben wie die
Regierung zurückgeht ins
Bundeskanzleramt vom äußeren Burgtor
Hans Bürger die Regierung ist jetzt am
Rückweg wie sonst nicht genau was sie
machen aber wir wissen dass sie wieder
zurückkommen um Reden zu halten auf der
papstbühne später die ÖVP ist ja derzeit
auch ziemlich unter Druck Stichwort
Korruptionsvorwürfe wird Bundeskanzler
kurz Entschuldigung
dass
erwähnen möglicherweise in seiner in
seiner Rede oder ist das nicht der
richtige Tag dafür also ich kenne die
Rede wirklich nicht ich habe sie auch
nicht vor abrecherchieren können aber
ich traue mir jetzt das fast
auszuschließen dass er heute an diesem
Tag über Korruptionen innerhalb der ÖVP
berichten wird oder irgendetwas dazu
sagen wird ich denke er wird sich mit
dem befassen was auch im Ministerrat er
sagen wird gemeinsam mit dem Vizekanzler
mit dem Thema Sicherheit und
Landesverteidigung und großes Thema
energieun Abhängigkeit ja wieder heute
noch nach Abu Dhabi reisen um dort in
Verhandlungen zu treten über mögliche
Gaslieferungen also dieses Thema ist so
bestimmend dass ich mir nicht vorstellen
kann dass er heute auf die klassische
Innenpolitik eingehen wird das heißt das
Thema Ukraine kriegen wir eine sehr sehr
große Rolle spielen in allen Reden
wahrscheinlich die wir heute hören
werden davon ist auf jeden Fall
auszugehen es gibt ja noch auch der
Bürgermeister
Wiens Bürgermeister wird eine Rede
halten nämlich sogar die allererste Rede
es wird auch Bundesministerin Tanner
eine Rede halten was was wird da gesagt
wenn es abgesehen von Ukraine Krieg
naja es ist schon so dass am
Nationalfeiertag grundsätzlich die
jeweiligen politischen Vertreter sich
mit dem befassen worüber Sie reden
nämlich über den Nationalfeiertag
diesmal ist es wirklich anders diesmal
muss auch darüber geredet werden welche
Folgen hat ihm dieser Ukraine Krieg was
bedeutet da für die
gesamtwirtschaftliche Situation in
Österreich da wird man mit Sicherheit
vom Wiener Bürgermeister Ludwig etwas
hören weil er auch in der
Energieunabhängigkeit in der fossilen
Energieunabhängigkeit Wiens bestimmte
Dinge plant und vorhat ob er da jetzt
ins Detail geht das glaube ich nicht
aber dieses Thema wird alle reden klar
beeinflussen und ich traue mir fast zu
wetten dass die
Verteidigungsministerin das Jahresbudget
loben wird die 16 Milliarden die das
Bundesheer bekommt und mit Sicherheit
darauf hinwirken weisen wird dass sie
die erste Verteidigungsministerin ist
jetzt mit großem i der es gelungen ist
dieses Budget durchaus zu bauen Fragen
die regiert wird Musik gespielt wollen
wir uns das vielleicht ansehen
oder bleiben wir im Studiogespräch
hier wird Musik gespielt der
Generalmajor was hat das für eine
Bedeutung
in den inneren Burghof hinein und wird
dort abtreten und
warten für das Aufziehen dann für die
groß Angelobung die wir dann in Bälde
sehen werden also den nächsten
wesentlichen Höhepunkt wo über 1000
Rekruten dann angelobt werden wo dann
wiederum die gare Kompanie entsprechend
eine große Rolle haben wird im
Zeremoniell man sieht auch hier jetzt
die zwei vergangenen corona-jahre da
waren jetzt nicht so viele Leute jetzt
hat sich hier der Platz schon gefühlt
kann man sagen das ist schon ein
größerer Antrag oder oder kommt dann
noch was ja jedenfalls die
wir können davon ausgehen dass das heuer
schon ein großer publikumszustom sein
wird es ist ja auch voriges Jahr sehr
gut besucht gewesen auch wenn die Anzahl
der Rekruten
überschaubar war mit 100 im Vergleich
sehr sehr gering aber üblicherweise
haben wir in den vor corona-jahren ja
sehr viele
Besucher aus ganz Österreich gehabt
natürlich
ziehen auch die große Angelobung die
Verwandten und die Eltern der
Rekrutinnen und Rekruten an die dann
auch die eine oder andere Stunde noch am
Heldenplatz verbleiben
etliche Schaulustige und das Bundesheer
zeigt bei der heutigen traditionellen
Leistungsschau nach zweijähriger
corona-pause ich habe es angesprochen
wieder allumfassend was es hat uns
bereits mehrfach erwähnt von Eurofighter
Hubschrauber und Panzer bis hin zu
Spezialkräften durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine ist das Thema Landesverteidigung
jedenfalls wieder in den Fokus gerückt
es ist fast schon Tradition mit dem
Black Hawk Hubschrauber über Wien
fliegen von der Kaserne aus dem Norden
kommend über die Innenstadt gemeinsam
mit drei anderen heereshubschraubern
dazu ein paar Runden über Stephansdom
Parlament und dem Heldenplatz drehen und
dann die Landung neben der Hofburg und
der Beobachtung zahlreicher
Schaulustiger es ist schon jedes mal
schön zu sehen dass die Anerkennung und
auch der Zuspruch sehr groß ist hier am
Heldenplatz und es ist natürlich nicht
wenn die Arbeit immer leistet auch
honoriert wird von der Bevölkerung nach
zwei Jahren corona-pause kehrt die große
Leistungsschau also zurück wir sehen
natürlich auch dass die Bevölkerung
interessiert ist ja also wir haben
mehrere hunderttausend Personen erwarten
die sich das da anschauen die das Gerät
wieder mal angreifen mit dem Personal
reden können sich einfach informieren
und wir da ein bisschen aufklären können
ein Nationalfeiertag am Heldenplatz wie
früher aber auch nicht seit 24 Februar
herrscht wieder Krieg in Europa das
Bundesheer und die Frage über dessen
Leistungsfähigkeit ist wieder in den
Fokus gerückt und auch die Frage über
die Durchführung der Schau es ist
sicherlich eine sehr besondere Situation
die wir derzeit in Europa haben aber es
wäre aus meiner Sicht völlig falsch die
österreichischen Streitkräfte zu
verstecken wir gehen daher ganz bewusst
wieder hinaus in die Bevölkerung um die
Leistungsfähigkeit des Bundesheeres und
auch um die Einsatzbereitschaft der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten zu zeigen
Panzer Hubschrauber und anderes
Militärgerät hat man zuletzt sehr oft
bei Bildern aus der Ukraine gesehen
dementsprechend der Umgang des
Bundesheeres mit dem Thema die
Sensibilität ist sicherlich gestiegen
wir werden das auch im Bereich der
Moderation sicherlich auch erwähnen und
Berücksichtigung finden darüber hinaus
haben wir auch ein Zelt mit
Militärexperten hier
durchaus auch zum Ukraine Krieg
informieren werden 1000 Soldatinnen und
Soldaten sind im Rahmen der
leistungschau im Einsatz dazu kommt die
feierliche großangelobung von rund 1000
Rekruten und ein Überflug von zwei
Eurofightern laut einer Herkules
Transportmaschine großes Thema für das
Bundesheer auch die Suche nach Nachwuchs
wie in fast allen Branchen gibt es
ebenso bei der armeepersonalmangel beim
Aufbau am Heldenplatz am Montag in
erster Linie Touristen die anderen
Reaktionen auf die ausgestellten
militärischen Fahrzeuge unterschiedlich
ich finde es interessant allein
technisch aber prinzipiell an Kollegen
jetzt mit der Steyr am Arm kann ich
nichts damit anfangen wir sind
beeindruckt wir haben sogar Fotos
gemacht und posiert
das Programm am heutigen
Nationalfeiertag durchaus größer als
früher denn neben der Leistungsschau
gibt es auch noch die digitale Version
im Internet ähnlich wie im Vorjahr
die vierte Panzergrenadierbrigade bildet
die schwere Brigade des Bundesheers und
ich stehe hier vor einem kampfband
seinem Leopard mit Oberwachtmeister Lars
Greinecker wie viele dieser Panzer sind
gibt es denn in Österreich und wie viele
Panzerfahrer wir haben derzeit
stationiert beim Panzerbataillon 14 in
Wels 50 einsatzbereite Kampfpanzer und
können diese auch mit Panzerfahrer
besetzen wobei unter anderem auch fertig
ausgebildete Panzerkommandanten die
Ausbildung zum Panzerfahrer besitzen
wann und wo kommen denn Kampfpanzer
rüber Panzer in zum Einsatz
grundsätzlich kämpfen Kampfpanzer gegen
andere Kampfpanzer daher dass wir das
hauptwaffensystem der österreichischen
Langstrecke sind bilden wir auch daher
dass er mechanisierte Rückgrat des
österreichischen Bundesheeres das heißt
man wird auch zum Panzer Offizier
ausgebildet was beinhaltet denn diese
Ausbildung ein panzerzieher hat ebenso
die Ausbildung zum Panzerkommandanten
und führt unter anderem auch einen
Panzerzug oder auch eine Panzerkompanie
kann man quasi sich beim Grundwehrdienst
sagen ich möchte Panzerfahrer werden ja
genau wenn man beim panzerbatterium 14
in Wels einrückt und man hat den
B-Führerschein Zivil dann hat man auch
die Möglichkeit dass man auf die
Panzerfahrschule nach ansteck geht und
dort die panzerfahrausbildung durchführt
jetzt ist es ja nicht ganz einfach so
einen Panzer zu fahren was sind denn da
so die Hürden die Hürden sind vor allem
er ist ziemlich breit ziemlich schwer
und vor allem auch die
sichteinrichtungen des panzerfahrers
nämlich nur mit drei Winkel spielen dass
die Sicht ziemlich eingeschränkt ist
dieses Gerät auch im Gelände zu führen
und zu fahren nun wir stehen hier eben
vor einem Kampfpanzer dem Leopard es
gibt aber auch sogenannte Schutzpanzer
wofür sind die da die sogenannten
Schützenpanzer sind grundsätzlich mit
den Kampfpanzern immer im Einsatz jedoch
können Kampfpanzer nur beschränkt den
Ortschaften oder im bewaldeten Gebiet
kämpfen und somit haben wir die
Schützenpanzer die auch eine
Infanteriegruppe mit haben zur
Unterstützung mit
danke und damit zurück ins Studio zu dir
Rebecca danke vielmals Saskia ja täglich
erleben wir wie russische Raketen die
kritische Infrastruktur der Ukraine
bombardieren im folgenden Film werden
eine Kremser Universitätsprofessorin und
ein Chorsänger der Wiener Volksoper
porträtiert beide minizoldaten sind
bereit im Krisenfall kritische
Infrastruktur wie Flughäfen Bahnhöfe
Kraftwerke raffinerin oder Krankenhäuser
zu beschützen
[Musik]
mein Name ist Anna Kaiser ich bin
assistenzprofessorin für
Kulturgüterschutz an der Universität für
Weiterbildung Krems einen wunderschönen
guten Morgen
militärisch war ich die letzten fünf
Jahre kompaniekommandantin der Jäger
company Tulln einer miliz-companie
[Musik]
bin der danielstraße bin seit 22 Jahren
jetzt an der Volksgruppe dann Wien ich
habe mich entschlossen mich zum
scharfschützenausbilden zu lassen um die
kritische Infrastruktur schützen zu
können
schutzkritische Infrastruktur ist
sicherlich einer der ganz wichtigen
Aufgaben des österreichischen
Bundesheers einfach weil es um das
alltägliche Leben der Österreicherinnen
und Österreicher geht da geht es um
Krankenhäuser es geht um
verkehrsnotenpunkte es geht um Einkaufen
es geht wenn man es ein bisschen
überspitzt formulieren möchte um es um
es überleben der Bevölkerung
[Musik]
zum schutzkritische Infrastruktur
braucht es nicht unbedingt das was man
sich jetzt als Angriffskrieg vorstellt
oder Landesverteidigung Österreichs es
kann auch viel viel früher eintreten
denkt man die covid-krise 2020 vor allem
denkt man aber auch an Naturkatastrophen
oder auch ein Terroranschläge
[Musik]
ich bin stolz dass ich als Milizsoldat
zur Sicherheit der Menschen in
Österreich beitragen kann
es ist die Familie es sind die Lieben
daheim es ist es ist unsere Kultur auf
die wir so stolz sind ja das ist zu
schützen das ist ja gar nicht mehr so
weit weg jetzt ja also Russland Ukraine
das ist diese paar hundert Kilometer
dann macht man sich natürlich Gedanken
die aktuellen Entwicklungen in der
Ukraine ist der Begriff Krieg viel
realer geworden wenn es denn so weit ist
werde ich schießen
ich habe keine moralischen oder
ethischen Probleme für Österreich die
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher da zu
sein und sie im Notfall auch zu
verteidigen
ich stehe jetzt hier direkt vor einem
Checkpoint mit Milizsoldaten also keine
Berufssoldaten sondern das sind alles
militsoldaten die im Ernstfall hier
Personen kontrollieren und notfalls auch
mit Waffengewalt aufhalten könnten und
bei mir steht eine wichtige
Persönlichkeit Frau Hauptmann Anna
Kaiser sie ist eigentlich gelernte
Kultur Schutz
kulturgüterschutzexpertin arbeitet an
der Universität in Krems wie wir es auch
im Beitrag gesehen haben und ist auch
bei europäischen Kulturprojekten dabei
und in ihrem
Privatleben sozusagen schlüpft sie in
Uniform und ist dann Kommandantin der
jägerkompanie in Tulln
Kulturgüterschutz auf der einen Seite
auf der anderen Seite Militär das klingt
nach einem Widerspruch wie geht sich das
beides aus
das geht sich wunderbar aus es passt
auch zusammen wenn man gerade an die
Ukraine jetzt denken oder militärische
Konflikte Afghanistan Syrien und
Kulturgüter ja auch zerstört wurden
absichtlich zerstört wurden das ist der
Bereich mit dem ich mich auch zivil an
der Universität in Krems beschäftige
also es passt wunderbar zusammen
Kulturgüterschutz zu Militär wie sind
Sie zum Bundesheer zum Miliz gekommen
tun sich ihrer Meinung nach Frauen beim
Bundesheer eher schwerer oder leichter
weil es eben sehr wenige nur gibt
ich würde mal sagen die
Herausforderungen körperliche Natur aber
auch psychischer Natur sind für Männer
wie Frauen gleich also es ist
herausfordernd man geht an die Grenzen
an die körperlichen an die psychischen
Grenzen da wird jetzt kein Unterschied
machen zwischen Männern und Frauen am
Ende zählt die Leistung dass man sich
den Herausforderungen stellt und dann
wird man akzeptiert das habe ich als
Offizier gemerkt das habe ich als
Kommandant gemerkt und deswegen kann ich
eigentlich jedem nur empfehlen eine
Karriere bei der Miliz anzustreben
Männer wie auch Frauen was konkret
können sie von ihrem Einsatz als
militsoldatin mitnehmen in das
Privatleben oder auch in ihren privaten
Beruf
ich war fünf Jahre lang
kompaniekommandanter jägerkompany Tulln
das ist eine Kompanie mit über 160
Soldaten das ist äquivalent zu einem
mittelständischen Betrieb also da war
ich auch als Manager quasi dann
gefordert als Kommandant als Manager und
da ist natürlich viel was ich mitnehmen
kann auch ins zivile jetzt ein
Organisation an Führungsstruktur an
Umgang mit Persönlichkeiten mit Menschen
es hilft natürlich auch zivil sehr viel
weiter jetzt gibt es immer wieder auch
den Wunsch dass bei der Miliz mehr geübt
wird sie stehen da mitten drinnen im
Leben glauben sie dass verpflichtende
milizübungen notwendig werden oder kommt
man mit dem System wie es jetzt ist auch
halbwegs durch
ist der Frage die ich jetzt nur
persönlich beantworten kann
ich würde mir wünschen dass mehr geübt
wird wenn nur wenn man übt dann kann man
auch das was man können soll im Ernst im
Ernstfall im Realfall das haben schon
die alten Römer so gesagt schönes you
fight hat damals auf Latein ich würde
das auch heute noch so sehen und
deswegen war ich immer sehr froh wenn
ich mit meiner Kompanie üben konnte und
ihr realistischer diese Übungen waren
desto besser für meine Soldaten aber
auch für mich vielen Dank Frau Hauptmann
und weiterhin gutes Gelingen mit ihrer
Kompanie dankeschön
vielen Dank Andreas mayer-busch vom
Heldenplatz ja der heutige Tag ist kein
Nationalfeiertag wie jeder andere es ist
der erste Nationalfeiertag einer
Zeitenwende vor genau 244 Tagen hat
Wladimir Putin den Krieg gegen die
Ukraine begonnen und die
Nachkriegsordnung in der wir es uns so
gemütlich gemacht haben pulverisiert
Millionen Menschen sind aus der Ukraine
geflüchtet zigtausende Tod oder verletzt
die Infrastruktur steht unter
Dauerbeschuss russischer Raketen ganze
Landstriche sind in Schutt und Asche
gelegt ein Abriss der Schrecken des
Krieges von Peter Welter
wer gibt den Takt an nach 244 Tagen
Krieg nach Tagen die in der Ukraine
alles verändert haben auch hier im
slowensk ganz im Osten auch in ludmilas
leben
wir kochen hier draußen mit Feuer seit
wir keinen Strom und kein Gas mehr haben
sie wird trainiert
das Heizkraftwerk der Region es ist von
Russen zerstört
ständig bekleidet sonst ist es zu kalt
die Stadt dobiansk im Donbass ist eines
der Hauptziele der russischen Armee
schon seit Kriegsbeginn
seit diesem Tag dem 24 Februar den
Beginn einer Invasion die aus russischer
Sicht alles in Frage stellt diese
varanitäts der Ukraine die Neuordnung
Europas nach 1991 der Kreml will wieder
als Großmacht den Ton angegeben
wer auch immer versucht uns aufzuhalten
sollte wissen dass russlandsreaktion
sofort erfolgen und zu solchen
Konsequenzen führen wird mit denen sie
in ihrer Geschichte noch nie
konfrontiert waren
die Atomwaffen Drohung wird zum
Psychoterror der sich abzunutzen scheint
und die Einnahme Kiews scheitert
Ende März bereits nach vier Wochen
konzentrieren sich russische Truppen auf
Gebietsgewinne im Osten und im Süden der
Ukraine zu diesem Zeitpunkt sind ein
Viertel aller Ukraine auf der Flucht
Mario pohlfeld im Juli dann luciansk im
Osten
die russische Armee kontrolliert nun 20%
des ukrainischen Staatsgebietes doch
dabei soll es nicht bleiben
[Musik]
wir werden zurückkehren dank unserer
Taktik dank der Waffen die wir bekommen
und genau das passiert Anfang September
dank der amerikanischen
internetsatelliten Aufklärung von ihren
Musk können die Ukraine die
Truppenbewegungen der Russen Orten dank
der Waffenlieferungen zu schlagen Städte
und Dörfer werden zurückerobert
eine erschöpfte russische Armee kommt
aus dem Takt und Putin muss retten was
ihm geblieben ist am 21 September mit
einer teilmobil-machung die er
ursprünglich selbst vermeiden wollte und
die zehntausende junge Russen zur Flucht
aus Russland bewegt
am 30 September mit der Annektion von
vier Gebieten nach Schein Referenten vor
dem Kreml Jubel hinter den Mauern gibt
es dazu wenig Grund wie lange ist dieser
Krieg für Russland durchzuhalten was
bringen diese Schläge gegen den
ukrainischen Energiesektor aussah das
vielleicht mehr Ukraine an die Flucht
Denken und die Kälte im Winter zur Qual
wird
für die Menschen die wie Ludmilla in
slobians bleiben oder auch für die
Soldaten die selbst nicht wissen was die
Zeit noch bringen wird
in den kommenden Jahren darf das
Bundesheer zwei Milliarden Euro für eine
dringend nötige Luftabwehr ausgeben mit
den flächendeckenden russischen
Luftangriffen auf dutzende Städte in der
Ukraine hat dieses Thema an Brisanz
deutlich dazu gewonnen die Nato hat
schon reagiert unter Federführung
Deutschlands wurde eine sogenannte
europeansky Shield Initiative gegründet
das neutrale Österreich ist bei diesem
schutzschirmprojekt nicht dabei was
Militärexperten Bedauern Klaus Bruckmann
berichtet
Luftalarm über dem nächtlichen Kiew
Drohnen sind im Anflug die Menschen
schrecken auf und flüchten in die Keller
das russische Fernsehen zeigt Bilder wie
Drohnen ukrainische Stellungen angreifen
doch die Drohnen aus Russland treffen
auch Wohngebiete bei Tageslicht ist
sichtbar was die Drohnen in Kiew von
anderen Städten angerichtet haben
gegen derartige Angriffe aus der Luft
planen 14 NATO-Staaten in Europa eine
sogenannte European Sky Shield
Initiative die Federführung für diesen
luftschirm hat Deutschland
die deutsche Verteidigungsministerin
lädt andere Staaten ein sich auch zu
beteiligen wir sind offen für jeden der
sich daran beteiligen möchte innerhalb
der NATO darum geht es
Österreicher ist nicht NATO-Mitglied ist
also nicht dabei doch von Staaten
umgeben die sich an der gemeinsamen Luft
Verteidigung beteiligen wollen
Robert Brieger war bis Mai
generalstabchef in Österreich und ist
nun Vorsitzender des EU
militärausschusses quasi also der Chef
aller Generalstabschefs in der EU die
europäischen Nationen haben in den
Jahrzehnten des relativen Friedens die
hinter uns liegen wie wir alle wissen
stark eingespart bei den Aufwendungen
für Verteidigung und Sicherheit und
daher gibt es hier einen riesigen
Nachholbedarf
eine Rakete nach Europa braucht aus
Russland nur 10 bis 15 Minuten
aus dem Iran 20 bis 25 Minuten
und aus Nordkorea 25 bis 30 Minuten eine
Abwehr muss daher sehr schnell erfolgen
es gibt verschiedene Systeme zur Auswahl
die in manchen Ländern wie den USA
Israel oder Polen schon im Einsatz sind
könnte das neutrale Österreich nicht
doch bei der nato-initiative mitmachen
Torten Arnold ist major im deutschen
Generalstab und Volkswirt wir haben
schon in anderen rüstungskooperationen
wie dem Eurofighter gesehen wo zum
Beispiel Österreich sich beteiligt hat
das heißt österreich könnte dazu nach
meinem Wertung ja und wer das was für
eine Rolle könnte Österreich das Spielen
alle starten um Österreich sind hier
dabei also im Endeffekt werden sehr
geschützt ohne dass du dabei sind ja sie
meine sogenannte freeriderprinzip aber
so wird kann man Sicherheit ja nicht
denken Sicherheit
setzt sich daraus zusammen dass jeder
seinen Beitrag leistet wir gemeinsam
vorgehen um uns so bestmöglich zu
schützen der frühere brigadierwalter
Feichtinger ist führender
Militärstratege er sieht kein Problem
mit der Neutralität ich würde den Zugang
über die EU suchen hier ist die
gemeinsame Verteidigung verankert auch
in den Gesetzen Österreich daher ist das
unproblematisch und wie weit dann die EU
mit der NATO kooperiert das ist eine
Sache die man sich gerne anschauen muss
aber vom grundsätzlichen her sehe ich
kein Problem dass ich Österreich an die
gemeinsamen europäischen sicherheits-
und Verteidigungspolitik voll inhaltlich
engagiert
die Ukraine kann die Luftangriffe aus
Russland derzeit nur teilweise abfangen
[Musik]
ein wirksamer luftschirm soll solche
Bilder von Europa fernhalten
[Musik]
und ganz andere Bilder sehen wir jetzt
vom Wiener Heldenplatz sehr Generalmajor
sehr beeindruckend was sind wir denn da
ja Gott sei Dank ganz andere Bilder wir
sehen hier jetzt die Anzug gelobenden
Rekruten über 1000 und das Besonderheit
heuer haben es jetzt kurz im Bild
gesehen in der Mitte dieses Blogs Fahnen
hier sind jetzt in den verschiedenen
Uniformen die die Rekruten
angetreten gewesen hier sehen wir jetzt
die flaggenhisse der Garde bei der
Vorbereitung dass dann wenn die
Ehrengäste eintretende unter den Herrn
Bundespräsident gemeldet wurde die
frankenparade durchgeführt werden kann
dieser Block mit den Fahnen in der Mitte
soll zum Ausdruck bringen dass die Miliz
integrierter Bestandteil des
österreichischen Bundesheeres ist und
nicht für sich allein steht sondern
integriert ein Teil des Bundesheeres ist
weil das Bundesheer ist ja ohne Miliz
nicht einsatzfähig wir haben da schon
jetzt einen Wandel hin dazu dass wir
auch so denken dass das Bundesheer ja in
Österreich zur Verteidigung Österreichs
eingesetzt werden muss und das
funktioniert nur nach Mobilmachung weil
nach einem 6 monatigen grundwirtinstag
dann hat auch gesehen dass selbst wie
für Corona aufgebiete aufgeboten wurde
eine Vorbereitungszeit der
Einsatzvorbereitung notwendig war und
das soll eben jetzt auch bei der
großaneelobung dargestellt werden
verfügt Österreich eigentlich gegenüber
genügend oder österreichische
bundessoldatinnen und Soldaten naja die
55.000 ist im Wesentlichen die Zahl die
zu erfüllen ist wir erfüllen die derzeit
schon es muss uns nur klar sein dass so
wie auch die Frau Hauptmann das ja klar
auf den Punkt gebracht hat dass nur der
etwas kann der auch etwas übt und wenn
man das mit einem Lehrberuf vergleicht
wo man sagt da sollte man drei Jahre
eine Lehre machen manche vier
und den soldatenberufler lernt man in
sechs Monaten muss eben klar sein dass
hier nur eine erste Fähigkeit gegeben
worden ist
um mal auf dem Gefechtsfeld dann auch zu
überleben muss man sich dann schon in
weiterer Folge auch noch ein bisschen
vorbereiten
kommen wir jetzt vielleicht noch zurück
zur Luftabwehr wo wir vor dem Beitrag
gesehen haben da hat Brigitte
Feichtinger in Beitrag gesagt dass es
wichtig wäre dass Österreich sich bei
dieser European Shield initiativ voll
inhaltlich engagiert wie sehen Sie denn
das nun European Sky Shield ist eine
Initiative die derzeit so beurteilt
werden kann dass sie doch innerhalb der
NATO den europäischen Pfeiler stärkt was
natürlich in Zusammenschau mit der
österreichischen Neutralität eine
gewisse Problemlage darstellt
andererseits muss man steht das Projekt
ja auch erst am Anfang und man muss
vielleicht die weitere politische
Wirkung militärische und wehrtechnische
Entwicklung abwarten wie und ob sich
hier Österreich entsprechend beteiligen
kann weil natürlich ein ungeschützter
Fleck in der Mitte ist auch nicht gut
für die Europäische Union aber am
Endeffekt kommt schon auch darauf an wer
in einem grünen Start der jetzt nicht
Mitglied der NATO commanderstruktur ist
dann im Endeffekt ein Feuerbefehl gibt
und das ist eine Sache die in Österreich
so lange wir uns so aufstellen wie wir
jetzt positioniert sind bei der
verbundungsministerin liegt und nicht in
einem NATO Kommando
Fragen kommen wir zurück zur Bedeutung
des heutigen Tages ja was bedeutet der
Nationalfeiertag eigentlich für die
parteichefinen und Parteichefs der
Parlamentsparteien wir haben bereits
darüber gesprochen gerade ein
anbetrachtes andauernden Krieges
Russlands gegen die Ukraine spielt die
Positionierung Österreichs auch eine
Rolle ist die Neutralität noch zeitgemäß
gehört sie abgeschafft oder sind wir
längst nicht mehr neutral wir haben
darüber mit Neos Chefin Beate mein
Reisinger der Clubchef in der grünen
Sigrid Maurer FPÖ-Chef Herbert Kickl und
spö-chefin Pamela rendi Wagner
gesprochen
[Musik]
wir wünschen allen Österreicherinnen und
Österreichern sowie den Anzug
gelungenenden Rekruten einen schönen
Nationalfeiertag und viel Soldaten
glücklich
Informationen der Garde
Fahnen Trupps und Abordnungen der
milizverbände
anzugehen
auf 9 Kommando
das ganze
dieser Abfangjäger im Bundesheer es soll
ja jetzt der Schritt gemacht werden die
Eurofighter auch für den Einsatz in der
Nacht tauglich zu machen und das
nachzuziehen
ein sehr leistungsfähiges Kampfflugzeug
das schon
kurz zu aufgrund der tiefen wollten
Untergrenze werden sie die Flieger aber
wohl nur hören können
ja das was wir schon vermutet haben wir
warten noch die Flieger also die kommen
aus Zeltweg
wir haben die im Einsatz des Abfangjäger
um Luftraumverletzungen abwerten zu
können bzw denen begegnern zu können
auch aus aktives in der Hand zu haben
also Republik und nicht nur über Rad
dazu zu sehen wie jemand über unseren
Luftraum überfliegt das passiert über
100 Mal pro Jahr
[Musik]
einen wunderschönen Vormittag nicht zu
sehen nur zu hören
also zu die die Eurofighter der abfangen
die 130 die große Transportmaschine die
ist ein bisschen auch unsere Nabelschnur
zu den auslandskontingen könnten zum
Beispiel im Libanon oder am Balkan wo
wir immer wieder Versorgungsflüge
durchführen wir haben auch eine
Möglichkeit
Schwerverletzte mit einem
sanitätscontainer
stabil zu evakuieren also das sind schon
Vorteile die so eine große
Transportmaschine bringt sie müssen sie
aber vorstellen diese Geräte sind so alt
wie ich also jetzt wird es Zeit dass sie
schon langsam auch abgelöst wird
abgelöst werden das heißt Baujahr 67 68
sollte dann irgendwann einmal durch neue
Maschinen abgelöst werden jedenfalls vor
Ende des jetzigen Jahrzehnts je
schneller desto besser wenn natürlich
älter so ein Flugzeug wird desto mehr
ist wodurch die aus der abgelöst werden
eine Typenauswahl ist dann auch nicht
getroffen sondern das läuft jetzt dann
an aber von der Leistungsfähigkeit
wollen wir in dem Segment bleiben wo
jetzt die Herkules wird aber
wahrscheinlich wieder eine langwierige
Entscheidung werden ich hoffe nicht dass
wir hier langwierige Entscheidungen
treffen üblicherweise wenn man das
militärische hinbekommen da das
natürlich auch viel Geld kostet wird die
eine oder andere Diskussion darüber
geben aber aus unserer Sicht ist es
unverzichtbares Mittel auch für den
Transport das muss man sagen innerhalb
von Österreich sehr gut geeignet wir
setzen daraus auch das Jagdkommando mit
Fallschirm ab also das ist nicht nur für
den Auslandseinsatz sondern auch zu
Hause recht gut brauchbar apropos
langwierig der Eurofighter wie lang ist
der noch im Einsatz
wenn er jetzt diese
tatsächlich Kampfwertsteigerung also
nachteinsatzfähigkeit hergestellt wird
wir gehen davon aus dass wir jedenfalls
bis Mitte der 2030er Jahre weiter
geflogen werden kann
alles andere ist derzeit nicht absehbar
das war der Überflug der Eurofighter und
des C130 die wir leider nur gehört nicht
gesehen haben über die Wiener Innenstadt
und wir nähern uns mit großen Schritten
dem Höhepunkt dieser heutigen
Veranstaltung der Angelobung der
Rekruten
an der Zahl
ja sehr viele Menschen wieder am
Heldenplatz die Rekruten warten schon
was was passiert denn da jetzt in den
nächsten Minuten also das nächste was
wir sehen werden ist die Meldung an den
Herrn Bundespräsidenten wir hören das
ankündigungssignal
[Musik]
Bundespräsidenten das ganze recht
wir haben jetzt ein Bild gehabt den
oberstreisner der derzeit der Kommandant
der Garde ist
Herr Bundespräsident oberstreisner
meldet eine Ehrenformation der Garde
fahnetrupps und Abholungen der
milizverbände
2025 Rekruten zur feierlichen Angelobung
[Musik]
so und jetzt wird durch die
durch den höchstanwesenden den Herrn
Bundespräsidenten die beim Bundeskanzler
die Frau Bundesministerin und den Kanal
stoppschiffen der ersten Reihe dahinter
der Vizekanzler der Bürgermeister von
Wien und der Militärkommandant von Wien
sowie der attetante sind
Bundespräsidenten die Front abgestritten
das dauert natürlich wenn hier so eine
große Ehrenformation steht etwas länger
[Musik]
wir haben wieder die
erbbietung vor der Fahne der Garde
[Musik]
und jetzt schaltet der Bundespräsident
die Front ab wir sehen wieder schön die
Soldaten der vierten gare Kompanie
wir haben wie möglich bei der Meldung
gehört am 1025 Rekruten die angelobt
werden es sind auch zwei
weibliche Soldaten darunter eine aus der
Gardemusik und eine die
bei der Garde eingerückt ist
[Musik]
woher kommen die Rekruten wir haben
einerseits Kontingente der Garde hier
jetzt der fahnenblock
der Miliz
die in der Mitte der Anzug gelungenen
aufgestellt sind
dann haben wir das weiteren Soldaten des
Panzer generierts 13 und der
Luftunterstützung das sind aus
Oberösterreich angereist das bb3
Pionierbataillon 3 aus Melk
Soldaten die bei mir abkommando
eingerückt sind wir haben jetzt gesehen
eine unterschiedliche Kopfbedeckung die
haben ein sogenanntes schifferlaufgesetz
gehabt und nicht wie die anderen
Soldaten das bereit und alle haben im
Endeffekt das Sturmgewehr um die Brust
[Musik]
Stelle gegangen und ja genau
100 in Repräsentanz quasi für die
restlichen Soldaten des Bundesheeres
hier bei der Angelobung dabei haben
können
[Musik]
meldet sich ab
und die Ehrengäste gehen auf Ihre
Plätze zurück
es wird ja im Rahmen der heurigen
Angelobung auch eine Besonderheit geben
nicht nur dass die Miliz eingetreten ist
mit den Fahnen sondern dass auch der
milize-wort übergeben wird wir werden
das dann sehen
das erfolgt an die Wirtschaftskammer
Österreich
durch die höchsten Repräsentanten der
Stadt genau
vor dem
Oberbefehlshaber sind die Fahnen
[Musik]
gesenkt
gesehen wäre höchste Repräsentanten aus
der Regierung
Ost aus dem Parlament und auch eine
Reihe ausländischer militärische ist die
da der Einladung
gefolgt sind den Nationalfeiertag
beizubringen und Militärbischof
dass man auch gut erkennen kann ist das
jetzt sehr schön langsam aber sicher die
neue Uniform auch ins Bundesheer kommt
also Teile sind bereits mit dem neuen
Tarnanzug ausgestattet
Teile noch in der bewährten grünen
Uniform zu sehen
[Musik]
das ganze recht so
diese Flaggenparade Teil des politischen
also das Protokolls warum wird das
gemacht
es wird im Endeffekt bei so einem Akt
die Staatsflagge hochgezogen man sieht
es ja es ist rot-weiß-rot mit dem Adler
um auch ganz klar dieses Symbol des
Staates hier in den Mittelpunkt zu
stellen und die meinen eigenen Platz
einzuräumen
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren ist Erfolg meine
Damen und Herren es erfolgt nun die
Begrüßung durch die Militärkommandanten
von Wien Herrn brigadierminister Kurt
Wagner im Anschluss hören Sie die
Ansprache des Bürgermeisters und
Landeshauptmannes von Wien Herr Dr
Michael Ludwig danach Herr Bürger Hans
Bürger wir konnten ja wir haben vorhin
leider nicht die Zeit gefunden um um die
Aussagen der Parlamentsparteien der
Vertreter der Parlamentspartei noch zu
diskutieren da ging es viel um
Neutralität haben wir recht
unterschiedliche Meinungen gehört wie
kann man denn das alles einordnen
interessant dass die Neutralität
offensichtlich als als
wichtigstes oder eines der wichtigsten
Güter in Österreich von allen Parteien
betont wird auch wenn die Neos da sie
weiterentwickeln wollen grundsätzlich
traut sich da sage ich jetzt einmal
niemand dran an diese Neutralität das
war in Österreich nicht immer so man hat
die NATO diskutiert einen NATO-Beitritt
das ist noch gar nicht so lange her Ende
des letzten Jahrhunderts ja warum ist
das so weil wir haben es gesagt 71% der
Österreicher und Österreicher
und aller die hier sind sagen die
Neutralität brauchen wir ich frage mich
nur wenn die Sicherheitsbedrohung
geografisch näher rücken würde ob das
dann auch so ist ich glaube dass der
Satz des Bundeskanzlers darüber reden
wir nicht auch nicht aufrechterhaltbar
ist also ich denke schon dass
Militärstrategen und einige andere und
Politologen und wer auch immer und
Europa Experten
diese Diskussion von selbst anstoßen
werden und sie ist glaube ich
unvermeidbar denn wenn das
Bedrohungsszenario ein anderes ist dann
wird man darüber reden müssen welche
Aufgaben hat man und weil wir auch
zuerst kurz üben Vorgespräch dazwischen
über die Gast gesprochen haben die
gemeinsame Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik
der Europäischen Union naja wenn fast
alle bei der NATO sind einer übrig sich
das das heißt man muss die sicher auch
Sicherheitsarchitektur auf diesem
Kontinent neu diskutieren und wie die
drei verbliebenen neutralen Staaten das
handhaben das wage ich nicht zu
beurteilen ob das immer so bleiben wird
wisst derzeit ist vor allem hat sich
auch die Neutralität ein wenig verändert
spätestens auch seit dem EU-Beitritt
also das die Neutralität ist ja nicht
mehr dieselbe Neutralität wie vor 30
Jahren ja wir hätten sogar eine
Beistandspflicht auch auch aufgrund der
europäischen Verträge erstmals eben mit
dem EU Beitritt und dann gibt es das
habe ich schon gesagt für uns immer die
Möglichkeit das sogenannten
konstruktiven stimmenhaltung das heißt
wir können immer sagen wir dulden das
was die Europäische Union macht aber wir
tun nicht mit und ob dieser Standpunkt
durchhaltbar ist über eine über einen
längeren Zeitraum das das sage ich
wirklich zu bezweifeln
genug stimmt das
naja das die Frage ist wie definieren
wir uns der generalmaierhofbau hat sich
schon gesagt gerade wenn wir neutral
sind müssen wir ja das Bundesheer noch
viel stärker ausrüsten und müssen
eigentlich noch viel wehrhafter werden
denken wir an die Schweiz aber da will
ich nicht vorgreifen also ich denke ob
das jetzt genügt was wir derzeit machen
diese schrittweise Entwicklung bis 2027
das weiß ich nicht und wenn sie sagt mir
wir müssen wehrhafter werden dann klingt
das politische sehr gut aber da muss ich
schon sagen was sie damit auch meint ja
noch mehr Geld fürs Bundesheer oder
nicht oder oder doch NATO also was sie
da genau meint weiß ich nicht
gibt es genug Geld fürs Bundesheer
das ist natürlich eine Frage die dich
diplomatisch beantworten möchte es gibt
jetzt
in der nächsten vier Jahren 16
Milliarden für das Bundesheer das ist
mehr als wir an und für sich erwartet
haben das muss ich auch sagen und wenn
wir auf dem 1,5% bleiben wird es uns
dazu befähigen dass wir ein ordentliches
Bundesheer ausrüsten ordentlich
ausbilden können eine vernünftige
Infrastruktur
[Musik]
wie sich die Entwicklung dann bei der
Bedrohung und das Risiko für Österreich
gestaltet das wird man weiterhin
betrachten müssen weil natürlich wird
man hier nur erste Schritte bis 2032
gehen können gerade wenn es zum Beispiel
über Fragen der Lust hat der
unterbrechen denn am Heldenplatz starten
jetzt die Reden der politischen
Vertreter den Anfang macht gemäß den
Protokoll der Wiener Bürgermeister
Michael Ludwig von der SPÖ zu
gratulieren zur kürzlichen Wiederwahl
den gerade in sehr schwierigen und
komplexen Zeiten in denen wir uns
befinden ist Berechenbarkeit und
Stabilität in der österreichischen aber
auch in der internationalen Politik ganz
wichtig
sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler Werte
Mitglieder der Bundesregierung des
Nationalrates des Bundesrates des
Landtags Würdenträger meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren es ist mir
eine besondere Ehre dass ich sie als
Bürgermeister und Landeshauptmann von
Wien hier im Zentrum der
Bundeshauptstadt begrüßen darf mehr als
1.000 Präsenzdiener die jetzt ihren
Dienst antreten beginnen gemeinsam mit
Familienangehörigen Freundinnen und
Freunden
und wenn man die komplexe Situation in
der wir uns befinden beschreiben muss
mit einem Wort dann mit dem Wort
Zeitenwende
das ist eine Krieg gibt in Europa hätten
wir uns vor einigen Jahren nicht
vorstellen wollen und können und das die
Europäische Union das größte
Friedensprojekt dass es je auf unseren
Kontinent gegeben hat hier eine
besondere Verantwortung eine besondere
Herausforderung hat ist evident auch um
mit den wirtschaftlichen Auswirkungen
dieses Krieges dieser militärischen
Intervention Russlands in der Ukraine
umzugehen
und es ist ein wichtiger Meilenstein das
gerade in dieser schwierigen Zeit Europa
gemeinsam auftritt
beispielsweise auch um den
Wirtschaftsstandort Europa zu stärken
gemeinsam am Energiemarkt einzukaufen
und deutlich zu machen dass man an einem
Strang zieht
und das ist mit ein Grund das bereits
die Gaspreise fallen den Europa ist
stärker als dass manche glauben und es
ist jetzt ein Entscheidung auch darüber
zu befinden wie wir
als Kontinent wie wir aus Europäische
Union in Zukunft wahrgenommen werden
wollen im internationalen Wettbewerb im
Wettbewerb großer
großer auch internationaler komplexer
Organisationen die durchaus auch die
nationalen Grenzen beeinträchtigen
von daher meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren ist diese
Zeitwende diese Zäsur in der
internationalen Politik etwas was wir in
Österreich auch besonders wahrnehmen und
wir sehen uns nach Frieden
und Frieden ist nicht alles aber ohne
Frieden ist alles nichts dieses Zitat
vom früheren deutschen
Bundeskanzler Willy Brandt
charakterisiert sehr gut und stark was
uns auch heute berührt wir sind in Wien
eine Friedensstadt wir sind eine Stadt
mit mehr als 40
internationalen Organisationen die bei
uns beheimatet sind von der UNO über die
oscd bis zur OPEC und der
Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde das wollen wir auch
nutzen eine Friedensstadt zu sein in
einem neutralen Österreich und der Grund
für den heutigen nationalfeiertag ist
der Umstand dass der Nationalrat
beschlossen hat am 26 oktober 1955 ein
Bundesgesetz dass die immerwährende
Neutralität festschreibt eine
völkerrechtliche Vereinbarung die wir
eingegangen sind und die wir auch heute
leben wollen
wir sind
militärischneutral aber nicht neutral
wenn es darum geht Menschlichkeit zu
üben es sind derzeit rund 25.000
Menschen aus der Ukraine in Wien die wir
hier betreuen
4.100 Kinder die wir in den regulären
Schulbetrieb integriert haben
und das ist auch etwas Typisches für das
österreichische Bundesheer in diesen
schwierigen Situationen zu helfen und
das von Beginn an bereits ein Jahr nach
der Gründung des österreichischen
Bundesheeres im 1956
mussten die Soldaten an der
österreichischen ungarischen Grenze des
Souveränität unseres Landes vertreten
aber auch einzutreten für die Demokratie
in Österreich und 1968 sind wieder
panzergerollt in einem Nachbarland in
der ehemaligen Tschechoslowakei
in den 90er Jahren war es der
jugoslawische Bürgerkrieg der deutlich
gemacht hat das durchaus anderen
österreichischen Grenzen auch
militärische
Möglichkeiten notwendig sind und zum
Einsatz kommen sollen
das österreichische Bundeswehr genießt
deshalb ein hohes Vertrauen in der
Bevölkerung und wenn man sich den
Vertrauensindex ansieht wo
unterschiedliche Organisationen
Institutionen bewertet werden liegt das
österreichische Bundesheer immer sehr
gut weil die Menschen sehen hier hat es
im Laufe der Zeit auch viele
Veränderungen gegeben und Vertrauen ist
etwas was in der Politik was in der
Demokratie ganz wichtig ist wenn
Vertrauen verloren geht dann muss ich
Politik und Verwaltung sehr intensiv
bemühen dieses Vertrauen in der
Bevölkerung wieder zu erlangen das ist
eine Grundvoraussetzung auch für die
Demokratie und dass die Menschen auch
sehr transparent wahrnehmen wie
politische Entscheidungen getroffen
werden
das österreichische Bundesheer hat einen
solchen Weg gemacht über viele Jahre und
Jahrzehnte das österreichische
Bundesheer heute ist anders als vor
Jahren und Jahrzehnten und damit meine
ich nicht Ausrüstung und Gerät sondern
vor allem auch den Umgang der Menschen
im Bundesheer hier ist sehr viel
positive andere Formen geschehen und
deshalb
danke ich dem österreichischen
Bundesheer ich danke dem
berufssoldatinnen und Berufssoldaten ich
danke den Präsenz Dienern und ich danke
den Mitgliedern der Miliz
und vielleicht können wir auch heute als
politisch Verantwortliche gemeinsam ein
bisschen darüber nachdenken wie wir jene
die bereits sind in der Miliz zu dienen
und oft berufliche familiäre Nachteile
auf sich nehmen um sich für die
Allgemeinheit einzusetzen ob es uns da
nicht gelingt da auch auf Seite der
Politik Möglichkeiten zu finden diese
die in der Medizinern auch entsprechend
finanziell zu unterstützen
denn ich höre immer wieder das ist immer
schwieriger wird freigestellt zu werden
nicht nur in der Privatwirtschaft auch
im öffentlichen Dienst für jene die in
der Miliz tätig sein wollen und ich
denke dass das auch für uns eine
gemeinsame politische Herausforderung
sein kann hier gemeinsam Lösungen zu
finden
ich danke dem österreichischen
Bundesheer auch für die Bewachung der
kritischen Infrastruktur auch in unserer
Stadt ich danke der Mitgliedern des
österreichischen Bundesheeres dafür dass
sie in internationalen Einsätzen im
Rahmen der UNO tätig sind und sich für
den Weltfrieden damit auch einsetzen
ich danke auch für die gemeinsamen
Aktivitäten die das Ministerium und das
Bundesheer gemeinsam mit der Stadt Wien
im Rahmen der corona-krise und der
corona-pandemie gesetzt haben und ich
danke vor allem auch in der Kooperation
statt Wien
Feuerwehren vor Ort und dem
österreichischen bundesheeren der
Bekämpfung des größten Waldbrandes der
es in den letzten Jahrzehnten gegeben
hat
als ich vor 40 Jahren
angelobt worden bin hat mich diese
Zeremonie sehr berührt
und ich hoffe sie auch geschätzte
präsenzdienerinnen und Präsenzdiener
nehmen die Wertschätzung war dienen die
Republik Österreich heute entgegenbringt
wir sind stolz auf sie und diesen Stolz
teilen wir mit ihren Familienangehörigen
mit ihren Freundinnen und Freunden wir
sind stolz dass sie die Uniform
angezogen haben dass Sie sich für unser
Land einsetzen dass sie bereit sind auch
in schwierigen Zeiten zu unserem Land zu
stehen und von daher wünsche ich Ihnen
eine interessante unfallfreie Zeit beim
österreichischen Bundesheer die
Gelegenheit Freundschaften zu schließen
und Kameradschaft zu erleben und vieles
mitzunehmen für einen weiteren Lebensweg
in diesem Sinne wünsche ich Ihnen alles
Gute ein herzliches Glück auf es lebe
das österreichische Bundesheer es lebe
unser Heimatland die Republik Österreich
es lebe ein gemeinsames und friedliches
Europa
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es erfolgt nun die Ansprache der von
Bundesminister für Landesverteidigung
Magister Claudia Tanner danach die
Verleihung des minitauers im Beisein des
Herrn Bundespräsidenten des
Bundeskanzlers des Vizekanzlers des Chef
des Generalstabes durch die Frau
Bundesminister und dem Miliz
beauftragten generalmy hammeseder an den
Generalsekretär der Wirtschaftskammer
Österreich Abgeordneten zum Nationalrat
Karl Heinz Kopf
hohe Geistlichkeit und kirchliche
Würdenträger
sehr geehrter Herr Bundespräsident sehr
geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler Herr
wietze-kanzler geschätzter
ministerkolleginnen und Kollegen
Frau Präsidentinnen sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren Abgeordnete sehr geehrter
Herr Bürgermeister Herr generalstoffchef
Werte Generalität sehr geehrte
Kommandanten
Soldatinnen Soldaten und
Zivilbedienstete vor allem heute aber
Damen und Herren Rekruten
die Welt ist im Umbruch
der 24 Februar 2022 stellt eine Zäsur da
eine Zäsur in der Geschichte und das
weltweit
geopolitische normenstrategien und
Glaubenssätze wurden an diesem Tag
binnen Stunden obsolet
alle Nationen dieser Erde mussten in
Folge ihre Politik neu ordnen
und so auch die Staaten der Europäischen
Union
und auch wir sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren wir müssen uns neu orientieren
denn und das gilt es gerade heute zu
betonen
die immerwährende Neutralität
die ist ein hohes Gut aber und das steht
fest sie schützt uns nicht vor Hybriden
Angriffen vor Terra und anderem
Bedrohungen das neutralitätsgesetz
schützt unser Land nicht aber
unser Herr tut es
und es schützt auch unsere Neutralität
denn die gilt es zu verteidigen
die historische Trendwende dieses
februar-tages die hat dazu geführt dass
wir unser Herr völlig neu denken müssen
und die Weichen neu stellen mussten
in den vergangenen Jahren haben unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten unglaubliches
geleistet wenn sie nur an die unzähligen
Naturkatastrophen an die corona-pandemie
denken bei der unser Herr alles getan
und gegeben hat um zu helfen
das war wichtig das war wichtig für
Österreich und somit für uns alle
doch nun müssen wir wieder verstehen
dass das eine Nebenaufgabe ist die
Hauptaufgabe die ist es unser Land mit
der Waffe zu verteidigen als Soldatinnen
und als Soldaten und sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren ich erlaube mir heute hier
eines einzufordern
der Beruf der Soldatin oder des Soldaten
der unterscheidet sich fundamental
fundamental von allen anderen Jobs denn
es gibt keinen anderen Beruf der im
Ernstfall erfordert bis zur ultimativen
Konsequenz also dem Einsatz des eigenen
Lebens zu gehen
ich fordere daher sie alle die
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher auf
sollen sie unseren Soldatinnen und
Soldaten Respekt wenn sie sie treffen
sollen sie ihnen Anerkennung das haben
sie verdient denn sie sind bereit für
Sie alles zu geben
am Beginn meiner Amtszeit vor beinahe
drei Jahren habe ich gesagt dass ich
nicht die oberste Soldatin sein kann und
auch nicht sein will das ist nicht meine
Aufgabe meine Aufgabe ist etwas anderes
das ist es für die Frauen und Männer die
bereit sind unser Land zu verteidigen
die entsprechenden Rahmenbedingungen zu
schaffen damit Sie genau das tun können
und das mache ich das machen wir als
Bundesregierung in den letzten drei
Jahren haben wir das heeresbudget drei
Mal erhöht und historische Höchststände
erreicht und nun ist es ein unglaublich
wichtiger Schritt der gelungen ist im
Miteinander mit dem neuen Budgetpfad
denn wir nun einschlagen erreichen wir
nie da gewesene Mittel für unser Herr
allein nächstes Jahr steigt unser Budget
um 680 Millionen Euro wir halten 16
Milliarden in den kommenden vier Jahren
und mit dem noch zu beschließenden
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
sagen wir auch dafür dass Budget weiter
steigt und so wird erstmalig in der
Geschichte unser Budget dann auf zehn
Jahre abgesichert sein werden das meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren das ist
historisch
und mit diesen Mitteln mit diesen
Mitteln werden wir investieren in die
Mobilität in den Schutz und in die
Wirkung unserer Soldatinnen und Soldaten
natürlich auch in die Infrastruktur
unseres Heeres das aber nicht zum selbst
Zweck sondern um sie zu schützen und
wenn ich vorhin sagte dass wir unser
Herr neu denken müssen da meine ich das
ernst Schutz und Hilfe sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren das war das Gerät
unseres Lehrers in den vergangenen
Jahren das gilt es nun weiter zu
entwickeln ich rufe daher heute hier die
Mission vorwärts aus diese Mission ist
keine
oberflächenkosmetik oder die hundertste
minimalreform nein mit dieser Mission
vorwärts werden wir uns daher modern und
kampffähig machen modern in all seinen
Facetten von der Infrastruktur über die
Ausrüstung bis hin zu den Fahrzeugen um
kampffähig zu jeder Zeit zu sein gegen
jede Bedrohung und heute sind sie alle
meine zeigen so war mir Gott helfe ich
werde ich mich erst dann zufrieden geben
wenn wir diese Mission vorwärts
erfolgreich beendet haben und Österreich
durch ein modernes durch ein
kampffähiges Bundesheer geschützt sein
wird das ist mein Versprechen am
heutigen Tag
aber nun zu Ihnen sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Rekruten
wenn ich hier und heute von der Mission
vorwärts spreche dann ist das nicht
unsere Mission oder meine Mission das
schon gar nicht nein das ist vor allem
ihre sie werden mit ihrem Dienst beim
Bundesheer wesentliche Schritte der
Erneuerung mittragen und mitermöglichen
denn die Entwicklungen zu einem modernen
zu einem kampffähigen Bundesheer das ist
eine Entwicklung die von ihnen her
passieren muss ich möchte Ihnen daher
danken danke dass Sie sich bereits
erklärt haben unser Land mit der Waffe
zu verteidigen einen Stück des Weges mit
uns gemeinsam zu gehen und ich darf mich
mit Ihnen gemeinsam über einen
politischen Erfolg freuen vergangene
Woche haben wir im Ministerrat einen
sehr wichtigen Beschluss gefasst nämlich
die Erhöhung der Besoldung der
Grundwehrdiener die in Wahrheit seit
beinahe 10 erste wirkliche Erhöhung ich
glaube das ist ein wichtiger Schritt in
die richtige Richtung mit dem wir uns
aber nicht zufrieden geben dürfen daher
Bürgermeister hat auch schon einiges
angesprochen ich werde mich auch
weiterhin dafür ersetzen das an allen
anderen Berufsgruppen die Unteroffiziere
Offiziere die Zivilbediensteten meines
Ressorts eine bessere Bezahlung erhalten
denn sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Sicherheit
das muss uns etwas wert sein
insbesondere die Menschen die sie
gewährleisten müssen uns etwas wert sein
abschließend sehr geehrte
Grundwehrdiener ein Auftrag und ein
Wunsch der Auftrag der Laute dich
erwarte vollen Einsatz Gehorsam
gegenüber ihren Vorgesetzten und die
Bereitschaft mehr zu tun als ihre
Pflicht sie sind Soldatinnen und
Soldaten der Republik Österreich seien
Sie stolz darauf und leben sie
Kameradschaft
zur bitte
genießen Sie die Zeit bei unserem Herr
die Abenteuer und das Miteinander hier
werden Sie lernen das Freundschaft das
eine ist aber Kameradschaft noch viel
viel mehr bedeutet ich danke ihnen ich
danke ihnen für ihren Dienst und hoffe
dass sehr viele von ihnen unseren
Bundesheer erhalten bleiben wir brauchen
Menschen wie sie österreich braucht sie
es lebe das österreichische Bundesheer
es lebe die Republik Österreich
[Applaus]
der milizerwort der so jetzt eben
verliehen wird ist die höchste
Auszeichnung des österreichischen
Bundesheeres für Personen Unternehmen
und Organisationen die sich um unsere
Milizsystem verbindt gemacht haben die
Nominierung für diesen Award kann durch
berufs-system bei österreichischen
Arbeitgebern flächendeckend anerkannt
wird und dass die besonderen Kompetenzen
von milizsoldatinnen und Soldaten vor
allem hinsichtlich moderne
Führungsausbildung anerkannt wird
[Musik]
ich ersuche nun Bundeskanzler Karl
nehammer um seine Ansprache der
nachspielt die Gardemusik den Marsch oh
du mein Österreich
sehr geehrter Herr Bundespräsident
sehr geehrte Ehrengäste
Liebe Soldatinnen und Soldaten
und da ich selbst noch Milizsoldat bin
Liebe Kameradinnen und Kameraden und vor
allem
liebe Angehörige da heute anzugelobenen
Familie Freundinnen Freund
Ehefrauen
alle die heute hierhergekommen sind
um bei diesem Tag dabei zu sein
und der ist tatsächlich etwas Besonderes
es ist euer es ist ihr Tag
es ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit wie
wir schon gehört haben heute
der Republik zu dienen
es ist keine Selbstverständlichkeit
ihr so zu dienen dass man bereit ist
auch seine eigene Gesundheit auf Spiel
zu setzen um den Auftrag zu erfüllen und
dieser Auftrag leistet Sicherheit für
dieses Land für die Menschen in diesem
Land zu gewährleisten
meine Angelobung ist 30 Jahre her
aber das Interessante an dieser
Jahreszahl ist nicht dieses Fakt sondern
da hatten wir an unseren Grenzen auch
wieder Krieg
der Zerfall des ehemaligen Jugoslawiens
direkt an unserer Grenze
hat seit vielen Jahrzehnten damals
wieder einen Einsatz des Bundesheeres
erfordert
Rekruten waren da im Einsatz gemeinsam
mit Berufssoldaten und haben unsere
Grenzen gesichert
und heute
30 Jahre später
herrscht wieder Krieg in Europa diesmal
ein invasionskrieg von Seiten der
Russischen Föderation gegen die Ukraine
unendlich vielleicht
Vertreibung
Tod
all das
erfahren jetzt gerade die Menschen im
Kriegsgebiet
und einmal mehr in einer unglaublichen
dramatischen Art und Weise hat der Krieg
gezeigt und zeigt dann noch wie wichtig
es ist
in der Lage zu sein sich auch selbst zu
verteidigen
militärische Landesverteidigung
viele Jahre vernachlässigt
und ich sage allen nein danke
dieser in dieser besonders fordernden
Zeit
durchgehalten haben nicht aufgegeben
haben an das geglaubt haben was uns alle
vereint nämlich dass es wert ist und
wertvoll ist für die Republik zu dienen
und
diese Bundesregierung und das ist mein
Versprechen an sie
hat ihre Lektion gelernt
die Erhöhung des Verteidigungsbudgets
dass die Frau Bundesministerin
angesprochen hat und wofür sie
leidenschaftlich gekämpft hat seitdem
sie Ministerin ist
wird dazu führen dass dieses Land
sicherer wird
sie wird aber auch dazu führen
diese Erhöhung dass sie sicherer besser
ausgerüstet
ihren Dienst leisten können
das ist wichtig
und richtig
und wir haben uns für zwei große Blöcke
in diesem Budget entschlossen nicht nur
im Verteidigungsbudget sondern im Budget
für diese Republik das eine ist das
sicherheitsbudget zu erhöhen
und das andere ist die Zukunft zu
gestalten die Transformation einzuleiten
Freiheit und Unabhängigkeit
dadurch zu verteidigen und zu erhalten
und auszubauen indem wir auch
unabhängiger werden von fossilen
Energieträgern und damit den Weg in die
Zukunft schaffen und die Industrie und
die Unternehmen auf diesem Weg begleiten
es gibt in dieser Frage viel zu tun
und ein Begriff der in der Verfassung
steht und auch über viele Jahre in den
Hintergrund getreten es ist jetzt
wichtiger denn je
die umfassende Landesverteidigung
sie beinhaltet die militärische
Landesverteidigung
unmittelbar den Dienst den sie leisten
und viele ihrer Kameradinnen und
Kameraden derzeit im Ausland wie im
Inland
und auch hier
spielt die Miliz
die BürgerInnen und bürgersoldaten des
österreichischen Bundesheers eine große
und bedeutende Rolle damit sowohl die
Einsätze im Inland wie im Ausland
möglich sind das ist der Dank den sie
verdienen wenn sie sich da engagieren
über das normale Maß hinaus die
militärische Landesverteidigung
die geistige Landesverteidigung ein
Begriff den wir schon lange nicht mehr
gehört haben der so wichtig ist in
dieser Zeit denn er macht klar dass man
wissen muss wofür man kämpft
das Werte nicht nur Worte oder
gedrucktes Papier darstellen wo man sie
liest oder wo sie ausgesprochen werden
sondern das Werte es im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes wert sind verteidigt zu
werden
Demokratie
Rechtsstaatlichkeit freie
Meinungsäußerung
Versammlungsfreiheit das ist das wofür
Sie heute hier stehen hier Gelöbnis
ableisten und dafür sage ich als
Bundeskanzler aber auch als Bürger
dieses Landes ein großes Danke an sie
alle für den Dienst den die zukünftig
leisten werden aber die umfassende
Landesverteidigung ist noch mehr
sie umfasst die wirtschaftliche
Landesverteidigung das ist das wovon ich
vorher gesprochen habe unabhängiger zu
werden das Land in die Zukunft zu führen
nicht erpressbar zu sein die Wirtschaft
so aufzustellen dass weder ein
quergestelltes Containerschiff im
Suezkanal noch irgendein Diktator der
auf die Idee kommt uns das Gas
abzudrehen und damit erpressen kann
daran arbeiten wir das ist ein
umfassender Begriff das ist ein
gesellschaftlicher Auftrag und es ist
vor allem auch ein Auftrag an uns alle
den Demokratie zeichnet sich dadurch aus
indem sie wehrhaft ist
indem sie Sicherheit
gewährleistet denn Sicherheit bedeutet
immer auch Freiheit
und die zivile Landesverteidigung
die ist die die uns immer und jederzeit
betreffen kann
sei es bei einem atomaren Störfall sei
es bei einer großen Naturkatastrophe sei
es bei einem blackout-szenario auch
daran und darauf gilt es sich
vorzubereiten die zivilschutzverbände in
diesem Land leisten hier eine gute und
wichtige Arbeit und auch dafür ein
großes Danke lassen Sie uns gemeinsam an
der Sicherheit dieses Landes bauen und
alle die hier sind heute auf diesem
Platz
fühlen Sie sich angesprochen
umfassende Landesverteidigung das sind
wir das sind wir als Gesellschaft
und noch ein persönlicher Punkt
spreche jetzt ganz bewusst die
Kameradinnen und Kameraden der Milizen
auch wir haben gemeinsam schon leichtere
Zeiten erlebt
und dieses Versprechen der
Bundesregierung ist den Stellenwert der
Miliz dorthin zu bringen wo er hingehört
nämlich Seite an Seite mit den
einzurückenden und eingerückten
Soldatinnen und Soldaten Seite an Seite
mit denen die das Soldatentum als Beruf
für sich entdecken
eines ist dabei wichtig
und wir haben es heute auch schon gehört
es ist einzigartig
das ist die Kameradschaft
Kameradschaft meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren ist mehr als
das Miteinander
sorgsam und ordentlich umgehen
Kameradschaft bedeutet in Wahrheit die
Verwirklichung sozialer Gleichheit
völlig egal woher man kommt wer man ist
man dient und man passt aufeinander auf
man ist füreinander da
und das ist auch für sie ist ganz
wichtig
Kameradschaft gibt es nicht nur in eine
Richtung
Kameradschaft heißt auch aufeinander
aufpassen
beim Kameraden und bei der Kameradin zu
sein politisch
entwickeln und dann nicht wegzuschauen
sondern hinzuschauen
das österreichische Bundesheer kann
stolz sein auf seine demokratische
Tradition auf seine Offiziere und
Unteroffiziere auf die Art und Weise wie
wir Dienst und Dienstpflicht sehen und
wahrnehmen und wir müssen stets und
ständig daran arbeiten dass wir dem
Vertrauen gerecht werden wenn wir dem
Land mit der Waffe dienen dürfen
das was ich Ihnen allen euch
Kameradinnen und Kameraden Soldatinnen
und Soldaten von ganzem Herzen wünsche
viel Soldaten Glück
gesund und sicheren Dienst für eure
Zukunft und großartige Erfahrungen
in diesem Sinne
hochlebe das österreichische Bundesheer
hoch Liebe die Republik Österreich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie hören nun die Festansprache des
Herrn Bundespräsidenten Professor Dr
Alexander van der Bellen es folgt ein
Koran und ein Gebet gesprochen von der
militärgeistlichkeit
sehr geehrte Herren und Festgäste meine
Damen und Herren vor allem aber sehr
geehrte recruitinnen und Rekruten
sie werden heute am Nationalfeiertag
geloben
Österreich und sein Volk zu schützen und
mit der Waffe zu verteidigen
mit dem Angriff Russlands auf die
Ukraine am 24 Februar dieses Jahres hat
Präsident Putin die europäische
Sicherheitsarchitektur wie wir sie
bisher gekannt haben in ihren
Grundfesten erschüttert
er hat uns allen schmerzlich vor Augen
geführt dass Kriege auch in Europa ganz
nahe an unseren Grenzen auch heute noch
passieren können und nach wie vor mit
Panzern Artillerie Kampfflugzeugen und
schwer bewaffneten Soldaten geführt
werden
die österreichische Neutralität ist ein
hohes Gut
wenn wir aber über die neutalität
sprechen und dann bleibt der zweite Satz
des neutralitätsgesetzes oft unerwähnt
der ist aber sehr wichtig
lassen Sie mich in wörtlich zitieren
Österreich wird diese Neutralität mit
allen ihm zu Gebote stehenden Mitteln
aufrecht erhalten und verteidigen
Ende des Zitats
das österreichische Bundesheer ist aber
noch nicht in der Lage die militärische
Landesverteidigung umfassend wahrnehmen
zu können
die rigorose Sparpolitik der vergangenen
Jahrzehnte am Budget des Bundesheers hat
ihre sichtbaren Spuren hinterlassen
und das gefährdet nicht nur den Schutz
der österreichischen Bevölkerung sondern
auch und insbesondere das Leben der
Soldatinnen und Soldaten in ihren
Einsätzen
und der Herr begrüße ich es sehr dass
meine langjährigen Forderungen nach
einem ausreichenden Budget für das
Bundesheer nun mit einem breiten
parteienkonsens umgesetzt werden
wir sind derzeit mit vielen Krisen
gleichzeitig konfrontiert der
corona-krise der Energiekrise
innenpolitischen Turbulenzen und der
Klimakatastrophe die Bewältigung aller
damit verbundenen Herausforderungen wird
nur durch einen gesamtstaatlichen
Schulterschluss zu bewältigen sein
auch das Bundesheer spielt hier eine
wichtige Rolle sei es durch den Schutz
von kritischer Infrastruktur sei es der
Einsatz bei Umweltkatastrophen bis hin
zur Organisation von impfstrafen im
Straßen Entschuldigung Organisation von
impfstraßen während der Pandemie
damit wir auf alle diese Krisen besser
vorbereitet sind hoffe ich sehr dass die
Erarbeitung des
krisensicherheitsgesetzes nun rasch zu
einem Abschluss kommt
meine Damen und Herren vor wenigen
Monaten war ich zu Besuch bei den
Pionieren in Melk und einmal mehr war
ich von der hohen Motivation und dem
ausgezeichneten Ausbildungsstand unserer
Soldatinnen und Soldaten sehr
beeindruckt
ich möchte mich an dieser Stelle bei
allen Soldatinnen und Soldaten für ihren
täglichen Einsatz bedanken und ganz
besonders bei jenen die derzeit in
Krisengebieten im Ausland und im
Assistenzeinsatz im Inland ihren Dienst
versehen
sie alle haben sich Respekt und
Anerkennung für ihre gewissenhafte
Pflichterfüllung und professionellen
Leistungen erworben sowohl auf
nationaler Ebene als auch auf
internationaler Ebene und in gleicher
Weise danke ich auch den
milizsoldatinnen und Soldaten die bereit
sind neben ihrem zivilenberuf freiwillig
sehr viel Zeit zu investieren um zum
Schutz der österreichischen Bevölkerung
beizutragen
sehr geehrte Rekrutinnen und Rekruten
sie werden heute am Nationalfeiertag ihr
Gelöbnis als Soldatin und Soldat Ablegen
von ihnen wird hohes Engagement
Rechtschaffenheit und hoher
Leistungswillen erwartet sie werden in
einem her dienen dass sich den Zielen
Schutz der Demokratie Achtung der
Menschenrechte und Engagement bei
internationalen Friedens einsetzen
verschrieben hat mit ihren Dienst
leisten sie einen wertvollen Beitrag zur
Sicherheit aller Einwohnerinnen und
Einwohner unserer Republik ich wünsche
Ihnen für die Zeit ihres Wehrdienst
alles alles Gute
es lebe das österreichische Bundesheer
es lebe unsere Republik Österreich und
es lebe unser vereintes friedliches
Europa
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die Reden der politischen Vertreter Hans
Bürger war da etwas Überraschendes dabei
die Rede von Bundeskanzler Neheim aber
ja durchaus emotional kann man sagen ja
beide reden eigentlich sowohl die vom
Bundeskanzler Nehmer als auch die vom
Bundespräsident von Tabellen habe jetzt
noch mal versucht mich zu erinnern und
er hat schon gesagt durch diese
schlimme Sparpolitik beim Bundesheer
waren zum Teil auch Leben von Soldaten
gefährdet weil wenn sie in
Einsatzgebieten waren das ist schon ein
sehr starker Satz für einen
Bundespräsidenten noch dazu wenn man
weiß dass er eigentlich von einer Partei
kommt von den Grünen früher die dem
Bundesheer jetzt nicht immer diese
Aufmerksamkeit zukommen haben lassen Dir
die jetzt der Bundespräsident ausdrückt
und so gesehen waren das sehr stark
geworden und das andere was er auch
gesagt hat er wird alles daran setzen
dass die Neutralität in Österreich
aufrecht erhalten bleibt das waren auch
klar und deutliche Worte wir haben ja
zuerst darüber gesprochen dass ein
Diskussionsprozess in Gang kommen sollte
aber das war jetzt eigentlich auch ein
Beenden jeglicher Diskussion wie man es
soweit interpretieren kann ähnlich bei
Bundeskanzler nähhammer der der Ton
macht die Musik der sich laut und
deutlich für das österreichische
Bundesheer ausgesprochen hat für eine
neue Sicherheitsarchitektur für
eine klare Linie im Ukrain Ukraine krieg
ja also man muss sagen für
übliche reden zum Nationalfeiertag waren
das sehr emotionale
stark pointierte reden was zu erwarten
war es das natürlich
was zu erwarten weiß dass Eigenlob der
Verteidigungsministerin
selbstverständlich sie kann das auch mit
Recht sagen unter unter ihrer
Ministerinnen schafft ist es gelungen
dass bundesheerbudget deutlich zu
erhöhen und ist immer höher und höher
aber auch vom
SPÖ-Bürgermeister von Wien muss man
sagen da kann man jetzt vielleicht
Unterschiede suchen aber er hat sicher
wenn ich mich Richter richtig erinnere
auch für eine höhere Bezahlung quer
durch das Bundesheer ausgesprochen das
hat dann Tanda gleich aufgenommen und
hat gesagt das gefällt dir dass das auch
der Wiener Bürgermeister so sieht und so
nehme ich an gibt es jetzt gewaltige
Gehaltserhöhungen auch für meinen
Nachbarn da links davon gehen wir jetzt
aus ja also sehr pointierte reden und
wahrscheinlich die die
eloquentesten und auch intensivsten
inhaltlich der letzten Jahre
der generalmaier wurde auch ein Miliz
Award übergeben an die Wirtschaftskammer
Österreich an den Generalsekretär
Karl-heinz Kopf warum man die
Wirtschaftskammer
in den letzten Jahren dafür eingesetzt
hat dass eben das anerkannt wird was die
milit Soldaten auch in die Wirtschaft
einbringen können das ist ja ein Thema
wo gerade in der Führungsausbildung des
Bundesheer sehr viel investiert in der
Offiziersausbildung wo Soldaten aber
auch
was die Frau Hauptmann sehr gut
dargestellt hat ihre Erfahrungen in der
Führung von Menschen einbringen kann
weil es ist erstens einmal nicht immer
ganz einfach im Bundesheer zu führen
weil wir ja auch schwierige Aufgaben und
der Belastungen lösen müssen und dass in
die Kommandanten schon ganz schön
gefordert und das ist nicht da üblicher
Bürojob sondern das passiert bei jedem
Wetter und das haben schon Dinge die
eine persönlich auch weiterbringen und
immer in der Privatwirtschaft gut
anwenden kann und der miliza Wort soll
auch zum Ausdruck bringen dass man uns
unterstützen möge in der
Weiterentwicklung der Miliz auch das ist
ja angesprochen worden dass es nicht
immer einfach ist für die milchsoldaten
zu üben
damit sie auch von ihrem Arbeitgeber
freigestellt werden ich denke dass wir
sowohl Wirtschaft wie auch das
Bundesheer neue Wege beschreiten werden
müssen
weil im Verhältnis dazu was Österreich
an Arbeitskräften hat und wie viele
davon nur milizoldaten sind Fels
insgesamt nicht so schwer ins so stark
ins Gewicht also wichtig wir haben es
hat schon ein paar mal gehört ist auch
Schwerpunkt dieser Leistungsschau und im
nächsten Film von Oskar Preisträger
Stefan roswitsky bringt ein
Computerspezialist sein Know-how im
cyberzentrum des Bundesheeres in der
stiftskaserne in Wien an ein Beispiel
dafür dass Österreicherinnen und
Österreicher ihre Kompetenzen die ist in
ihrem zivilen Leben erworben haben dem
Bundesheer zur Verfügung stellen
[Musik]
mein Name ist Robert Lamprecht im
Zivilberuf arbeite ich bei einer
wirtschaftsprüfungskanzlei dort im
Bereich cybersicherheit im militärischen
habe ich den Dienstgrad mallor und
unterstütze des Bundesheer mit meinen
Kenntnissen und der Expertise die ich
aus meiner beruflichen Leben mitgenommen
habe diese Erfahrungen die wir
mitbringen können natürlich sehr
vielfältige eingesetzt werden im Bereich
der ABC Abwehr wo wir
strahlenphysiker Chemiker und
dergleichen haben im Gesundheitsbereich
die Ärzte aber auch Juristen oder
technische Berufe man glaubt gar nicht
wie vielfältig die Möglichkeiten sind
dieses cyber-feld dürfen wir nicht
unterschätzen es ist zwar immer relativ
still und wir merken es nicht direkt
aber die Auswirkungen sind doch sehr
sehr unangenehm wir sehen die Bilder wo
ein Stau an der polnisch ukrainischen
Grenze war da Grenzübertritt war nicht
möglich weil die Systeme für die
Grenzabfertigung der Ukraine gelöscht
wurden durch angreifen
Ukraine kriegt man sicherlich zu einem
wachrütteln geführt das heißt das was
man vorher für unmöglich gehalten hat
ist von einem Tag auf den anderen mehr
oder weniger Realität geworden
inwieweit ich mich für einen Staat
einsetze ist natürlich auch eine
Haltungsfrage weil bin hier groß
geworden ich bin hier geboren ich darf
die Vorzüge dieses Staates und dieses
Landes genießen und wenn es wirklich
hart auf hart kommt muss ich auch die
Souveränität und meine eigene
Souveränität entsprechend verteidigen
[Musik]
Soldaten sind also ein unverzichtbarer
Teil des österreichischen Bundesheers
und leistendienst Seite an Seite mit
aktiven Soldaten bei mir nun Oberst
Berthold Santner von der
Landesverteidigungsakademie wie viele
milizoldaten im Ernstfall könnte denn
das österreichische Bundesheer jetzt
zugreifen ja bestimmen ist der
mobilenmachungsrahmen mit 55.000
Soldaten derzeit sind es etwa 25.000
beorderte mit lizoldaten innerhalb
dieses Rahmens die ihren Dienst versehen
und die in ihrer Gesamtstärke in einem
Einsatzfall einberufen werden könnten so
was hatten wir einmalig in der Zweiten
Republik mit einer Teilmobilmachung sie
kennen das im Rahmen der corona-pandemie
2020 wo es etwa 1.500 millilitsoldaten
waren die ihre aktiven Kameraden dann
unterstützt haben
danke und damit zurück ins Studio zu
vielen Dank Saskia vielen Boss ja und
jetzt sind wir wirklich angelangt am
Höhepunkt dieser Veranstaltung nämlich
bei der Angelobung der 1000 Rekruten
wenn Sie jetzt das zugeschaltet haben
vergangenes Jahr waren es corona-bedingt
nur 100 heuer sind es eben wieder 1000
Rekrutinnen und Rekruten
Herr generalmaier wie läuft das jetzt ab
also der
Höhepunkt des Festaktes auf den wir
jetzt zulaufen beginnt damit dass die
der insignientrupp der Garde aus der
Formation austritt und vor die
Ehrenformation
im paradeschrittmarschiert das sehen wir
jetzt gerade
gut im Bild der kommandanter Garde jetzt
im Vordergrund zu sehen und hier der
insignientrupp
das ist die Fahne der Garde daneben das
ehrensignalhorn und links und rechts
zwei Offiziere auch das sehr
traditionell dass im entsprechend die
Fahne immer durch zwei Offiziere zu
deren Bewachung hier begleitet werden in
weiterer Folge werden dann Rekruten
Austreten aus der
aus der aus der Formation und zur Fahne
gehen und dort dann das Gelöbnis welche
Rekruten sind das ist das zufällig
ausgewählt oder
das wird von den zwei ausgewählt dass
das
dass das gerecht verteilt wird auf die
angetretenen Kontingente wir haben hier
eine weibliche Soldat in der Garde und
einen
männlichen das ist der soldatenvertreter
der Garde die dann jetzt das Zeug
Gelöbnis ihren Kameraden Vorsprechen
werden und die anderen Soldaten die zur
Fahne gehen die sind eben ausgewogen auf
die verschiedenen Kontingente ausgewählt
das heißt das Treuegelöbnis wird von
Soldaten von der Soldatin und dem
Soldaten ihren Kameraden vorgesprochen
die dann gemeinsam nachsprechen
Rekruten sprecht uns nach ich glaube
[Musik]
die Republik Österreich
und mit der Waffe zu verteidigen
ich gelobe
den Gesetzen und den gesetzmäßigen
Behörden
treu und Gehorsam zu leisten
alle Befehle meiner Vorgesetzten
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen
und mit allen meinen Kräften
und dem österreichischen Volker
[Musik]
über die letzten Jahre nicht verändert
worden das sind die sechs vorgetretenen
Soldaten aus den unterschiedlichen
Kontingenten die jetzt dann wieder zu
ihren Aufstellungsorten zurückkehren und
daraufhin wird dann auch die Fahne der
Garde wieder
in die Ehrenformation eintreten
wir haben auch gesehen dass man sich
jetzt schon auch bemüht hat
[Musik]
eine weibliche Soldatin hier auf die
Bühne zu holen das ist uns ein großes
Anliegen
wir haben den Frauen an und für sich im
Bundesheer alle möglichen eröffnet ich
muss
gleicher Lohn mit gleicher Leistung also
dafür stehen wir jedenfalls ja weil es
da hier keinen Unterschied gibt es gibt
eine Aufgabe zu erfüllen und dafür wirst
du bezahlt egal ob Mann oder Frau
der Garde eintreten
jetzt kommt den siegenturm den
Einteilung zurück
ist im Endeffekt dass die zwei Fahnen
Offiziere bzw die Fahne der mit dem
Fahnen Träger das ist immer eine
besonders herausgehobene Aufgabe in der
Garde wer die Fahne tragen darf und das
ehrensignalhorn das auch noch sehr
traditionell daran erinnert dass er
früher die Signale über Hörner gegeben
worden sind und das ist an und für sich
jener Teil der immer mit dem
Kommandanten unmittelbar verbunden war
und hier jetzt
wieder vorbei an der Ehrenformation
zurück an den Aufstellungsplatz
marschiert
den die gehen das ist ein sehr groß
das ist
an und für sich der Garde vorbehalten
weil es sehr schwierig und sehr
aufwendig ist das zu trainieren
das ist traditionell der Paradeschritt
den auch die K+K mich gehabt hat nicht
zu verwechseln mit dem Stechschritt den
man in anderen Ländern sieht
somit ist jetzt an und für sich der
Höhepunkt erreicht und
das ganze
ihre komponie
und wir sehen jetzt wieder den Gewerk
auf der Garde die Waffen werden
präsentiert
[Musik]
zum Abspielen der Bundes-
Gemeinde
[Musik]
das ganze
Ehre Kompanie schon
ober
Markus Reisner Kommandant der ausgeübten
Truppe bietet nun den Herrn
Bundespräsidenten um weitere Befehle mit
dem ausmaßstabilitärmusik der
Ehrenformation und der angelobten
Rekruten endet der Festakt die Rekruten
kommen nach Abgabe der Waffen wieder
hier auf den Heldenplatz zurück wo sie
von ihnen Angehörigen in Empfang
genommen werden können meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren ich darf mich
an dieser Stelle bei ihnen vorläufig
verabschieden mich für die Teilnahme am
Festtag bedanken und sieht noch darauf
hinweisen dass wir heute bis 17 Uhr hier
noch einige Höhepunkte erleben werden
ihre Kompanie pressen
der bundesvertreten das ganze rechts tut
der oberste generalstabsdienstes
Präsident oberstreisner meldet die
Beendigung der feierlichen Angelobung
und bitte um weitere Befehle
paarbrücken
und hat jetzt als kommandanter Garde
gleich eine sehr schwierige und
spannende Aufgabe übernehmen können
nämlich als Kommandant der gerade diese
groß angelogen zu kommentieren das ist
schon eine Nervenanspannung für den
Kommandanten der da ganz alleine vor der
angetretenen Truppe steht ganz
besonderes
die Ehre Informationen Kommando
übernehmen abrücken
jetzt tritt der Kompaniekommandant
wieder aus
und übernimmt über die vierte klare
Kompanie würde das Kommando das ist auch
eine Kompanie die er kommentiert hat
während der Kranzniederlegungen
und jetzt wird im Endeffekt abmarschiert
[Musik]
die marschieren jetzt
durch das Innere in den inneren Burghof
und dort in weiterer Folge dann
abzutreten sie haben ja alle
entsprechend ihre Waffen mit auch die
Rekruten die angelobt werden haben ihre
Waffen mitgegeben jetzt ihre Waffen dann
zurück damit die gesichert entsprechend
verwahrt werden um die werden dann auch
abtreten können um sich mit ihren
Verwandten und Bekannten zu treffen und
vielleicht noch ein bisschen am
Heldenplatz zu bleiben
[Musik]
nachdem die Zuschauer man sieht es jetzt
sehr gut
sehr umfangreich gekommen sind wird hier
jetzt
vor den Ehrengästen
vorbeimarschiert und dann über einen
Umweg Richtung Hofburg zurück
[Musik]
Bundesministerin schaut sehr zufrieden
auch
[Musik]
da haben wir jetzt noch einmal den
Ehrenkompanie
dahinter der insinger-trupp
[Musik]
und die Garde ist ja nach wie vor für
die Repräsentationszwecke mit dem alten
Sturmgewehr 58 ausgerüstet und hat nicht
das
bewährte STG 77 das hat primär den auch
einen traditionellen Hintergrund und es
ist einfach so dass der österreichische
militärgriff mit dem
Sturmgewehr 58 besser gemacht werden
kann
[Musik]
ja es ist also vollbracht 1.000 Rekruten
sind angelobt worden Herr Generalmajor
es gibt ja nicht nur das 1.000
Rekrutinnen und Rekruten werden das
ganze Jahr über angelobt aber diese
1.000 woher kommen die aus welchen
Bundesländern also im Wesentlichen sind
das
Soldaten die aus dem Raum Oberösterreich
Wien und Niederösterreich kommen es gibt
natürlich auch
einzelne Soldaten die aus anderen
Bundesländern hier in die Kontingente
hineinfallen im Kern gibt es ein großes
Kontingent der Garde die dann in
absehbarer Zeit die Aufgaben übernimmt
die man jetzt gesehen haben durch die
vierte klare Kompanie das waren sogar
garantiert Bataillons 13 aus
Oberösterreich das sind die die hier im
fleckdown-anzug gestanden sind das
werden Panzergrenadiere also
kampfsoldaten die auf den
Schützenpanzern die Kampfpanzer
unterstützen sollen aus der
Luftunterstützung ein großer Anteil die
mit der Fliegermütze angetreten sind
Pioniere aus Melk
die wir ja immer wieder im Einsatz sehen
sowohl in der pionierkampfunterstützung
im Auslandseinsatz aber natürlich auch
bei den verschiedensten Katastrophen
Hilfsmaßnahmen weil die Birne für das
sehr gut ausgestattet sind um hier zu
unterstützen wenn die Feuerwehren nicht
mehr können oder ganz einfach der
Einsatz schon zu lange dauert und dann
haben wir noch einzelne Teile vom merk
Commander die Gesundheit bzw auch aus
Freistaat gibt es eigentlich ganz
generell mehr Interesse jetzt auch durch
den Ukraine Krieg am Bundesheer es ist
schon so dass das Interesse am
Bundesheer gestiegen ist jedenfalls wir
werden sehen ob es auch Mittel- und
langfristig eine positive Wirkung aus
Bundesheer
bringt jedenfalls denke ich schon dass
wenn modernes Gerät moderne
Ausbildungsmittel dem den Soldatinnen
und Soldaten zur Verfügung stehen dass
das auch einen positiven Effekt auf die
Rekrutierung und auf das eben sich die
jungen Österreicherinnen und
Österreicher für den Wehrdienst
entscheiden dass es das schon haben wird
Dankeschön und wir sehen nun einen
weiteren Film von Oskar Preisträger
Stefan rusowitzky eine Milizsoldat beim
Jagdkommando steht im Zentrum ein Jurist
der in Wien und New York tätig ist er
spricht darüber wir aus seinen
Erfahrungen im Bundesheer auch in seinem
Zivilberuf profitiert und umgekehrt
lamsten Robin Rechtsanwalt in Österreich
und in den USA und in meiner
Milizfunktion bin ich Offizier beim
Jagdkommando
als junger Mensch hat mich natürlich
auch das Abenteuer bei Militär und
insbesondere beim JA Kommando fasziniert
und angezogen aber es ist viel mehr als
ein Abenteuer ich bin bei der Miliz aus
Überzeugung aus Patriotismus und weil
ich mir sicher bin dass ich sehr viel
vom Militär gelernt habe und ich bin
stolz darauf
eine Konflikt zeigt uns dass es ein
Bundesheer ein starkes bundesheerbedarf
und das die Stimmen die davon ausgehen
dass es keine Konflikte mehr geben wird
doch verstummen wir wünschen sonst aber
es ist nicht realistisch in der Ukraine
sieht man dass Menschen bereit sind für
Vaterland zu kämpfen oder für ihre
Umgebung für Ihren Ort für ihre Gemeinde
für alles was ihnen etwas wert ist
ich habe viel Zeit im Ausland verbracht
und viele Jahre in Amerika gelebt und
besonders wenn man von außen wieder
zurück nach Österreich kommt weiß man
eigentlich was Österreich zu bieten hat
welche Qualitäten österreich hat man
kann bei uns das Wasser trinken wir
haben eine tolle Sozialversicherung wir
haben viele Errungenschaften und ich
glaube dass der Blick von außen vielen
helfen könnte sich auch Gedanken dazu zu
machen bin ich bereit dies zu
verteidigen
und wir gehen jetzt wieder live zum
Heldenplatz zu Saskia venenboss
entschuldigen Sie bitte zu meinem
Kollegen Andreas Mayr Bogusch
ich stehe wieder am großen Checkpoint
der Miliz und habe hier einen wichtigen
Offizier der Reserve Oberleutnant vom
Jagdkommando Robin lumpsten bei mir sie
sind erfolgreicher Anwalt in den USA in
New York und in Wien in ihrer Freizeit
tauschen Sie den schönen Anzug mit der
Uniform sie sind Elite Soldat warum tun
sie das na ich bin der Ansicht man muss
in jeglicher Funktion noch etwas
zurückgeben in meinem Fall hier den
Bundesheer ich habe sehr viel von diesem
Land bekommen und ein bisschen einen
Beitrag möchte ich auch leisten und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr machen
als den normalen Grundwehrdienst
jetzt für Sie als Anwalt was können Sie
aus Ihrer Tätigkeit als Elite-Soldat in
den beruflichen Alltag auch in ihr
Privatleben mitnehmen was bringt sie in
den persönlich das ist das Schöne daran
dass man sehr sehr viele Fähigkeiten die
man beim Bundesheer oder beim
Jagdkommando lernen kann ins zivile
Leben mitnehmen kann in meinem Fall
Managementfähigkeiten ich hatte das
Privileg in Amerika in Stanford zu
studieren habe viel Geld ausgegeben
dafür dass ich management skills lerne
in Wirklichkeit hat man die der Verband
und das Bundesheer eigentlich schon
beigebracht wie reagiert man unter Druck
wie geht man mit seiner Mitarbeitern um
und dem Vorurteil dass es bei Militär
mit Befehlen zugeht das gibt es unter
Druck muss einer entscheiden aber in
Wirklichkeit ist es ein sehr
kollaboratives System man muss einen
Kompromiss finden man muss mit sehr
vielen verschiedenen Arten von Menschen
umgehen können und all diese Fähigkeiten
bin ich den Bundesheer sehr dankbar dass
ich die lernen durfte sie sind ja Teil
einer Eliteeinheit der Miliz haben Sie
das Gefühl dass bei ihrer Truppe auch
ausreichend investiert wird oder ist
nicht doch auch so dass selbst so
wichtige Truppenteile in den letzten
Jahren und Jahrzehnten ein bisschen
vernachlässigt wurden dass es zu wenig
Geld gibt letztlich geht es immer auch
ums Geld ja das ist auch ein Faktor aber
ich glaube es sind ja jetzt in letzter
Zeit die richtigen Schritte gesetzt
worden um das Militärbudget aufzustocken
mein Zugang ist je nach dass man sich
vielleicht über manche Themen jetzt
nicht ich in meiner Rolle nicht
beschweren soll sondern ich überlege mir
was kann ich machen ich kann meine Zeit
zur Verfügung stellen ich bin sehr
beschäftigt ich habe ein Unternehmen
aber ich nehme diese Zeit hier also
nicht gern es ist wichtig es ist wichtig
glaube ich dass Menschen wie ich ihre
Zeit im Bundesheer schenken und dem Land
schenken und ich würde mir wünschen dass
mehr junge Leute sich jetzt besonders
auch wo das Militärbudget aufgeschraubt
wurde für spannende Zeit beim Militär
mit Fähigkeiten interessieren würden
vielen Dank Robin numbsen Elite Soldat
und Rechtsanwalt in Wien danke schön
ja etwas laut ist es hier weil gerade
die Panzer über den Heldenplatz in
Position gebracht werden aber ich stehe
hier mit den Familien die gerade die
Angelobung ihrer Verwandten mitbekommen
haben Familie Becker wie war denn das
vor so vielen Menschen dass ihr Bruder
hier angelobt wurde vor der gesamten
Bundesregierung um ehrlich zu sein man
fühlt eigentlich nichts außer stolz gar
nichts
ihre Tochter ist auch gerade angelobt
worden wie war denn das für sie das
Gefühl wie sie damals gewusst haben sie
geht es zum Bundeshaus oder sie gesagt
hat sie geht zum Bundeswehr
sie hat lange
sie waren wohl mehr aufgeregt als ihre
Tochter merke ich gerade ja
[Musik]
woher sind sie angereist heute
es gibt doch also Nähe von Steyr ganz
Großraming was wird denn ihre Tochter
jetzt nach der Grundausbildung beim
Bundesheer machen
[Musik]
ja wird das nächste Jahr über gerade
Musik bleiben sondern drehe ich mich
gleich wie war denn das für ein Gefühl
heute hier vor so vielen Menschen
angelobt worden zu sein also wie war
richtig aufgeregt aber schon sehen ich
weiß ja nicht voll cool und ja und ist
irgendwie schon ein tolles Gefühl doch
ich glaube der Papa war aufgeregt als
können wir gut vorstellen aber wir haben
optische gebrauchen
[Musik]
danke ich glaube der Papa will zu Ihnen
ja und auch Vati bektag ist hier bei mir
sie wurden gerade angelobt wie ist das
wenn die ganze Familie hier zusieht und
auch die ganze Bundesregierung dabei ist
wir haben es nicht gefühlt während der
angelogen also einerseits fühlt man sich
schon geehrt wenn man für tausende von
Leuten ein Gelöbnis sprechen darf vor
allem wenn auch die höchsten Menschen
Österreichs dabei sind und umso schöner
ist es am Nationalfeiertag und auch umso
schöner wenn die Familie dabei ist wann
sie sehr aufgeregt eine gewisse
Nervosität war immer da aber dann gilt
unseren Ausbildungen wir haben genug
Zeit damit verbracht uns auf den
heutigen Tag vorzubereiten in der
Ausbildung das konnte meine Universität
senken und deswegen ging es auch super
dann und ich fühle mich jetzt einfach
gut jetzt sind sie seit vier Wochen in
der Grundausbildung es war Folgen
weiterer Monate wissen Sie schon ob sie
dann verlängern werden ich bin bereits
der Miliz beigetreten werde aber nicht
Berufssoldat werden oder das dürfte sich
vielleicht noch ändern nach dem Studium
vielleicht als Offizier im Militär
einsteigen als Arzt oder Jurist das
müsste man sich noch anschauen danke
viel Erfolg und damit zurück zu Ihnen
Rebecca ins Studium der berührende
Szenen waren das mitunter jetzt am
Heldenplatz vielen Dank Saskia venenpass
wir gehen dann auch mal auch nochmals
zurück zum Heldenplatz aber heute wird
nicht nur in Österreich unser
nationalfeiert auch im Ausland treffen
sich die österreichischen Gemeinden also
Communitys um den Tag zu begehen in
einigen Städten spielt sogar die
Militärmusik dazu auf etwa in New York
schon gestern überbrachte die Gardemusik
in New York denn in der US Metropole
lebenden Österreicherinnen und
Österreichern einen Gruß aus der Heimat
geprobt wurde im Generalkonsulat
anschließend ging es in den Central Park
zum ersten öffentlichen Auftritt
[Musik]
und vor dem österreichischen Kulturforum
wurde dann sogar getanzt
[Musik]
und wir wollten uns eigentlich wieder
zum Heldenplatz gehen zu meinem Kollegen
Andreas Andreas Mayr Bohusch ich höre
gerade es gibt keine Schaltung es gibt
keine verbindung würde ich vorschlagen
wir sprechen ein bisschen im Studio Herr
general major das Wichtige und das sehr
bei dieser Leistungsschau auch sind die
milizoldaten und milit Soldatinnen wie
viele Frauen gibt es da eigentlich unter
diesem milizoldaten ja das ist noch eine
überschaubare
Größe die wir hier also wir haben
ungefähr 80 Milli Soldatinnen im
Bundesheer da hat haben wir noch etwas
Luft nach oben
[Musik]
je länger der je mehr berufssoldatinnen
wir in zum Beispiel für ein
Zeitverhältnis ins Bundesheer
hereinbekommen desto leichter wird es
dann auch sein auch in die Miliz mehr
weibliche Soldaten hineinzubekommen ich
kann nur sagen es stehen alle
Möglichkeiten offen es ist natürlich
eine Zusatzbelastung das muss man
anerkennen für männliche wie auch für
weibliche Soldaten
aber ich denke schon dass gerade in
gewissen Bereichen
es sehr sehr lohnende Möglichkeiten gibt
auch für weibliche Soldatinnen sich in
der Miliz engagieren ob das jetzt die
generellen Themen wie zum Beispiel
Sanität sind mal herkömmlich eher hier
verbindet aber auch so Dinge wie im
Cyberspace im ikd-bereich auch ein
durchaus in technischen
Belangen könnten wir kann immer sehr gut
vorstellen dass auch Frauen hervorragend
eingesetzt werden können ich glaube es
50.000 also
davon sind dann ungefähr 34.000
medizoldaten
ich höre gerade von der Regie wir können
wieder zum Heldenplatz schalten zu
Saskia beerenbos und zu philippielinek
offenbar wird wieder geturnt
ja wir sind ja schon wieder bei der
nächsten sportlichen Einheit mit Philipp
der Regen von dem lässt er sich nicht
beeindruckt genau was trainiert sie denn
heute alles ja trainieren generell geht
es um die tägliche bewegungeinheit und
das Schöne ist dass wir heute hier uns
gemeinsam bewegen mit den
heeressportlerinnen und herrensportlern
aber wie man sieht jung und alt ist mit
dabei und es geht nicht immer nur den
Spitzensport es geht um die regelmäßige
und tägliche Bewegungseinheit also
mobilisieren mobilisieren aktivieren
koordinieren kräftigen und einfach Spaß
daran zu haben um das geht
zeig uns mal ein paar Übungen mit allen
die
bewegen sie alle auf der Seite jawohl
rechts links sehr schön und jetzt
versuchen wir
linke Ferse also wir versuchen mit dem
Ferse unsere Fingerspitzen zu berühren
genau sehr gut und setzen dabei unser
Lächeln auf genau von rechts nach links
super macht sie das sehr schön genau
jawohl und das schöne ist ja bei uns
kann jeder und jede mitmachen ob klein
ob groß ob Jung und Alt ja die
regelmäßige Bewegung genau die Macht aus
den schlussendlich wollen wir fit und
gesund eignen und Kinder sollten sich
wieder regelmäßiger bewegen sehr gut
okay machen wir einmal klatschen
und wieder genau wir haben Spaß
gemeinsam super wir setzen uns genau das
ist gut so starten wir aktiv in den Tag
hinein
sehr gut okay wir laufen kann aus kommen
zur Mitte gehen die Hände Richtung Hüfte
und jetzt ganz locker einfach nur mal
hier zum mobilisieren
ja sehr schön ganz locken eine Richtung
sehr gut jetzt wechseln wir die Richtung
andere Richtung zu gehen und ich darf
alle Damen und Herren die jetzt gerade
Lachen einladen mitzumachen sehr schön
auch zu Hause jeden Tag um kurz nach
neuen fit mit Philipp ja so nächste
Geschichte Hände nach vorne
und jetzt eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs
super eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs und
der 1 2 3 4 5 6 super 1 2 3 4 5 6 genau
auch zu Hause jawohl die Arme nach oben
super seid ihr einfach dranbleiben und
es ist genau die regelmäßige Bewegung
die ist ausmacht jawohl nach oben sehr
gut auf die Damen und Herren da hinten
ja
super ich finde es weit klasse genau
nicht nur lachen auch mitmachen
Temperaturen da lässt sich hier
anscheinend niemand beeindrucken alle
machen Braten mit außer mir natürlich
und deswegen gebe ich jetzt übergebe ich
jetzt an Andreas meyer-busch auf der
anderen Seite Platz
ich stehe hier vor dem Sanitätszelt mit
der Chefin der Bundesheer Sanität
sozusagen Gudrun Walter was ist denn das
Besondere der militärischen
Sanitätsausbildung wenn man an Militär
denkt denkt man vor allem an schweres
Gerät an gefährliche Waffen und weniger
daran dass natürlich auch die
medizinische ärztliche Versorgung und
die Sanitätsversorgung eine
entscheidende Rolle spielt ja das
natürlich wir sind natürlich so wie das
zivile ausgebildet aber wir haben
natürlich unsere speziellen
Zusatzausbildungen und sind im Prinzip
bei allen Waffengattungen eingesetzt was
kann jetzt sozusagen die militärische
Ausbildung mehr im Vergleich zu einer
zivilen sanitäts- oder medizinausbildung
ja deutlich mehr lernen was Führung ist
wie ich meine Kräfte entsprechend gut
einsetzen kann wenn jetzt jemand sich
als Miliz Soldat Soldatinnen schließt
eine Sanitätsausbildung zu machen was
nützt denn die Ausbildung beim
Bundesheer dann auch im Zivil leben kann
man die auch beruflich im Zivilbereich
einsetzen ja durchaus wie gesagt er
bekommt dann eine Zusatzausbildung vor
allem was das militärische betrifft und
was Führung betrifft
wenn man jetzt sich den Krieg in der
Ukraine anschaut wäre das
österreichische Bundesheer auch bei der
medizinischen Versorgung bei der
sanitätsbetreuung für so einen Einsatz
gerüstet oft hat man ja den Eindruck in
Österreich beim Bundesheer wurde in den
letzten Jahren Jahrzehnten zu viel
gespart jetzt kann man sagen dass
Sanitätsbereich ist vielleicht nicht so
teuer und aufwendig wie die technische
Ausrüstung bei der Flugabwehr etc ist
man da im internationalen Vergleich
vorne dabei wir können natürlich vorne
dabei sein Problem ist dass wir
mengenmäßig derzeit noch zu geringer
aufgestellt sind was macht denn einen
Job als Sanitäter beim Bundesheer
interessant wenn sich jemand für eine
Waffengattung entscheiden muss viele
junge Menschen wollen vielleicht lieber
mit schwerem Gerät arbeiten was ist denn
die Herausforderung im militärischen
Sanitätsbereich die Herausforder
ungen vor allem als
sanitätsunteroffizier tätig sein kann
das heißt vom Gebirge bis zum Panzer ist
da alles drinnen und sie brauchen nur um
die Ecke schon dort haben wir auch das
schwere Gerät also man ist auch mit dem
Band zu unterwegs und das kann man
durchaus auch machen vielen Dank also
das Spannende an der Sanität auch als
Rettungssanitäter beim Bundesheer ist
man bei allen Waffengattungen im Einsatz
muss ich nicht auf eine festlegen
dankeschön
vielen Dank Andreas Mayr Bosch für diese
Informationen und vor dem aus weil ich
Quartier oder ihm ausreichend das
Parlaments steht jetzt mein Kollege
Klaus Bruckmann seit 10 Uhr noch bis 16
Uhr bietet sich noch einmal die
Gelegenheit das Parlament in der Hofburg
zu besuchen bevor sich im Jänner dann
nach intensiven Jahren der Sanierung und
das Umbaus die Pforten des historischen
Parlamentsgebäudes am Ring wieder öffnen
was tut sich denn da jetzt bei Ihnen wie
groß ist der Andrang
der Andrang ist relativ groß wenngleich
die Wartezeit nicht zu kurz ist ist das
alles sehr gut eingeteilt hier man kann
den großen reduttensaal besichtigen
indem wir uns jetzt gerade hier befinden
man kann den kleinen retroutensaal
besichtigen dort gibt es verschiedene
Ausstellungen und das Besondere hier im
großen redotensaal man kann sich auch am
Rednerpult fotografieren lassen das ist
natürlich ein Anreiz für ganz viele
Leute das ist Erinnerungsfoto
mitzunehmen heuer letztmalig hier im
Ausweichquartier
der letztmaligem da auch heute
Informationen über das neue oder
wiederöffnete bald wieder öffnen
man kann vor allem ein Stück vom alten
Parlament mit nach Hause nehmen warum
die Münze Österreich hat eine fünf Euro
Münze geprägt eine neuneckige
symbolisierend für die neuen
Bundesländer und dieser Münze diese
Kupfermünze ist aus dem Dach des alten
Parlaments gemacht das grüne Dach ist
natürlich gereinigt worden und das ist
jetzt in reinem Kupfer es freuen sich
hier eigentlich alle mit denen man
spricht auch mit den drei
Nationalratspräsidenten habe ich in der
Früh gesprochen auf die Übersiedlung sie
blicken mit Dankbarkeit zurück hier auf
die Zeit im Ausweichquartier aber sie
freuen sich dann schon alle wieder auf
das zeitgemäß hergerichtete historische
Parlament an der Ringstraße es gibt aber
auch stabile bundesländertour mit
Informationen zum neuen Parlament was
wissen Sie denn darüber
das ist ganz etwas Neues das sind vier
Container die derzeit hier am
josephsplatz aufgestellt sind sie sollen
zeigen wie Demokratie funktioniert wie
Parlamentarismus funktioniert das ganze
nennt sich Parlament on Tour und diese
Ausstellung soll dann tatsächlich auch
in die Bundesländer gehen es beginnt im
Jänner mit dem Burgenland das Burgenland
wird ab Jänner den Vorsitz in der
Landeshauptleutekonferenz und auch im
Bundesrat führen und dort können nicht
nur Besucher sich das anschauen es
können auch Abgeordnete oder Bundesräte
in diesem Container oder vor diesem
Container Sprechstunden abhalten mit
Bürgern oder einfach Bürgern das
Parlament erklären das ist eine ganz
tolle Sache die dann ab Jänner durch
Österreich Touren soll vielen Dank Klaus
Bruckmann vom Parlament und wir kommen
jetzt direkt wieder zum Heldenplatz zu
einer Performance der Militärmusik
Niederösterreich ein musikalischer
Zapfenstreich sozusagen ja sehen wir
jetzt
[Musik]
ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich
befinde mich hier neben der Frau
Bundesminister und ich würde sagen wir
beginnen mit dem nächsten Highlight und
zwar ist es ja bereits ein Thema Schutz
der Bevölkerung und Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur dafür haben wir
uns auch jetzt wieder ganz was
besonderes überlegt und zu meiner
Rechten wenn Sie die Richtung Burgdorf
sehen dann sind Sie auf der rechten
Seite einen Checkpoint aufgebaut bei
diesem Checkpoint befinden sich
Milizsoldaten die im Bedarfsfall
Fahrzeuge kontrollieren Personen
durchsuchen oder ebenfalls kontrollieren
können beziehungsweise natürlich auch
dann ein weiterer Folge diese fiktive zu
und abfahrtsstraße zu einem kritischen
Element der Infrastruktur beschützen was
bedeutet das dies könnte eine das ist
ein die zu einem Umspannwerk zu einem
Wasserkraftwerk oder was auch immer
führt und unsere Soldaten am Checkpoint
überwachen diese Straße
ein weiterer Folge werden wir ein
kleines Szenario hier spielen es wird
hier eine Gruppe von Saboteuren wird
direkt vor mir ein Fahrzeug auf die
Straße schieben und dann natürlich auch
die Straße sperren unsere Soldaten
werden das ganze erkennen und werden
alarmiert
der Kommandant wird entscheiden dass
dann ein aufklärungsdruck bzw zwei davon
und ein gepanzertes Fahrzeug der Husar
mit einem Lautsprecher ausgestattet sich
dieser Sperre nähern um mehr
Informationen generieren zu können
sehen wir mal nach hinten
die Motoren laufen bereits in weiterer
Folge wird das Fahrzeug sich hier
annähern und über den Lautsprecher dann
auch verkünden dass die Sperre geräumt
werden soll die feindarstellung ist
davon unbeeindruckt und wird das Feuer
auf unsere Soldaten eröffnen es wird zu
verletzten fiktiv gespielt auf beiden
Seiten kommen wir verwenden hier
natürlich nur knallmunition
nachdem unsere Aufklärung weiter Folge
Unterstützung ersuchen werden wird ein
Kampfpanzer Leopard A2 zu meiner Linken
und ein schützenpanzerolan zu meiner
Rechten hier die Stellung beziehen
ein Bergepanzer M88 wird dann in
weiterer Folge die Sperre Räumen und die
Straße wieder frei machen und die
abgegessenen Panzergrenadiere werden
gemeinsam mit den Sanitätern unsere
Soldaten die Verwundeten ins Fahrzeug
bringen und die Lage dann wieder
deeskalieren lassen aber ich würde sagen
ich habe ihr vorstellungsgenügend nun
genügend strapaziert ich würde sagen wir
beginnen mit der Show
[Musik]
ja
diese Richtung Bereich Heldenplatz
Sperre verstanden
alle hier Checkpoint im Bereich
Heldenplatz Aufbau Sperre
Aufklärungsgruppe und sayups
achtung Achtung hier spricht das
österreichische Bundesheer an die
bewaffneten Kräfte an der spüre
der generalm was passiert da jetzt genau
im Endeffekt so wie ich daher hat man
das kurz dargestellt hat wird hier jetzt
her verkürzt und das sehr konzentrierten
Raum eine Vorführung gemacht wieso so
was abspielen könnte
wo man vor allem darstellen möchte wie
das militärische System zusammenarbeitet
es Sonne in verschiedene Waffengattungen
die wir vorher gesehen haben mit
verschiedenen
barettfarben die auch im Einsatz
unterschiedliche Aufgaben wahrzunehmen
haben wir haben hier zum Beispiel
Aufklärer die hier jetzt gerufen wurden
die einen
Soldaten waren an dem an dem an dem
Checkpoint die haben eine Situation
erkannt auf zu reagieren war die
Aufklärer gerufen
andererseits das Tactical sei auf Steam
ist dann mit dem Husar vorgefahren das
war dieses unangenehme Geräusch dass man
gehört hat das ist wenn man daneben
steht wirklich sehr laut und und ein
tatsächlich unangenehmes Geräusch wo
quasi versucht wird in solchen
Situationen auf
zum Beispiel hier sukzessive Kräfte
einzuwirken und das ganze auch ohne
Eskalation ablaufen zu lassen wenn das
wie in diesem Fall dann aber doch
eskalieren sollte während schwerere
Kräfte geholt hier dargestellt durch den
Kampfpanzer und den Schützenpanzer
wie gesagt sehr stark verkürzt natürlich
würde der Kampfpanzer niemals so nahe an
diese Sperre heranfahren aber das soll
ja entsprechend vorführen wie das
passiert und da ist jetzt der
Bergepanzer
auch im Einsatz das heißt wir haben
jetzt rechts den Ulan links den Leopard
in der Mitte
den
Bergepanzer im 88 der jetzt die Sperre
wegräumt
so sieht man auch nicht alle Tage
immer wieder und
in einsetzen im Balkan sind solche Dinge
durchaus schon passiert
jetzt sieht man es ist angesprochen
worden dass wir Sanitäts also das auch
verwunderte eingespielt werden würden
man sieht hier einen
gepanzerten ein gepanzertes
sanitätsfahrzeug einen Dingo
wo im entsprechend auch unter unter
Schutz vorgegnerischer Waffenwirkung
Sanitätsversorgung durchgeführt werden
kann und verwundete evakuiert werden
können die Infanterie sichert das jetzt
wie gesagt sehr stark
verkürzt und die Abstände massiv
verringert um eben hier den Publikum ein
bisschen nahe zu bringen wie so ein
Zusammenwirken laufen könnte in
Wirklichkeit ist es wesentlich
komplizierter auch sie müssen sich
vorstellen üblicherweise hat würde die
Aufklärung dann Drohnen einsetzen um das
einmal zu betrachten man würde vorher
Unterstützung einsetzen also das sind
dann Dinge die man hier jetzt bei dieser
Vorführung nicht so eins zu eins bringen
aber man merkt so dass Bundesheer
fasziniert denn trotz Schlechtwetter
sondern es ist ein bisschen so nass und
nebelig sind tausende Menschen hier ist
ja Gott sei Dank es zeigt schon auch das
Interesse und der 26 Oktober ist ja doch
hin jedes Jahr ein ein Zeitpunkt wo die
österreichische Bevölkerung sehr gut
sich dafür informieren möchte dazu
informieren möchte was das was das
Bundesheer so macht unter zeigen wir uns
natürlich auch von unserer besten Seite
und zum Abschluss der Vorführung darf
ich noch mehr als an obersten Magister
ade oben drauf übergeben der mit der
Militärmusik Niederösterreich und hier
nochmal karisches gusterstückerl
präsentiert
ja also im Gegensatz zu vorher ist das
jetzt die Militärmusik Niederösterreich
60 Soldaten das sind auch viele
weibliche Soldaten dabei Soldatinnen
nehmen das Angebot in der Militärmusik
gerne an
[Musik]
die bringen jetzt noch den zweiten Teil
des Tattoos was eine Kombination
zwischen marschieren und musizieren ist
und das kann man uns jetzt gut anschauen
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren das war jetzt
noch ein Donauwalzer von der
Militärmusik und das war die
Live-Übertragung der leistungschau des
Bundesheeres der Kranzniederlegung durch
den Bundespräsidenten und die
Bundesregierung und natürlich die
Angelobung von 1000 Rekruten und ich
darf mich an dieser Stelle bei ihnen
beiden für die ausführliche
Informationen für fundiertes
Hintergrundwissen bedanken und wir
verabschieden uns an dieser Stelle von
Ihnen und wünschen noch einen angenehmen
und entspannten Nationalfeiertag auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
rundfl
UG die Herzblatt anzaubern
hier
leider schauen
und hatten sie nicht
bis
dahin
Gänger
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
herzlich willkommen jetzt zu den
nächsten Programmpunkten und als erste
eine Info aufgrund der aktuellen
Wetterlage ist der Absprung der
Fallschirmspringer nicht möglich nicht
weil es uns prinzipiell nicht möglich
wäre so ein reiner Sicherheitsgründen im
Rahmen einer Übung wollen wir eben
dieses Risiko nicht eingehen als
nächstes zeigen wir Ihnen einen kurzen
Einspieler wie es derzeit ausschaut und
danach gibt es eine Info zum Thema
Grundwehrdienst auch als Einspieler
ja sie sehen hier bei dem Einspieler die
Station Katastrophenschutz beim
Burgtheater die Möglichkeiten im Rahmen
der ABC Abwehr aber auch der Pioniere
mit modernsten Gerät ausgestattet
angefangen von Robotern die also unter
Schutz eigener Kräfte hier entsprechend
agieren können aber auch die Möglichkeit
hier zu dekontaminieren zu schützen zu
helfen sie sehen hier auch
Feuerwehrfahrzeuge in grün gehalten sie
sind einen un-checkpunkt Checkpoint hier
am Hof das Thema der
Auslandseinsätze speziell hier auch
Fahrzeuge die eigens dafür geschaffen
werden und ja nützen Sie die Zeit
besuchen Sie auch die anderen bei den
themeninsel beim Burgtheater und am Hof
sie finden dort sehr viel Information
sie haben dort kompetente
Ansprechpartner und speziell natürlich
auch am Hof sehen Sie das Jagdkommando
sie haben Möglichkeiten für sich selber
zu betätigen selbst Teil des Ganzen zu
sein nützen Sie das Ganze und ansonsten
genießen Sie die Zeit hier noch bei uns
und es geht in Kürze hier weiter auf der
Hauptstraße hier am Heldenplatz
als nächsten Programmpunkt wird uns die
Garde hier am Heldenplatz besuchen und
dazu bitte ich als Einstieg einen
Einspieler zum Thema Garde
[Musik]
Kaserne in Wien erste Garde Kompanie da
muss die Tagwache natürlich schon ein
bisschen mehr Stil haben deswegen habe
ich jemanden mitgebracht
Meister bitte
[Musik]
das ist ein neuer schöner Tag bei der
Garde bitte kein Stress sagen wir
einfach in zwei Minuten unten in voller
Motor
[Musik]
in Wien
geradekommando
[Musik]
servus Robert einen wunderschönen guten
Morgen guten Morgen was sind denn jetzt
die Aufgaben
zunächst einmal sind wir verantwortlich
für die Ausbildung von Klaus 500 jungen
Soldatinnen und Soldaten Ausbildung für
den Einsatz sowohl für den
repräsentationseinsatz wo sehr
hinlänglich von der Garde bekannt ist
aber auch für alle anderen
einsatzrelevanten Szenarien Männer wie
Frauen Männer wie Frauen aber ich andere
Aufgaben mit denen sie der Gesellschaft
dienlich sind ja wir unterstützen
natürlich die unterschiedlichsten
karitativen Einrichtungen und haben im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes sehr gute
Instrumente dazu nämlich die Garde Musik
die ein musikalischer Botschafter ist
und darüber hinaus zum Beispiel die
Aktion Licht ins Dunkel wo unsere
Soldaten am 24 Dezember telefonieren
damit die Aktion gut unterstützen
hoffentlich das Produkt dass man erzeugt
ist die Repräsentation und da ist jeder
gleich wichtig egal wo er herkommt und
was er für ein Vorleben hat könnte ich
hier auch mitmachen selbstverständlich
zum Friseur gehen
[Musik]
gut
[Applaus]
einsteigen Niederösterreich und hallo
herzlich willkommen heißen da die Karte
nicht ein repräsentationsverband ist
sondern auch ein infansischer Verband
darfst du heute bei einem
zugsgefechtschießen dabei sein okay das
heißt ich sehe die infanteristische
Ausbildung aus nächster Nähe genau hier
habe ich gleich dich einen Helm das
steht sogar schon miteinander oben und
wir haben für dich heute eine ganz
spezielle Aufgabe ja und zwar ist der
Fundament
ja irgendwie treffen eine der
wichtigsten
[Musik]
okay und wenn du bereit bist wir sind
bereit dann kann man loslegen
[Musik]
01 hier 20 klagemeldung Spitze
angeschossen kläre Lage kommen
[Musik]
so und jetzt schauen wir das ganze mal
in der Nacht an
[Musik]
repräsentiert Österreich die Republik
bei Einsätzen im Inn und im Ausland
macht es auf jedem existiert Platz
einfach eine gute Figur ihr habt nicht
gewusst dass die auch noch eine wirklich
perfekt ausgebildete Kampfgruppe sind
wie alles beherrscht und das auf jeden
terrar das habe ich heute selbst
erfahren
einer hochinteressanter Job und das war
wirklich toll zuzusehen ich gehe jetzt
schlafen ich bin fertig gute Nacht
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren eine
wichtige Durchsage bitte eine wichtige
Durchsage wir suchen einen 7-jährigen
Jungen Name Timo radionon mit einer
blauen Jacke weiße Haube grüne Hose und
einem grünkristall gestreiften Pullover
also wir suchen einen siebenjährigen
Timo radionon mit einer blauen Jacke
darunter eine grüne Hose und mit einem
grün gestreiften Pullover wenn sie ihn
finden er spricht Ukrainisch Russisch
und ein bisschen Englisch bitte nehmen
Sie mit dem nächsten Militärpolizisten
in Ihrer Nähe Kontakt auf
danke
ja meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
und neben mir steht jetzt Hauptmann
Lichtenegger von der Garde und der
nächste Programmpunkt wird wieder ein
Höhepunkt des Tages wir werden die Garde
diesmal in Aktion sehen und ich darf das
Mikro und einen Hauptmann übergeben
Hauptmann lassen Sie uns wissen was wir
jetzt alles hier sehen werden
vielen Dank
wie schon erwähnt mein Name Hauptmann
Lichtenegger ich bin der Kommandant der
vierten gardekompanie sie durften heute
die Ehrenkompanie von uns live sehen und
was die Rekruten können und ich darf
jetzt gleich übergehen
zu ein paar Fakten fakt ist heute ist
ein schlechtes Wetter für sie aber ein
gutes für ein Gardisten weil wir sehr
warm angezogen sind immer wir
kompensieren das aber mit diesen
Auftritten und hierzu gibt es einen
showzug komplett mit Grundwehrdienern
geführt von Oberwachtmeister lazina der
sich dementsprechend ein Programm für
sie überlegt hat
[Musik]
die Garde nur als Eckpfeiler hat ihre
Präsentation und den infanterieauftragt
den Kampfverband
und unser Motto lauertet Ehre und
Pflicht in diesem Sinne darf ich kurz
übergeben
aber ansonsten wünsche ich viel Spaß bei
dieser Show von dem Show zu ich darf
noch einen letzten Hinweis geben es wird
mit knallmunition gearbeitet
dementsprechend kleinere Kinder sollten
nicht unmittelbar vor dem showzug sein
wenn die Waffen nach oben zeigt vielen
Dank
und im Hintergrund in Richtung Inneres
Burgtor hat sich das schonzug bereits
fertig gemacht und wir den Kürze am
Platz erscheinen
Herr Hauptmann eine Frage in welchem
ausbildungsmonat befinden sich die
Grundwehrdiener
das ist eine gute Frage dieser Rekruten
leisten die am Beitrag bis zum letzten
Tag der an die rüsten am Freitag diese
Woche haben und haben noch zwei
ehrenkomparieren eine morgen oder eine
am Freitag
[Musik]
es wird laut
meine Damen und Herren Präzision in
höchstem Ausmaß vom showzug der Garde
und ich darf noch einmal das Mikro einen
Hauptbahnhof geben
ich bedanke mich vielmals für diese
Showeinlage von Teilen meiner company
die machen mich sehr stolz ich bin sehr
stolz diese grundverdiener und auch das
Kader zu führen ich möchte noch einmal
betonen diese Vorführung war nur von
gwds also Grundwert jener Präsenzdienst
ich glaube es ist noch einmal einen
applauswert das Ganze zu feiern aber wir
sind ja nicht auf einem Friedhof also
gibt es
[Applaus]
ja
sehr gut
im Anschluss folgt der nächste Auftritt
dieser Auftritt ist was ganz Besonderes
denn das ist nur von Kader Soldaten der
Garde
diese gardesoldaten haben begonnen diese
sogenannte Grillteam zu entwerfen indem
sie eigens privat eine ma- Garant also
die M1 Garant ist dieser Karabiner
gekauft haben den sie hier jetzt sehen
werden einen Nachbau
wir haben sie privat angekauft haben
damit angefangen vor 15 Jahren hat es so
sich eingetrudelt
und irgendwann hat sich das gefestigt
und heute
mitteilen der ersten Grade Kompanie und
Teil meiner der vierten Garde Kompanie
wird es zu einem besonnenauftritt kommen
in Begleitung natürlich von unserer
Gardemusik ganz geführt und dieser ganze
Performance wird geleitet durch den
sogenannten stoffmeister viele vielkind
er ist so quasi der Captain dieses
Stream Teams und auch für diese ganze
Performance verantwortlich bitte ein
recht herzlichen Applaus mal im vorab
für dieses thrill-team
das ist mir eigentlich noch immer zu
leise also wir sind eigentlich lauter
also
[Applaus]
danke danke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gut ich darf hiermit einleiten
Ausmarsch vielen Dank für Show Zug
und ich darf wieder übergeben meine
Herren
noch einmal einen kräftigen Applaus für
den Show Zug
bis zum letzten Tag Ehre und Pflicht das
ist Österreichs
mögen die Spiele beginnen
[Musik]
eine herzliche Applaus das ist eine
kleine Zwischenpause es geht gleich
weiter
die Waffe mit denen das real Team
arbeitet hat ein Gewicht von 4,8
Kilogramm sie können sich vorstellen
dass es in der Rotation dementsprechend
sehr schwierig ist das zu kontrollieren
ja Frage hat man wie lange oder wie
viele Stunden pro Woche muss man
eigentlich trainieren um so eine
Präzision zu erreichen
salopp gesagt 20 Stunden in der Woche
und mündet dann in einer Überprüfung von
der Garde wo jeder einzelnen Mann ein
eigenes Showteam page bekommt das heißt
quasi eine Art Zertifizierung richtig
dann sind wir schon gespannt was wir als
nächstes sehen werden
so wir haben ein kleines technisches
Gebrechen
wir starten neu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Applaus meine Damen und Herren die hohe
Schule
[Musik]
vielen dank vielen Dank will dem die
musikalische Begleitung von Wachtmeister
Daniel Lesko herzlichen Dank dafür
und auch noch mal Danke
[Applaus]
und musikalische Unterstützung wieder
Militärmusik gerade
eine nebeninformation für das trilream
mittlerweile verfügen international fast
alle Nationen über ein tril-team das
österreichische thrill-team wurde das
letzte Jahr bereits von vielen Nationen
eingeladen und konnte zum Beispiel in
Tschechien Kroatien und Deutschland und
der Beweis stellen was sie können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Applaus für die Teile der Garde
Grillteam und Show Zug und Gardemusik
ein bisschen lauter glaube ich geht das
noch
jawohl dankeschön ich bedanke mich recht
herzlich und darf nicht hier jetzt
abwenden wir haben noch weitere Aufträge
zu erfüllen dafür wieder übergehen
noch einmal ein großer Applaus für die
Garage
und ich darf übergeben an Männern
für den nächsten Programmpunkt
bevor wir starten darf ich mich recht
herzlich für die Unterstützung auch
bedanken der kleine Timo konnte in der
Zwischenzeit wieder seiner Mutter
übergeben werden
und von unseren Experten aus dem Osten
wechseln wir zu einem Experten aus dem
Westen neben mir steht major Markus
Kirchmeier von der sechsten
gebirgsbrigade der hat den weiten Weg
aus Tirol auf sich genommen Markus was
hast du uns aus dem Westen mitgebracht
wir dürfen hier in unserer
Bundeshauptstadt die Gebirgsgruppe
präsentieren dazu ist im Einsatz ein ca
10 Meter hoher Kletterturm eine
Seilrutsche also eine kleine Mutprobe
für junge und alt und einen
Informationsstand der Gebirgsgruppe
ja wir haben natürlich schon gestern
mitbekommen dass alle drei Attraktionen
schon fast zu Mittag ausgebucht waren
und die Schlangen sehr lang waren als
ich würde um Verständnis ersuchen wenn
sie sich heute bitte nicht mehr
anstellen aber lieber Markus es wird
doch sicher wieder mal die Möglichkeit
geben dass ihr euch aus dem Westen daher
begehts in die Bundeshauptstadt wenn
wann ist es denn wieder mal soweit
natürlich Marcel wir dürfen wieder
hoffentlich beim Donauinselfest 2023
teilnehmen sowie beim Nationalfeiertag
2023 unsere nächste Großveranstaltung
ist die Weltmeisterschaft der
Gebirgsjäger in der wattenletzung im
wunderschönen Tirol Ende Februar Anfang
März
jetzt haben wir ja so viele
Ausstellungen hier von den Hubschraubern
über die Panzer was ist denn die
Spezialisierung der sechsten
gebirgsbrigade
die Gebirgsgruppe
kennzeichnet oder zeichnen sich dadurch
aus dass der Einsatz bei schwierigsten
witterungs- und Umwelt Einflüssen
stattfindet im schwierigsten und
extremsten Gelände also unser Auftrag
beginnt grundsätzlich dort wo die
meisten Aufträge der anderen enden
also ich bedanke mich erstens einmal
recht herzlich für die doch
verständliche Aussprache also als
gebürtiger Tiroler hat er sich redlich
bedient und ich glaube das hat sich auch
einen Applaus verdient danke lieber
Markus
und nicht nur er hat sich in den Osten
getraut sondern natürlich auch der
Robert Kratky hat sich an und dazu mal
in den Westen getraut und ich würde
sagen wir schauen uns den nächsten Matz
gemeinsam an
[Musik]
willkommen im schönen Tirol ich bin hier
mit dem Kommandanten verabredet und
pünktlich auf der Minute
herzlich willkommen hier am
guppenübungsplatz
wer hoch hinaus will ist hier gerade
richtig absolut was sind denn die
vorwiegendsten und wichtigsten Aufgaben
für die
pc-stärke liegt aber unter diesen
Umfeldbedingungen und in diesen Geländer
die Aufträge zu erfüllen es heißt was
härteres als die Gebirgsjäger gibt
der Seele braucht man ja das Lager mir
vor probier mal aus wie es mit meiner
Leidensfähigkeit so aussieht sehr gerne
der Bekleidung passt aber du brauchst
ein bisschen Ausrüstung hier
tut mir leid es ist der Rucksack nicht
das Quad ist auch schön ich nehme an
alles drinnen was er gebirgsäge braucht
Handschuhe danke Helm auch ganz wichtig
ich denke ohne das geht in den Bergen
nicht verschütterten Suchgerät
abgefahren neben dem
Witterungsbedingungen ist eben die
lawinenverschüttung Ausrüstung
und einer gebirgsjägerin bitte das
zeigen ich glaube ich sehe sie auch
schon die stört sich da gerade runter
hallo na dann
[Musik]
mitgebracht
beim normalen Spaziergang
sondern gebracht und probieren zu weit
wie möglich zum Schirm
im Gebirge gibt es natürlich nicht nur
Pisten
das im Gegenteil es geht aus die
Stellwände
wir müssen einfach den schwierigen
Gelände auch in der ersten Gelände auf
geht's
[Musik]
Richtung
heute bei mir fest
[Musik]
noch mehr Respekt für die die das
hauptberuflich machen mit hausöstern
und weiters höher und das als Beruf
[Musik]
auch bei dieser Gruppe gibt es natürlich
Spezialisten für alle Fälle zum Beispiel
auch ausgebildete Flugretter
[Musik]
unsere Soldaten haben sie Vorarbeit
geleistet von unserem Hotel es ist noch
nicht ganz fertig aber wir haben bereits
den Zimmerschlüssel dort
[Musik]
ab ins Bett gute Nacht gute Nacht
zum munter werden heiß danke schön
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Gebirgskampf findet natürlich im Gebirge
statt den Kampf habe ich heute auf
allein das Lager ist schon auf 2000
Meter Höhe jetzt immer noch einmal ein
paar Hunderter weiter drüber wo gerade
eine lawinensprengung stattfindet was
ist das jetzt eigentlich irgendwie ein
klassische lawinensprengung oder
die Lösung ist
die OBI fertig zum Zünden zünden
Achtung
[Musik]
so sprechen wir erfolgreich durchgeführt
die Kollegen fahren auf Schienen runter
warum weil sie können
[Musik]
Soldaten unterhalten der hat mir erzählt
er hat vor 20 Jahren die Entscheidung
getroffen zu dieser Gruppe zu stoßen und
das war die beste Entscheidung seines
Lebens der hat hier jeden beruflichen
und persönlichen Traum verwirklicht ich
verstehe was er meint das ist wirklich
eine ganz ganz besondere Truppe hier im
Schnee bei Eiseskälte teilweise unter
widrigsten Bedingungen klettern sprengen
die Rettungseinsätze Assistenz Einsätze
zum Beispiel beim lawinendienst das
Verteidigen der Landesgrenzen mitten im
Nirgendwo wo der Schnee fünf Meter hoch
liegt all das sind Dinge die sind
einfach wahnsinnig beeindruckend und ich
bin so fertig und ich brauche noch
mindestens ein Jahr bis ich das abseil
verdaut habe deswegen verabschiede ich
mich hier aus dem Tiroler Bergen mit
wunderbar
danke fürs dabei sein alles liebe Ciao
[Musik]
ja und aus dem Westen wechseln wir
wieder schrittweise und langsam nach
Wien
kurzer Zwischenstopp in Oberösterreich
und da wir habe ich hier neben mir
mallor Horst towerböck von der internen
Kommunikation wechseln wir doch das
Thema reden wir über die Miliz Horst
warum ist die Miliz so wichtig ja stets
bereit für Österreich unsere Soldatinnen
und Soldaten des Präsenz und des Miliz
Standes die Miliz als Rückgrat unseres
österreichischen Bundesheeres
ich jetzt nicht schöner sagen können und
zu meiner richten eine der Produzenten
des nächsten filmischen Beitrages und
zwar von der uppermedia ihr betreibt er
das erste digitale Jugendzentrum in
Österreich was bedeutet das was kann man
sich da drunter vorstellen ja wir haben
uns die Aufgabe gemacht Jugendarbeit neu
zu denken und dabei haben wir die
digitalen Inhalte für uns gefiltert und
wie beispielsweise hier im
österreichischen Bundesheer das Thema
Miliz aufbereitet und für Jugendliche
konsumiere macht in sozialen Medien und
das ist uns Auftrag weil das normale
Jugendzentrum nicht mehr so funktioniert
und jetzt haben wir es in den digitalen
Raum gebracht und sind sehr froh
gemeinsam arbeiten zu dürfen ja dann
schauen wir uns doch gemeinsam auf der
Leinwand dieses digitale Produkt an ich
würde sagen nächster Matz ab
in der Miliz Kaderausbildung lerne ich
Führungsqualitäten die mir auch im
Berufsleben nützlich sind meine
Qualifikationen kann ich und habe ich
bereits zertifizieren lassen
gleichzeitig bringe ich aber auch meine
zivile Qualifikation in das
österreichische Bundesheer ein und
leiste auch dadurch einen Beitrag für
meine Heimat
[Musik]
als milit Soldat kann ich Verantwortung
übernehmen im Inland und im
Auslandseinsatz zum Beispiel im
Assistenzeinsatz oder als Beitrag in
friedenserhaltenden Einsätzen
obwohl es für Frauen erwerblich gibt
kann ich dennoch freiwillig mein Dienst
für Österreich als milizsoldatin leisten
und mir stehen dort die gleichen
Karrierewege offen
[Musik]
ich melde mich schon im Grunde Diez zum
Miliz und erhalte dadurch weitere
Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten wie auch ab dem
dritten Monat 400 Euro zusätzlich zum
monatsgeld
hier bei dem Protagonisten handelt es
sich um eine ganze milizfamilie
sozusagen und der Vater steht jetzt
links von mir einer der Protagonisten
Herr Dr Kammler wie kam es zu dem Video
die Bekanntschaft und Freundschaft zu
Horst dauerböck und das Philosophieren
über die milits aber auch um umfassende
Landesverteidigung hat genau zu diesem
Ergebnis geführt und es hat uns allen
drei unheimlich viel Spaß gemacht
wie kann man sich das so vorstellen wenn
man als Familie gemeinsam in einen
Einsatz verlegen könnte oder die
unterschiedlichen miliztätigkeiten kann
man das irgendwie Vereinen waren sie
schon gemeinsam in einsetzen
dass die Zeit noch zu kurz außerdem bin
ich auf der milicine das Sanität meine
Tochter ABC Abwehr und der Sohn gerade
in Ausbildung zum Infanteristen also die
Einsätze werden nur dann stattfinden
gemeinsam waren wir auch alle gemeinsam
üben können aber ich hoffe darauf und
freue mich auch schon darauf
ja alle die drei angesprochenen
Waffengattungen haben wir auch heute
hier am Heldenplatz am Hof bzw auch beim
Burgtheater ausgestellt das heißt Sie
können sich jederzeit informieren auch
über die Miliz und ich würde sagen wir
wechseln von Oberösterreich in die
Steiermark und sehen uns den nächsten
matzern
wir sind Menschen aus der Mitte der
Gesellschaft
Menschen mit unterschiedlichsten
Persönlichkeiten und Qualifikationen
doch so unterschiedlich wie auch sind
haben wir doch das gleiche Ziel
gemeinsam für Österreich
[Musik]
was meine Kameraden und mich verbindet
ist der Wille zu helfen so Ziel zu
unseren vielfältigen Aufgaben die
Unterstützung beim Katastrophenschutz
hier wird das Wissen jedes einzelnen
eingebracht bei der Beseitigung von
Unwetterschäden oder bei Hochwasser wir
sind jederzeit zur Stelle
genauso wenn es um die Sicherung unserer
Außengrenzen geht seit Jahrzehnten
leistet die Miliz bei
sicherheitspolizeilichem Assistenz
einsetzen einen unverzichtbaren Beitrag
[Musik]
vor allem üben wir aber auch regelmäßig
für den militärischen Ernstfall denn die
Miliz ist ein elementarer Bestandteil
der militärischen Landesverteidigung
[Musik]
zur Landesverteidigung zählt dabei auch
das Sichern lebensnotwendiger
Infrastruktur im Einsatzfall betrifft
das zum Beispiel die Strom- und
Wasserversorgung
[Musik]
wir das siegerbataillon Steiermark
Erzherzog Johann sind stets bereits für
dich und für unser Österreich
[Musik]
einen wunderschönen Nachmittag am
Heldenplatz ich begrüße sie aufs
herzlichste im Namen der
österreichischen Miliz mein Name ist
Robert speeberg ich bin Milizsoldat ein
Bürger in Uniform wir möchten Ihnen
heute demonstrieren für was die Miliz
steht was die Miliz kann wo wir uns alle
im Einsatz befinden und wer sich hinter
der Miliz versteckt ich freue mich wenn
ich sie damit ermuntern kann zu
überlegen vielleicht doch Teil der Miliz
zu werden wir stehen für Sie bereit auf
der milizinsel und würden uns freuen
über das eine oder andere Gespräch also
herzlich willkommen
diese dynamische Vorführung die wir
Ihnen präsentieren wollen ich lade Sie
herzlichst ein sich in folgendes
Szenario zu versetzen
aufgrund von Unruhen kam es und konnte
es zu einer Flüchtlingswelle die uns ja
mittlerweile sehr bekannt ist die sich
auf Europa zu bewegt die genauen Wege
und Ströme der hilfs- und
schutzbedürftigen Personen und fremden
können derzeit noch nicht genau
vorausgesagt werden
wir das österreichische Bundesheer steht
seit mehreren Wochen im
sicherheitspolizeilichen
Assistenzeinsatz an den österreichischen
Grenzen dass sie mit Sicherheit schon
mitbekommen haben neben der
Streifentätigkeit entlang der Grenze ist
das Bundesheer auch zur Kontrolle
von schutzbedürftigen Personen an
mehreren Grenzübergängen eingesetzt von
ihnen wird ein solcher Vorgang
dargestellt im Einsatz stehen hier
derzeit Soldaten der präsenten Kräfte
die wir hier darstellen an den Zäunen
wir versuchen mit den Zäunen den
Grenzübergang darzustellen transparent
mit Gittern dass man links und rechts
durchschauen kann wie sich denn das von
beiden Seiten anschaut diese führen
Ausweis und Personenkontrollen durch und
leiten dann die Personen an die Behörden
zur daraufwegenden Administration weiter
ich muss dich leider kurz unterbrechen
aber hier neben mir haben wir den
kleinen Nils thomasi der vor wenigen
Minuten beim Kampfpanzer Leopard seinen
Vater verloren hat falls der Vater
zuhört neben mir befindet sich der
kleine Nils thomasi
wir würden sie ja suchen dann einfach
nach vorne zu kommen bei der Vorführung
der kleinen Nils Thomas
der Papa ist sicher gleich wieder da wir
befinden uns bei der Vorführung sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Nils thomasi
sucht seinen Vater der kleine befindet
sich bei uns derzeit
perfekt ein Happy End hat es schon
gefunden gratulation bravo
in unserer Simulation geht es weiter wie
Sie sehen
nimmt der Zustrom immer weiter zu wir
befinden uns in unserer sogenannten
Phase 2 so dass es zur ersten
Verzögerungen bei der Aufnahme von
Personen kommt
eine Reduktion der Genauigkeit von
Kontrollen ist keine Option und unser
Kommandant hat sich entschlossen die
letzten ihm noch zur Verfügung stehenden
Kräfte in den Einsatz zu bringen um den
Zustrom am Kontrollpunkt bewältigen zu
können
weiters gibt ja eine sogenannte
Lagemeldung an das im Vorgesetzte
Kommando durch das vorgesetzte Kommando
befiehlt mit den verfügbaren Kräften den
Einsatz aufrecht zu erhalten was heißt
das mit dem Rückhalt der uns noch zur
Verfügung stehenden Mannschaften
versuchen wir so rasch so professionell
und so sicher als möglich die Aufnahme
zu gewährleisten
sie können sich vorstellen und man
braucht jetzt nur am Heldenplatz den
Blick schweifen zu lassen was Personen
und Menschen Anzahl betrifft wenn Sie
sich jetzt in Bewegung setzen auf einen
Checkpoint zugehen und kontrolliert
werden müssen hier haben wir das in
einer verkleinerten Version gemacht
damit es verständlich werden kann
wir kommen in die dritte Phase die
dritte Phase bedeutet für uns der
Zustrom und wir sehen es an unseren
Darstellern wird immer stärker und der
dadurch entstehende Stau wird immer
größer
menschlich verständlich ist dass diese
Personen die bereits lange auf dem Weg
sind und nun warten müssen ein wenig die
Geduld verlieren
wir denken zum Beispiel hier daran an
die klassische Supermarktkasse wo ich
das siebente in der Warteschlange bin
der achte steht hinter mir und es geht
keine zweite Kasse auf ja also ich denke
jeder hat von uns kennt diese Situation
ist nicht praktisch da der Druck nun
groß genug ist und die Soldaten ihre
Kontrolltätigkeiten nicht mehr
durchführen können
verlangt der Kommandant Unterstützung
er muss allerdings zu diesem Zeitpunkt
den Kontrollpunkt schließen
Verschließen des Kontrollpunktes hat den
tieferen Sinn dass keine Unruhe und
unkontrollierte Maßnahmen passieren und
sind voll Entscheidungen getroffen
werden können
und einerseits die Präsidenten Kräfte
die bereits seit längerer Zeit im
Einsatz stehen aus diesen herauslösen zu
können
um für den Fall einer weiteren
Eskalation der Gesamtlage noch genügend
Reserven zu haben wurde durch die
österreichische Bundesregierung die
Teilmobilmachung angeordnet das bedeutet
nun bestimmte Teile aller milizverbände
und milizanteile mobil gemacht sprich
einberufen werden damit ist die Miliz
die strategische Reserve des
österreichischen Bundesheeres
die milzoldaten Rücken in einem solchen
Fall in einen vorgegebenen Sammelraum
ein ich denke einige von uns die sich
hier im Heldenplatz befinden sind
gestandene Milizsoldaten Wagen stand
eine Milizsoldaten und wissen was dies
zu bedeuten hat wir sehen das im
Hintergrund bereits sehr aktiv engagiert
und spontan wie ich sehe sogar aus dem
Besuchern heraus einige die versuchen
ihre Kameraden der Miliz zu unterstützen
ein herzliches Dankeschön übrigens dafür
der Bürger in Uniform also wir
legt seine Zivilkleidung ab und trägt
stattdessen ohne Form die soll mir nicht
Soldaten kommen aus den
unterschiedlichsten Berufsgruppen und
unterschiedlichste Berufsgruppen
bedeutet nicht nur der Bäcker nicht nur
der Anwalt nicht nur der Tankwarts nein
auch Opernsängern sind dabei es sind
Künstler dabei es sind Leute aus dem
öffentlichen Leben dabei der
Straßenbahnfahrer der Straßenkehrer es
sind
Generaldirektoren dabei und es sind
Spezialisten wie Ärzte und weiteres
Fachpersonal ein klassischer Querschnitt
der österreichischen Gesellschaft das
macht die österreichische Miliz sehr
stark
im Einsatzraum eingetroffen wird nun die
Situation in Zusammenwirken der
Präsidenten Kräfte und der Milizsoldaten
bewältigt sie sehen jetzt das Ausrüsten
der Kameraden das Anlegen der Kleidung
das Umrüsten vom zivilen ins
militärische
als auch das bereit halten und sie sehen
auch es geht hier nicht nur um den
Schutz sondern es geht hier auch um die
Sicherheit wir haben ein Ärzteteam dabei
wir haben Sanitäter dabei das heißt wir
versuchen helfen wo andere vielleicht
nicht mehr helfen können und die
Bewältigung der Sicherungsmaßnahme an
der geschlossenen Grenze zu unterstützen
mit Kräften die nun durch die militäre
angeführt werden
aber nicht nur im Falle einer
Teilmobilmachung oder Mobilmachung
stemilitsoldaten gemeinsam mit dem
präsenten Kräften im Einsatz derzeit
stehen tausende milizsoldatinnen und
Soldaten
bei Einsätzen des österreichischen
Bundesheeres nicht nur im ihn sondern
auch im Ausland im Einsatz in der
Unterstützung der laufenden In- und
Auslandseinsätze ist nicht nur der
Schutz der kritischen Infrastruktur
sondern auch die Unterstützung in der
Pandemie sie werden sich vielleicht die
Wienerinnen und Wiener erinnern an St
Marx an die Wiener Stadthalle durch das
österreichische Bundesheer unterstützt
und hier auch durch große Teile der
österreichischen Milizsoldaten das heißt
Personen haben ihre Zivilkleidung
ausgezogen und haben
kameradschaftlich Personen unterstützt
bei der Bewältigung unserer Pandemie
wie Sie sehen formiert sich der Teil der
Miliz und unterstützt aktiv durch
Eingriff und Zuzug der Kommandant hat
entschieden hier großartige Hilfe zu
leisten
der Kommandant hat eine Entscheidung
getroffen dass ich die Gesamtlage im
Umfeld auch entspannt hat werden nun
aktuell nicht mehr so viele Soldaten im
Einsatz zum Schutz unserer Heimat
benötigt
und somit
und jetzt kommt das große umblättern
und somit werden die Kameraden der Miliz
schlussendlich wieder aus dem
Einsatzraum herausgelöst und in weiterer
Folge wieder demobilisiert sprich sie
tauschen wieder Uniform gegen die
zivilgewand die Simulation die Sie hier
sehen ist eine gestellte Simulation die
uns darstellen soll wie schwierig es ist
auch ohne Vorbereitung und das ist hier
sehr spontan zusammengezogen worden eine
echte reale Situation darzustellen fakt
ist unsere Leute unsere Damen und
Kameraden und Kameradinnen sind gerüstet
jederzeit bereit zu sein für uns für die
österreichische Bevölkerung da zu sein
ich danke unseren Kameradinnen und
Kameraden dass sie diesen spontanen
Einsatz gemacht haben und möchte das
Mikrofon an dieser Stelle dem
Kommandanten des Jägerbataillons Wien
zwei Maria Theresia Herne Hof übergeben
er hat noch ein paar Worte
danke dir für die Moderation sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren mein Name ist
Markus hornhoff ich bin Kommandant des
jägerpatron Wien 2 die heute sich hier
verantwortlich zeigen im Zusammenwirken
mit vielen anderen Kameraden der Miliz
hier die Station milizinsel zu betreiben
als auch diese Vorführung durchzuführen
ich möchte Ihre Lanze brechen für die
Kameraden der Miliz die neben ihrem
Hauptberuf sehr viel Zeit auch Freizeit
aufwenden um hier dem Staat Österreich
der Republik und auch Ihnen verehrte
Staatsbürgerinnen und Staatsbürger zu
dienen und ich möchte auch hier einen
Appell an alle Chefs an alle
Wirtschaftstreibenden und
Manager von Firmen
tätigen ich weiß in Zeiten wie diesen
ist es schwer gute Leute zu entbehren
aber ich würde sie um wirklich um
Unterstützung ersuchen weil sehr viele
Milizsoldaten müssen viele Tätigkeiten
in Ihrem Urlaub nachkommen weil die
Firmen wenig Verständnis oder auch aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen hier die
abkömmigkeit nicht gewähren und um
diesen Zusammenhang am heutigen Tag wo
so viele Worte gesprochen wurden möchte
ich hier dem ein oder anderen Appell
einfach an Sie richten wenn sie
Milizsoldaten in ihren Reihen haben in
ihren Firmen in ihren Betrieben sie
haben einen Mehrwert sie haben einen
Mehrwert dahingehend weil ihre
Angestellten erstens in ihrem Beruf gute
Leistung bringen und weil sie diese
Tätigkeiten diese Eigenschaften
Kompetenzen die sie in ihrer
militärischen Ausbildung erlernt haben
auch meistens zum Wohle ihres Betriebes
einbringen können in diesem Sinne danke
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit es lebe die
Miliz es lebe die Republik Österreich
danke
[Applaus]
danke sehr bevor wir zum nächsten
Programmpunkt schreiten darf ich
nochmals erinnern dass wir ja unser
Gewinnspiel immer noch am Laufen haben
also wenn Sie heute einer von zehn
glücklichen Gewinnern sein möchten der
heute den Heldenplatz vielleicht mit
einem Hubschrauber verlässt dann starten
Sie zum karrierezelt des Bundesheeres
füllen Sie einen Zettel aus und
vielleicht gehören Sie zu einem der zehn
Glücklichen die heute hier vom
Heldenplatz noch in einem Hubschrauber
abheben als nächstes und als Würdigung
für die Miliz möchten wir vier Filme ins
Rennen schicken die von einem
Oscar-Preisträger von einem
österreichischen Filmregisseur und
drehautor richtig von Stefan rusowitzki
gedreht worden und ich würde sagen meine
Damen und Herren die die sich nicht auf
den Weg zum karrierezelt machen weil sie
keine Lust auf Helikopterfliegen haben
die Wenden ihren Blick wieder auf die
Leinwand und wir schauen uns die nächste
Matz an
[Musik]
Verteidigung werden und die haben
natürlich auch gut
[Musik]
für mich alleine durch diesen Konflikt
ist die Übung jetzt eine ganz andere
durch den Konflikt rückt
ich persönlich neben mir auch war dass
ich die Motivation und die Einstellung
um 180 Grad gedreht hat weil ich einfach
sehe dass die reale Bedrohungen wirklich
vorhanden sind
greift an mit egoFM an und werfen sein
im
Raum
in Europa klären das Land also
die haben tatsächlich Kinos verteidigen
bei mir im Bekanntenkreis waren jetzt
erstaunlicherweise einige Leute die
vorher absolut pazifistisch eingestellt
waren im Sinne überhaupt kein
Kriegsgerät bedeutet überhaupt kein
Krieg die ihre Meinung jetzt sehr stark
geändert haben
[Musik]
Sprichwort das heißt kämpfen können und
nicht kämpfen zu müssen
[Musik]
die passen auf uns und da schaut gut aus
wo drauf verlassen kannst für uns ist
das ganz normal wir sind die ganze Zeit
in der jeder von uns auf der Welt ist
und in Österreich lebt wir leben in
einer Demokratie jeder darf sagen was er
für richtig hält ja jeder hat er freie
Meinung das ist bei uns möglich und das
ist auch das ist auch wert also das ist
riesen riesen Luxus
mein Name ist Anna Kaiser ich bin
assistenzprofessorin für
Kulturgüterschutz an der Universität für
Weiterbildung Krems einen wunderschönen
guten Morgen
militärisch war ich die letzten fünf
Jahre kompaniekommandantin der
jägerkompanet
bin der Daniel Strasser bin seit 22
Jahren jetzt an der Volksgruppe dann
Wien ich habe mich entschlossen mich zum
Scharfschützen ausbilden zu lassen um
die kritische Infrastruktur schützen zu
können
schutzkritische Infrastruktur ist
sicherlich eine der ganz wichtigen
Aufgaben des österreichischen
Bundesheers einfach weil es um das
alltägliche Leben der Österreicherinnen
und Österreicher geht da geht es um
Krankenhäuser es geht um
verkehrsnotenpunkte es geht um Einkaufen
es geht wenn man es bisschen überspitzt
formulieren möchte um es überleben der
Bevölkerung
[Musik]
zum schutzkritische Infrastruktur
braucht es nicht unbedingt das was man
sich jetzt als Angriffskrieg vorstellt
oder Landesverteidigung Österreichs es
kann auch viel viel früher eintreten
denkt man die covid-krise 2020 vor allem
denkt man aber auch an Naturkatastrophen
oder auch ein Terroranschläge
[Musik]
während bezogen
ich bin stolz dass ich als Milizsoldat
zur Sicherheit der Menschen in
Österreich beitragen kann
es ist die Familie es sind die Lieben
daheim es ist es ist unsere Kultur auf
die wir so stolz sind ja das ist zu
schützen das ist ja gar nicht mehr so
weit weg jetzt ja also Russland Ukraine
das ist diese paar hundert Kilometer
dann macht man sich natürlich Gedanken
die aktuellen Entwicklungen in der
Ukraine ist der Begriff Krieg viel
realer geworden wenn es denn so weit ist
werde ich schießen
ich habe keine moralischen oder
ethischen Probleme für Österreich die
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher da zu
sein und sie eben Notfall auch zu
verteidigen
lamsten Robin Rechtsanwalt in Österreich
und in den USA und in meiner
Milizfunktion bin ich Offizier beim
Jagdkommando
als junger Mensch hat mich natürlich
auch das Abenteuer bei Militär und
insbesondere beim JA Kommando fasziniert
und angezogen aber es ist viel mehr als
ein Abenteuer ich bin bei der Miliz aus
Überzeugung aus Patriotismus und weil
ich mir sicher bin dass ich sehr viel
vom Militär gelernt habe und ich bin
stolz darauf
eine Konflikt zeigt uns dass es ein
Bundesheer ein starkes bundesheerbedarf
und das die Stimmen die davon ausgehen
dass es keine Konflikte mehr geben wird
doch verstummen wir wünschen sonst aber
es ist nicht realistisch in der Ukraine
sieht man dass Menschen bereit sind für
Vaterland zu kämpfen oder für ihre
Umgebung für einen Ort für ihre Gemeinde
für alles was ihnen etwas wert ist
ich habe viel Zeit im Ausland verbracht
und viele Jahre in Amerika gelebt und
besonders wenn man von außen wieder
zurück nach Österreich kommt weiß man
eigentlich was Österreich zu bieten hat
welche Qualitäten österreich hat man
kann bei uns das Wasser trinken wir
haben eine tolle Sozialversicherung wir
haben viele Errungenschaften und ich
glaube dass der Blick von außen vielen
helfen könnte sich auch Gedanken dazu zu
machen bin ich bereit dies zu
verteidigen
[Musik]
mein Name ist Robert Lamprecht im
Zivilberuf arbeite ich bei einer
wirtschaftsprüfungskanzlei dort im
Bereich cybersicherheit im militärischen
habe ich den Dienstgrad mallor und
unterstütze des Bundesheer mit meinen
Kenntnissen und der Expertise die ich
aus meinem beruflichen Leben mitgenommen
habe diese Erfahrungen die wir
mitbringen können natürlich sehr
vielfältige eingesetzt werden im Bereich
der ABC Abwehr wo wir
strahlenphysiker Chemiker und
dergleichen haben im Gesundheitsbereich
die Ärzte aber auch Juristen oder
technische Berufe man glaubt gar nicht
wie vielfältig die Möglichkeiten sind
dieses cyber-feld dürfen wir nicht
unterschätzen es ist zwar immer relativ
still und wir merken es nicht direkt
aber der Auswirkungen sind doch sehr
sehr unangenehm wir sehen die Bilder wo
ein Stau an der polnisch ukrainischen
Grenze war der Grenzübertritt war nicht
möglich weil die Systeme für die
Grenzabfertigung der Ukrainer
entsprechend gelöscht wurden durch
angreifen
[Musik]
Ukraine kriegt man sicherlich zu einem
wachrütteln geführt das heißt das was
man vorher für unmöglich gehalten hat
ist von einem Tag auf den anderen mehr
oder weniger Realität geworden
inwieweit ich mich für einen Staat
einsetze ist natürlich auch eine
Haltungsfrage weil bin hier groß
geworden ich bin hier geboren ich darf
die Vorzüge dieses Staates und dieses
Landes genießen und wenn es wirklich
hart auf hart kommt muss ich auch die
Souveränität und meine eigene
Souveränität entsprechend verteidigen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren willkommen
zurück und bevor wir mit dem nächsten
Act weitermachen also mit der
Justizwache darf ich noch verkünden dass
ein Schlüssel verloren wurde ich zeige
Ihnen die Kamera
bis zum Ende der Veranstaltung darf
dieser Schlüssel gerne bei mir abgeholt
werden es befinden sich zwei Schlüssel
drauf nachdem ich selbst einige
schlüsselbesitze macht es keinen Sinn
wenn ihr die Nummern vorlese aber ich
zeige es noch mal her
mit Clip der wurde beim Husar gefunden
also wer heute das einen Schlüssel
verloren hat bis 17 Uhr noch bei mir so
und bevor es jetzt weitergeht bitte ich
die Justizwache hier auf dem Platz
riesen Applaus für die Justizwache meine
Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Tag meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren es ist uns
eine Ehre und Freude die Justizwache und
insbesondere die Justizwache
Einsatzgruppe hier mit einer ganz einer
kurzen effektiven Vorführung darstellen
zu dürfen ich darf zunächst den
Kommandanten der Einsatzgruppe und die
Einsatzgruppe
unterschiedlicher Justizanstalten
begrüßen wir werden Ihnen hier
unterschiedliche Szenarien da bieten
wobei die erste Szenario sofort mit
einem sogenannten thesa Schuss beginnt
während sich die Kollegen vorbereiten
darf ich Ihnen einiges über die
Justizwache erzählen bzw die Justizwache
Einsatzgruppe wir haben 28
Justizanstalten in Österreich
davon gibt es in jeder Justizanstalt
sind Einsatzgruppen eingerichtet mit
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das heißt die
Damen und Herren werden nach einem
Auswahltest einer mehrwöchigen
Ausbildung unterzogen die es sehr sehr
viele Inhalte und Aspekte
Bedarf bzw die Ausbildung in Modulen
gestaltet ist das beinhaltet das
Einsatztraining das Waffentraining
jedoch auch das dekalationstraining
menschenrechtstraining Taktik schießen
und vieles vieles mehr es sind sehr
aufwendige anspruchsvolle
Ausbildungswochen die die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen hier zu absolvieren haben
zunächst gibt es die erste Vorführung
wir haben hier sie müssen sich
vorstellen einen Insassen ein
sogenannter benennen in Bösewicht aber
er ist ein ganz ein lieber sein Kollege
von uns erstellt nur einen böser weg da
er wird nun gegen die Kollegen in hier
etwa einige Holzstücke werfen wird dann
aggressiv sein wird gegen die Schilder
treten und die Kollegen werden zunächst
mit raschen griffen überwältigen
Kollege gibt die Kommandos es geht los
sie sehen ja die Kollegen haben
Schutzschilder schützen sich gegen
bewürfe gegen Schläge gegen Dritte ja
unser lieber Kollege ist nicht mehr so
lieb er nimmt ein besenstange und hier
setzt der Attacken der er tritt gegen
die Schutzschilder erschlägt darauf ja
er ist schon recht grantig
möglicherweise hat er hier nichts zu
essen bekommen Kollegen übernehmen ihn
mit einfachen Griffen bringen ihn zu
Boden sie sehen er bleibt natürlich
unverletzt es ist uns ganz ganz wichtig
unser gegenüber den sämtlichen
Amtshandlungen in Einsatz Techniken
unverletzt zu halten
der Bösewicht wird nun abtransportiert
versorgt und dann
wirkt er jetzt was zum Essen dass er
nicht mehr so grantig ist bzw nicht mehr
so böse ist er muss nämlich dann noch
mal auftreten
der nächste Part den wir sehen ist die
Basics die Basis der einsatzstechnik der
Justizwache Einsatzgruppe diese
sogenannten Grip ducript-techniken wo
ganz einfache Grifftechniken an den
Armen beziehungsweise
reine Techniken die fixieren
festhaltegriffe beinhalten dargestellt
werden
alle diese Technik haben eine Nummer und
können auf Kommando abgerufen werden
sie sehen hier der ganze Körper wird
behandelt und mit fixieren
festhaltegriffe bzw griffen wo das
Gegenüber zu Boden gebracht wird
beantragen
in weiterer Folge kommt auch der
teleskopeinsatzstock
zur Anwendung wobei wir hier ebenfalls
Spezialtechniken entwickelt haben mit
denen wir nicht schlagen müssen sondern
wir handelt es sich um einen fixier und
Festhaltetechnik und in weiterer Folge
in Transporttechniken
auch hier sehen Sie diese Griffe sind
gut trainiert können jederzeit abgerufen
werden auch in Stresssituationen
jederzeit
das Gegenüber beamtshandelt werden
Einsatzgruppen Mitglieder trainieren in
den Justizanstalten regelmäßig sie haben
unterschiedliche Trainingseinheiten wie
ich schon erwähnt habe Einsatztaktik
Schießen mit Pistolen und Langwaffen
auch die
elektroimpuls-pistole der Tesa X2 wird
regelmäßig trainiert mit denen die
Kollegen umgehen müssen und können
müssen vielen Dank für die zweite
Einheit dankeschön
gleich im Anschluss zeigen die Kollegen
Schlag und tritt Techniken die natürlich
auch insbesondere zum Konditionsaufbau
trainiert werden müssen und sollen die
zwar nicht im Einsatz zum Schlagen
kommen aber beherrscht werden müssen es
ist ganz ganz wichtig dass unsere
Kollegen sowohl mental als auch
körperlich fit sind und auf jeder Lage
perfekt vorbereitet sind
hier sehen Sie dass der
Kollege mit dem Messer zusticht und der
andere Kollege mit dem sogenannten
teleskopeinsatzstock ja diesen
Messerangriff abwehrt
auch hier zeigen wir wieder Schlag und
dritttechniken die natürlich nur
gestellt sind wir haben hier eine Show
nur damit sie sehen wie diese Techniken
ausschauen könnten
ich sag gleich dazu es ist eine
Live-Show ja sollten hier Fehler
passieren dann ist das kein Problem wie
im echten Leben ist das auch so unseren
Kollegen passieren sie ganz ganz selten
bis nie dementsprechend schaut diese
Show flüssig und elegant aus
die Kollegen machen diese Tätigkeit
freiwillig neben ihrem normalen
Regeldienst sind in der Justizanstalt
etabliert und werden bei Bedarf gerufen
und kommen
wenn Not am Mann ist und da Kamera waren
nicht im Weg steht nichts passiert
gut auch hier wieder Angriff mit dem
Messer Messer wird Kollege wird
entwaffnet Messer kommt weg
Kollege bleibt natürlich unverletzt
auch hier weitere Techniken die
blocktechnik Abwehrtechniken fixiere
Transporttechnik und hier sogenannte
takedown-
sie sehen hier Schlagtechniken
blocktechniken und natürlich
wieder takedown-techniken
nächsten Techniken die hier gezeigt
werden
setzen diese schlagentechnik fort mit
höheren
Schwierigkeitslevel
Kollege wird zu Boden gebracht
überwältigt
alles kein Problem
sie sind ja Spezialtechniken
bin schon aufgefallen ist haben wir hier
keine komplizierten Wurftechniken
sondern es geht um das sanfte Ablegen
des Gegenübers damit beide Seiten immer
unverletzt bleiben
auch hier blocktechniken
eine Wurftechnik dabei sogenannter
Hüftwurf
wir verfügen über eine Menge an
Schutzausrüstung Waffen
und anderer Einsatzmitteln bei uns
werden sowohl Damen und auch Herren
gleich trainiert kommen gleich zum
Einsatz sie sehen dann in weiterer Folge
auch eine Kollegin die dann mit dem Tesa
Arbeiten wird auch in der
Ausbildungsschiene setzen wir 100%ig die
unsere Damen und Herren gleichermaßen
ein und beziehungsweise werden diese
genauso gefordert wie wie die Damen und
Herren
hier sehen Sie mehrere Techniken
Wurftechniken fixiertechniken und nun
mit so das sogenannte teaming teaming
mehrere Kollegen setzen kompilierte
einsatzstechniken am Gegenüber an um
dieses zu überwältigen und in weiterer
Folge gesichert abtransportieren zu
können
nun haben wir einige Technik mit dem
sogenannten teleskopeinsatzstock die von
uns speziell für
anwendungsschonendes entwickelt wurden
Transporttechniken
Abwehrtechniken und wieder fixiertechnik
die Kombination mit dem
teleskopeinsatzstopp durchgeführt werden
wir sehen uns eine sogenannte
bodycontrol und eine amtkontrolle
wenn es kommt immer als Abwehrmittel zum
Einsatz und den weiterer Folge als
fixier und Transport nimmt
die Techniken sind sehr schnell gezeigt
müssen aber sehr lange trainiert werden
vielen Dank dafür
zum Abschluss benötigen wir wieder unser
lieben Kollegen den Bösewicht
der diesmal mit einem Schutzanzug mit
einem flauschanzug ausgerüstet ist ein
Messer in der Hand hat und eine Attacke
auf die Justizwache darstellt er
attackiert die Kollegin und die Kollegen
mit seinem Messer wobei auch hier
wichtig natürlich die Kommunikation ein
ganz ein wichtiger Teil ist unsere
stärkste Waffe ist das Wort
und erst dann kommen andere Mitteln zum
Einsatz hier für die Show wird natürlich
unser Gegenüber taktisch
überwältigt und dann mit dem Tesa zu
Boden gebracht
so
die Kollegin mit der gelben Waffe mit
dem sogenannten Tesa
sieht sich an eine taktische
Positionierung zurück
sprich den Täter an
Täter will nicht es kommt zum Tesa
Beschuss
der Bösewicht versteift sich einen durch
eine Muskelkontraktion wird zu Boden
gebracht bleibt unverletzt und kann
geschützt durch den Taser der noch einen
reserveschutz hat
visitiert werden anschließend
abtransportiert werden
das Messer wurde bereits abgenommen
bei Einsätzen gibt es sind immer
Kollegen dafür da die sogenannten
angriffsmitteln zu sichern und das Tesa
hat und das Messer abzunehmen
nun werden die Kabel noch abgeschnitten
und Tesa bzw die Pfeile entfernt keine
Angst es handelt sich hier um
klettpfeile
die auf dem flauschanzug für
Trainingszwecke gut haften bleiben gut
Kollege
Kollegen transportieren ab sichern das
Messer wie schon gesagt und Bösewicht
wird abtransportiert
das ist natürlich nur ein kleiner Auszug
aus unseren unzähligen vielen
langwierigen stundenlangen
Trainingseinheiten die hier sehr einfach
aussehen aber es ist ein Unterschied ob
man sowas im turnsal trainiert
beziehungsweise
ohne so viel Publikum bezaubern das
tolles Publikum oder auf einem
Asphaltboden vor so vielen Menschen es
ist uns trotzdem eine große Ehre die
Justizwache Einsatzgruppe darstellen zu
dürfen präsentieren zu dürfen
zum Abschluss darf ich die Kollegen und
Kolleginnen sobald sie ihre
Einsatzmitteln Ausrüstungsgegenstände
versorgt haben auf meine Seite bieten da
wir noch ein kurzes Video für Sie
vorbereitet haben da wir nicht nur
unsere einsatz-techniken unsere
Einsatzmittel unsere Dienstwaffen
darstellen möchten sondern hier in
diesem Video auch unsere Fähigkeiten und
Fertigkeiten und insbesondere unsere
Haltung vermitteln möchten denn dafür
stehen wir
bitte um Abspielen des Videos
wir die Einsatzgruppe der Justizwache
durchlaufen eine komplexe Ausbildung
trainieren den sicheren Umgang mit
unseren Einsatzmitteln und kommen dort
zum Einsatz wo andere Unterstützung
benötigen
wir agieren im Team gehen an unser Limit
und darüber hinaus das Ziel immer klar
vor Augen im Tränen geschult um im
Einsatz bestmöglich vorbereitet zu sein
dadurch sind wir Komplikationen auch in
Extremsituationen gewachsen und
bewältigen diese Aufgaben effektiv und
kompetent
wir lösen Konflikte und sind uns unserer
Verantwortung stets bewusst durch
spezialisierte aus- und Weiterbildungen
sind wir in der Lage unseren
anspruchsvollen Tätigkeiten immer mit
dem notwendigen Know-how
entgegenzutreten
die Mitglieder der Einsatzgruppe
verstehen sich als Hüter der
Menschenwürde und Menschenrechte Handeln
im Rahmen der Verhältnismäßigkeit um den
Schutz der Menschen respektvoll zu
gewährleisten denn menschlichkeit ist
unser Credo wir betrachten
Gewissenhaftigkeit Sorgfalt Flexibilität
und Innovation als
Selbstverständlichkeit
mentale Stärke Belastbarkeit und
körperliche Fitness Geld bei uns als
Grundvoraussetzung täglich stehen wir
als Einheit füreinander ein und
betrachten es als unser oberstes Ziel
unseren Mitmenschen zu helfen dafür
gehen wir an unsere Grenzen um immer
einen Schritt voraus zu sein Sicherheit
Schutz und Vertrauen haben auch in
unserem Einsatzbereich einen hohen
Stellenwert wir trainieren Körper und
Geist Handeln effektiv tragen
Verantwortung und zeigen immer hohe
Leistungsbereitschaft unsere
Einsatzgruppen Mitglieder sorgen täglich
für den personellen und materiellen
Schutz innerhalb und außerhalb der
Justizanstalten als Team Seite an Seite
für Sicherheit und Ordnung unter den
Prämissen der Menschlichkeit und der
Professionalität dafür stehen wir die
Einsatzgruppe der österreichischen
Justizwache
danke das war das Video von der
Justizwache Einsatzgruppe ich wurde
gerade vom Kollegen vom Militär gefragt
warum unsere Kollegen vermummt sind
erstens ist es ganz ganz wichtig auch
das Gesicht zu schützen auch im Einsatz
weil wir möglicherweise mit
Flüssigkeiten kontaminiert werden weil
es möglicherweise weil wir auch mit
Brand zu tun haben es sind auch wir
haben auch Brandschutz haben nicht nur
anonymisierungshauben und in weiterer
Folge haben auch die Kollegen
Persönlichkeitsrechte und möchten hier
nicht erkannt werden insbesondere in
dieser Vorführung wo sehr sehr viele
Handyvideos vermutlich gemacht werden
und es hat einen tollen Schuhe Effekt
gut ich darf mich bei Ihnen recht
herzlich bedanken wir sind mit ihrer mit
unserer kurzen Vorführung am Ende ich
darf euch bei der Kollegin und bei den
Kollegen recht herzlich bedanken vielen
Dank für diesen kurzfristigen
vorbereiteten Trainingsablauf herzlichen
Dank und ich darf Ihnen noch recht
herzlich einen schönen Tag wünschen und
ein weiteres gutes Gelingen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
in diesem Sinne möchte ich mich auch
noch mal recht herzlich bei der
heeresbildung bedanken sie werden es
gerade mitbekommen haben ein Kameramann
der recht außer Atem hier neben mir
gestanden ist weil er natürlich versucht
die Bilder so gut wie möglich für Sie
auch einzufangen damit wir diese auch
auf die Leinwand bringen
ich möchte hier noch mals betonen ich
habe nach wie vor einen Schlüssel hier
bei mir es handelt sich nicht um den
Schlüssel zu meinem Herzen sondern
wahrscheinlich um einen Schlüssel zu
einer Wohnung oder zu einem Büro ich
darf Sie daher suchen dass sie diesen
Schlüssel bis spätestens 17 Uhr bei mir
abholen des Weiteren auch noch mal
darauf hingewiesen unser Gewinnspiel
bevor unsere Hubschrauber hier um 16 Uhr
15 abheben würde ich sie ja suchen dass
sie beim karrierestand des Bundesheeres
vorbeischauen und vielleicht einer der
zehn glücklichen Gewinnerinnen oder
Gewinner sind die dann hier vom
Heldenplatz mit einem Blackhawk abheben
ja und bevor wir zum nächsten
Programmpunkt kommen darf ich noch mal
um einen recht herzlichen Applaus für
unsere Justizwache bitten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Blick zu Justizwache
ja und was steht bei uns noch am
Programm wir haben heute noch ein
Panzerballett hier zu bieten wir haben
noch eine sportvorführung die
Hubschrauber werden dann zu späterer
Stunde natürlich auch wieder abheben wie
schon bereits angekündigt aber wir
werden auch uns um die Luftstreitkräfte
noch mal etwas genauer kümmern das
bedeutet wir holen nicht nur die Piloten
vor den Vorhang sondern zeigen auch die
Videos wie unsere Luftstreitkräfte
funktionieren das bedeutet es gibt
Bodenpersonal Techniker Piloten und
dieses ganze Zusammenspiel werden wir
uns dann im nächsten Programmpunkt
ansehen unsere luftschaltkräfte bis
dahin würde ich ja suchen zwei bis fünf
Minuten Pause und wir treffen uns dann
hier wieder zur nächsten Vorführung
danke
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf
sie abermals um ihre Aufmerksamkeit
ersuchen ich habe hier neben mir die
Kleine Sina die ihren Vater sucht
bitte einmal zur Leinwand der Blick auf
die Leinwand wir suchen den Vater von
Sina
bitte nach vorne kommen zum Platz der
dynamischen Vorführung we are looking
for the father of Sina
little girl is standing right next to me
we are still looking for the father of
Sina little girl right next to me wir
suchen den Vater von Sina die hier zu
meiner Linken steht
bitte nach vorne kommen zur Vorführung
[Applaus]
und auch hier sehen Sie die perfekte
Zusammenarbeit zwischen der Exekutive
und dem Bundesheer hat wieder zu einem
Happy End geführt
ja meine Damen und Herren ich darf sie
noch darauf hinweisen bis 17 Uhr können
Sie alles was hier am Platz noch steht
besichtigen
raufklettern einsteigen sich das
anschauen besuchen Sie die Zelte
informieren Sie sich und denken Sie
daran wir werden dann in Kürze eine
Vorführung haben der beiden Panzer die
hier in Richtung des äußeren
burgverständnis diese Fahrzeuge können
sie werden dazu das eine oder andere
interessante erfahren und ansonsten
nützen Sie die Zeit schauen Sie sich an
was wir haben und ich darf es noch
darauf hinweisen dass die Hubschrauber
heute noch abfliegen werden die Panzer
werden das Gelände verlassen und um 17
Uhr gibt es dann das offizielle Ende den
Zapfenstreich geblasen vom Solothurn
Peter der Garde hier als offizielles
Ende bleiben sie noch bei uns genießen
Sie die Vorführungen und wir melden uns
in Kürze wieder mit den nächsten
Informationen
[Musik]
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wie sie vorhin schon gehört haben geht
es um Berufsbilder die es beim
österreichischen Bundesheer gibt unter
anderem auch um den Schutz in der
dritten Dimension um Soldaten bei den
Luftstreitkräften und dazu haben wir
jetzt einen kurzen Einspieler
vorbereitet
Respekt hier beim Bundesheer braucht
echt keine durchstarten
[Musik]
ja ein ganz kurzer Überblick und Marcel
hat es vorhin schon erwähnt wir
benötigen Soldaten sowohl für die
Flughafenfeuerwehr wir benötigen die
Soldaten für die Luftraumüberwachung für
die Piloten egal ob jetzt Hubschrauber
Fläche oder den Eurofighter und all das
konnten sie jetzt vor kurzem im Rahmen
der Airpower 2022 in Zeltweg sehen die
größte Airshow in Europa nicht nur mit
den Luftstreitkräften der
österreichischen Bundesheeres sondern
auch mit Luftstreitkräften aus dem
Ausland mit Shootings unter anderem
waren die fragert die colore dabei und
dazu möchten wir Ihnen jetzt noch einen
kurzen Rückblick zeigen
[Musik]
ja ein kurzer Rückblick von der auf die
Airpower 2022 meine Damen und Herren und
wir kommen nun zum nächsten
Programmpunkt es geht um das Thema
gehärtete und robuste Einsätze es geht
um die Panzertruppe wir haben vorhin
Szenarien gesehen wo Soldaten in als
Infanterist im Einsatz waren aber
irgendwann kommt der Zeitpunkt wo sie
einfach entsprechende Schutz und
schweres Gerät brauchen das ist die
mechanisierte Truppe und dazu haben wir
wieder einen kurzen Einspieler
vorbereitet mit Robert Kratky
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in Wels Panzer bei
der jung 14 und ich werde die
Herrschaften jetzt mal aufwecken Tag war
offensichtlich bin zu spät hallo
robertal mitgebracht
[Musik]
und bist schon oben sehr gut hier ist
dein Platz mit der Ladeschütze das ist
mein Platz der Kommandant
zum Ausbildungszentrum die
panzerstreitkräfte beim österreichischen
Bundesheer was muss ich wissen es gibt
ein Panzerbataillon 14 wir verfügen
insgesamt über 56 Kampfpanzer Leopard 2
A4 wie wir mit einem hier fahren der
Leopard ist nur immer da Standard
Kampfpanzer in Europa wir haben 1500 PS
wir haben eine Kanone mit 120 mm wir
haben Einsatz schon zweiten von
2500 Meter
bewegungsgelände bis zu 80 km/h schnell
und das voll stabilisiert wenn ich jetzt
davon träume panzerfahrerin oder
Panzerfahrer zu werden weil eben anders
geht für Fragen für Männer natürlich wir
haben genauso Frauen was was ist denn
was hinter die Ausbildungsschritte 5
plus dann kann man bei uns alles werden
einrücken befasst werden 14 da kann das
grundverdiener Panzerfahrer werden
Richtschütze L unintelligible und als
Karl präsenzsoldat sind dieselben
Funktionen möglich und wir bleiben will
kann natürlich viel zu Bahn zukommen
lassen aufsteigen jeder kann Bundesheer
ist ganz besonders stolz immer auf seine
waffenkarte was macht die Panzerfahrer
so stolz wir sind das schwere
mechanisierte Rückgrat der militärischen
Landesverteidigung wir schauen dass wir
alle anderen Waffengattungen mit unserem
hauptwaffensystem unterstützt nehmen wir
mal prinzipiell anlassung mit den
kommandantenposten nicht geben will aber
wie wäre es mit dem Panzerfahrer Frauen
und ein bisschen Ausbildung davor
ich darf jetzt vorstellen den Urlaub den
Blaha den Kommandant unsere KPE
willkommen im Ausbildungszentrum am
sogenannten ad-
mit wuch deine vierte und damit die
Kanone und Feuerstellung geht drückst du
auf hauptfachfrisuren
bitte endlich der vorlehrer der wird die
einweisen bitte dich fast einfach einmal
einiges sehr cool
sehr gut bin bereit
ja
[Musik]
dahinter 12 Trennung fahrschulpanzer
Übungsfahrt gewinnen Ende
[Musik]
das war nicht schlecht probeweise
opfern
[Musik]
wer ich noch einmal zwei drei Jahre
jünger also 18 da hätte meine Einheit
gefunden und war sie heute alles erlebt
habt das war schon echt irre total
verantwortungsvolle coole Leute extrem
gut ausgebildet die einen unglaublichen
Job machen und das nicht nur wirklich
gut sondern preisgekrönt gut also
Einheit des Jahres beim österreichischen
Bundesheer und das ist echt speziell das
ist nämlich ein internationaler Preis
welcher das disrong Europe Tank
Challenge wow hier wolltest die
allerbesten danke
für dich habe ich noch kurz was unseren
page ja und eine kleine Aufgabe
so was für mich ja okay
das ist also der besondere Job für mich
speziell für mich
[Musik]
ja meine Damen und Herren das Mikro
funktioniert wieder ja sie haben jetzt
einen ersten Eindruck gewonnen wie es
bei der mechanisierten Truppe zugeht und
ich darf jetzt bitten die Panzer zu
räumen und den Weg frei zu machen damit
die Fahrzeuge in Kürze hier auf dem
Platz kommen können und ihnen zeigen
können welche
Leistungsmöglichkeiten diese bieten in
der Zwischenzeit darf ich Sie über eine
weitere Waffengattung informieren die
Sie derzeit auch im Bereich des
Burgtheaters näher sehen können die ABC
abwehrtruppe ABC steht für atomar
biologisch-
Frage entsprechende Verschmutzungen
Verstrahlungen
Kontaminationen zu erkennen aber auch zu
entfernen und um Ihnen hier einen
Eindruck zu bringen haben wir das
nächste Video vorbereitet Video ab
herzlich willkommen im tritolwerk wir
schauen uns jetzt mal an was die ABC
abwehrtruppe des österreichischen
Bundesheeres so drauf hat so und
herzlich willkommen bei der ABC
ABC hat jeder schon mal gehört aber
wofür steht eigentlich genau steht für
Automatik biologische chemische
Abwertungen wir schützen die Soldaten
und vor allem auch die Zivilbevölkerung
vor tomatenbilologischen Kampfstoffen
als auch Gefahrstoffen Chemiker aber
nicht die Kernkompetenz der
Waffengattung liegt in vier Bereichen
ist die ABC Aufklärung das ist die
Dekontamination des Retten und Bergen
und Brandschutz in kontaminierten
Gelände die Wasseraufbereitung ihr seid
so eine gute Truppe dass ihr weltweit
gefragt hat
ist eine katastrophenhilfeeinheit die
speziellen mit den Fähigkeiten der
bezaubte Truppe weltweit zum Einsatz
gelangen kann
ein bisschen genauer anschauen
lassen wir haben heute einiges
vorbereitet für dich
vorbereitet
es hat 30 Grad also
[Musik]
bereit was bei unseren aufklärungsdruck
mitmachen kannst
[Musik]
Boden zu entnehmen von den Gefahrstoffen
den potenziellen die hier vorgefunden
worden sind und da welche zählt sie
werde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Aufklärungszeit ist jetzt erledigt und
noch jeder oft Näherung folgt die
Dekontamination wir haben tatsächlich
die Unterstützung sie werden
brandschutzbekleidung
[Musik]
hallo
da ist die Rettung ja
[Musik]
so beim Verwundeten geht's gut
die ABC abwehrtruppe des
österreichischen Bundesheers wenn der
Feind ein unsichtbarer ist dann ist er
nicht besonders furchteinflößend er ist
auch sehr gefährlich wir Furcht kennen
die Frauen und Männer dahinter überhaupt
nicht super ausgebildete Soldatinnen und
Soldaten auf der einen Seite perfekt
ausgebildete ABC Abwehrkräfte auf der
anderen und nicht nur bei uns in
Österreich sondern die seine
internationale im Einsatz rund um den
Globus beeindruckt in der Gruppe und ich
glaube weiß jetzt gerade versammelt sind
aber gute Gelegenheit Danke zu sagen
danke
[Musik]
ja meine Damen und Herren das war die
Info über die arbeitserba-truppe und wie
Sie vielleicht hier schon festgestellt
haben haben wir die Aufstellung etwas
verändert und in Kürze werden hier die
Panzer präsentiert und zwar der
Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 A4 und da kam
Schützenpanzer Ulan meine Damen und
Herren eine große bitte bitte halten Sie
Ihre Kinder hinter den Sperren achten
Sie wenn Sie Haustiere mit haben dass
diese hier nicht herauslaufen die Sicht
des panzerfahrers ist eingeschränkt wir
bleiben natürlich innerhalb der
abgesperrten Fläche aber trotzdem bitte
schauen Sie darauf dass niemand hier auf
die Fahrbahn laufen kann es geht um
schweres Gerät eingeschränkte Sicht und
wir werden in Kürze die Motoren anwerfen
und dann können Sie etwas erleben
während die Soldaten des anwerfen
vorbereiten eine kurze Info die
Kampfpanzer wie sie schon im Video
vorhin gesehen haben sind in Wels
stationiert und die kampfschützenpanzer
sowohl in großmittel im Süden von Wien
als auch in Ried im Innkreis in beiden
bataonen allen drei Patronen kommen auch
Grund wird ihnen zum Einsatz in allen
Funktionen also auch als Panzerfahrer
Richtschütze Ladeschütze und bei den
Grenadieren natürlich auch als Grenadier
das Wesentliche der jeweiligen
Kampffahrzeuge beim Kampfpanzer der
Kampf auf große Entfernungen und der
starken Panzerschutz also zwischen
zweieinhalb und 4000 Meter geht die
Kanone und beim Ulan geht es darum die
Mannschaft ins Gefecht zu transportieren
aber sowohl abgesessen und aufgesessen
zu kämpfen und ich habe jetzt einen com
Moderator ich darf begrüßen Hauptmann
überegger und wir sind schon sehr
gespannt was wir jetzt sehen werden ich
schlage mal vor wir hören uns einfach
einmal an wie die Motoren klingen wenn
sie mir angeworfen werden
hey was danke für die guten Information
und die Einleitung wir haben noch ein
paar Minuten und werden dann sehen den
Schützenpanzer Ulan der uns einmal
zeigen wird wie er seine Wanne bewegen
kann und den Turm und natürlich auch wie
die Mannschaft absitzt und aufsitzt
ich glaube das Wesentliche ist es muss
ein klar sein das sind hochkomplexe
Geräte das heißt man braucht einmal eine
Zeit es gibt da eigene Checkliste beim
Anlassen bis man das amerikan wie lange
braucht man eigentlich als sage ich
Fahrer oder als Bediener egal in welcher
Funktion bis man dieses Gerät in seiner
Funktion beherrscht
beim kampfpoints ist es so dass der
Panzerfahrer auch ein Grundwehrdiener
seiner sein kann das heißt auch in den
sechs Monaten Grundwehrdienst kann man
das Erlernen und wichtig ist aber für
die
Kommandanten der Fahrzeuge dass ihr
Unteroffiziere sind und jede Funktion
auf den Geräten beherrschen das heißt
beim Kampfpanzer auch Ladeschütze
Richtschütze Fahrer und Kommandant
besetzen können
jetzt ist es ja nicht so einfach sage
ich so ein Gerät zu fahren wo haben Sie
die Möglichkeit diese Geräte auszubilden
und das auch zu üben weil es geht ja
nicht nur darum zu fahren das ganze ist
ja noch in weiterer Folge dann im
Gefecht einzusetzen ja vor allem das
Gefecht ist die große Herausforderung
wir haben Gott sei Dank die Möglichkeit
in allen steigt das Ganze zu üben dort
die panzerfahrschulen zu haben und dort
auch mit den gefechtsfahrzeugen scharf
zu schießen jetzt haben wir im Video
gesehen es gibt auch simulationsanlagen
das heißt sie sind nicht immer darauf
angewiesen mit dem Fahrzeug selber zu
üben das heißt also auch im Sinne einer
Kostenersparnis Umweltschutz etc gibt es
ja auch die Möglichkeiten wo kann man
das dann machen
genau man kann dann am Institut Panzer
Panzergrenadier den Turm also alle
Tätigkeiten welche haben durchgeführt
werden können üben aber Nachhaltigkeit
haben wir gerade angesprochen die Panzer
sind relativ sparsam sie verbrauchen ca
6 Liter pro Kilometer
naja wird denken wir allein beim
Kampfpanzer Leopard sind wir bei denke
ich wenn er voll auf uns 55 Tonnen die
können bewegt das immer bei
1.500 PS und also mein Auto hat zwei
Liter Hubraum was hat der Kampfpanzer ja
hier ist einmal bei circa 48 Liter
Hubraum und wie bereits schon gesagt
eben 1500 PS die 1500 PS befinden den
Kampfpanzer dazu dass das 70 km/h auf
der Straße fährt und im panzergelände
circa 50 bis 60
also ich rechne nach 24 mal mein Auto
Motor ist das was da Kampfpanzer hat
wenn ich noch einmal rechne also ich
weiß 12 Zylinder das heißt ein Liter hat
ein Zylinder hat vier Liter Hubraum das
ist doppelt das von meiner Mutter ja da
glaube ich sind sechs Tonnen glaube ich
für den Motor auch schon recht heftig
ja genau also das ist Fahrzeug alleine
zu bewegen ist schon eine
Herausforderung wir werden es dann
gleich hören wenn die Motoren starten
und ich glaube jetzt am Heldenplatz auch
spüren wenn die Kameraden mal richtig
Gas geben womit werden wir beginnen
wir beginnen jetzt mit dem schönsten
Panzer olan und ich würde sagen Motor an
da sprechen wir glaube ich von was 320
340 PS glaube haben wir in etwa wir
haben beim schützenband solaran 720 PS
und circa 28 Tonnen
können diese Fahrzeuge ohne lotsung auf
der Straße fahren oder braucht man da
extra jemand dazu naja das funktioniert
nicht so einfach wir haben sehr gute
Zusammenarbeit mit der Militärpolizei
und genau die werden dann gelotst und so
sind wir auch hier auf den helmplatz
gekommen das heißt beide Fahrzeuge
breiter als 250 definitiv gut dann
harren wir der Dinge und hören uns
einmal an und schauen uns an was da
Kampfbahn so lang kann
ein extrem kurzer Bremsweg
und sie sehen die Panne kann unabhängig
vom Turm sich bewegen einmal das Ziel
anvisiert bleibt die Kanone auf das
zielgerichtet
sie sehen die Grenadiere absitzen
der Panzer verfügt über einen
entsprechenden Minenschutz das heißt
also die Besatzung ist auch gegen
entsprechende Panzerminen geschützt die
Panzerung schützt die Besatzung im
Gefecht sowohl im sage jetzt einmal
aufgesessenen Einsatz natürlich aber der
Panzer selber kann natürlich auch im
Gefecht als Deckung gebraucht werden und
die Kanone eine 30 mm Maschinenkanone
kann entsprechend unterstützen da
Kommandant hat den Befehl zum aufsitzen
gegeben die Truppe sitzt wieder auf
wichtig natürlich die Vollzähligkeit
dass alle wieder im Panzer drin sind
letzter Mann steigt wieder ein die Tür
wird hydraulisch geschlossen und der
Panzer wird sofort wieder zurückverlegen
die Geschwindigkeiten sind natürlich
vorwärts- und rückwärts auch möglich
[Musik]
so
herzlichen Dank einen großen Applaus für
die Besatzung des gabs Schützenpanzers
Hauptbahnhof
ja vielleicht eins noch vorneweg für uns
ist ganz wichtig der Verbund der Waffen
also immer der Schützenbahn Solar mit
dem Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 auf 4 das ist
auch die kernfähigkeit der vierten
Panzergrenadierbrigade diese
wappensysteme gemeinsam mit der
Artillerie zum Einsatz zu bringen
wunderbar danke für die Info das heißt
das Zeichen ist gegeben und in Kürze
werden Sie hören wie 1500 PS arbeiten
natürlich hat man ein bisschen Rauch
beim Starten das merken die Damen und
Herren die hinter dem Panzer stehen
[Musik]
ja meine Damen und Herren mit dem winken
des Rohres hat sich der Kampfpanzer
Leopard 2 verabschiedet vielleicht noch
ein kleiner Hinweis zum Thema Motor also
vom Drehmoment her mein Motorrad hat 100
Newtonmeter Drehmoment ein LKW hat 2500
Newtonmeter vielleicht 3000 dieser Motor
hat
4.700 Newtonmeter Drehmoment
dementsprechend haben sie die Kraft auch
gespürt in diesem Sinne darf ich mich
auch bei ihnen Hauptmann recht herzlich
bedanken darf mich bei Ihnen für das
Zusehen bedanken und wir machen in Kürze
weiter die Fahrzeuge können natürlich
noch bis 17 Uhr besichtigt werden einen
großen Applaus für unsere
Panzerbesatzungen
[Applaus]
ich muss mich korrigieren bis 16 Uhr 30
weil dann verlegen die Panzer wieder die
Heimat Garnison und zurück also wie
gesagt bis 16.30 können Sie sich die
Kampfpanzer noch ansehen raufklettern
reinschauen fragen Sie die Soldaten so
schnell werden Sie die Gelegenheit nicht
mehr bekommen
meine Damen und Herren vorweg noch ein
Hinweis vor allem an die Personen die
sich dann in der Nähe der Hubschrauber
aufhalten werden wenn diese Staaten wir
machen natürlich die entsprechenden
Absperrungen trotzdem die Bitte an Sie
bitte nehmen Sie die Kopfbedeckungen im
Umkreis der Flug der Fluggeräte ab wenn
so ein Kopfbedeckung in den tur wie
gesagt wird kann das große Schäden
verursachen daher bitte Kopfbedeckungen
abnehmen keine Luftballone bitte
mitnehmen und achten Sie bitte auf
Kinder und Haustiere am besten genug
Abstand halten ich wiederhole denken Sie
bitte daran wenn sie nahe der
Hubschrauber beim Abheben dann gegen 16
Uhr 15 sein werden bitte Kopfbedeckungen
abnehmen keine Luftballons und Kinder
und Haustiere bitte bei sich behalten
dankeschön
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wie sie sich mitbekommen haben hat der
ORF heute am Vormittag übertragen und es
geht jetzt darum dass die Fahrzeuge des
ORF abrücken müssen ich darf Sie bitten
kurzfristig die Straße hier am
Heldenplatz frei zu geben das heißt
bitte auf die Seiten zu gehen es werden
ein oder zwei übertragungsfahrzeuge des
ORF den Platz verlassen danach machen
wir die Absperrung wieder zu und Sie
können dann wieder nach Vorgehen jetzt
bitte öffnen Sie die Teile auf der
Straße gehen Sie auf die Seite sie
können nachher dann nachdem die
Fahrzeuge durchgefahren sind wieder
zurück das gleiche bitte auch auf der
Seite der Panzer räumen Sie bitte kurz
die Straße sie können nachdem die
Fahrzeuge des ORF durchgefahren sind
wieder zurück auf die Straße bitte
räumen sie jetzt
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren wir beginnen
jetzt langsam aber sicher mit der
Räumung rund um den um die Hubschrauber
ich darf Sie bitten den Anweisungen der
Militärpolizei und der Polizei Folge zu
leisten und dem Platz frei zu machen wir
können sonst nicht starten und die
Hubschrauber müssen heute Weg bedenken
Sie der Black Hawk hat ein Abfluggewicht
von 8 Tonnen der muss 8 Tonnen nach
unten drücken die Windgeschwindigkeiten
unterhalb des rotes sind zwischen 80 und
100 Stundenkilometern das werden sie
nicht erstellen bitte gehen Sie daher
zurück räumen sie den Platz und macht
leisten Sie den Anweisungen der
Militärpolizei Folge und auch der
Polizei bitte verlassen Sie jetzt den
Bereich rund um den Black Hawk auch rund
um die anderen Hubschrauber herzlichen
Dank dass Sie dass ich das alles
angesehen haben aber bitte beginnen Sie
jetzt zu räumen
bitte machen Sie den Platz rund um den
helikopterfrei auch wenn sie beim
Pinzgauer stehen auch dort bitte räumen
sie wir haben rote Windgeschwindigkeiten
zwischen 80 und 100 Stundenkilometern
das bläst sie weg es bläst Ihnen
möglicherweise Steine ins Gesicht sie
könnten sich verletzen Kredite räumen
Sie jetzt die Bereiche um die
Hubschrauber
eine Damen und Herren bitte über die
Straße drüber sie stehen zu nahe über
die Straße bitte die Straße muss frei
sein über die Straße bitte hinüber
auf die andere Straßenseite gegenüber
vom Hubschrauber ist das möglich näher
nicht
auf die andere Straßenseite bitte zurück
auf den Gehsteig auch Kinderwagen
bringen vorne nichts bitte zu rück
glauben Sie mir Sie müssen nicht in der
ersten Reihe stehen um das Abheben des
Hubschraubers zu sehen er geht eh nach
oben sie sehen es dann auch wenn er
aufsteigt auch wenn sie nicht in der
ersten Reihe und ganz vorne stehen noch
einmal zurück auf den Gehsteig bitte zu
Ihrer eigenen Sicherheit gehen Sie bitte
auf den Gehsteig zurück
meine Damen und Herren der Gesteck
zeichnet sich durch die Gehsteigkante
aus und da stellen Sie sich bitte oben
drauf nicht auf der Straße es ist zu
Ihrer eigenen Sicherheit und sie sehen
den Helikopter abheben zurück bitte auf
den Gehsteig
glauben Sie mir meine Damen und Herren
sie sehen das Abheben des Helikopters
auch wenn sie am Gehsteig oben stehen es
funktioniert so bitte nicht
noch einmal bitte auf den Gehsteig die
Gehsteigkante ist da es ist zu Ihrer
Sicherheit und die paar Zentimeter sind
kein Problem sie sehen den Helikopter
beim Abheben bitte vor allem auch
Kinderwagen nach hinten es werden Steine
fliegen wir haben möglicherweise das ein
oder andere Teil hier noch in der Wiese
gesehen das ist ein Problem bitte gehen
Sie auf den Gehsteig zurück
bitte auf den Gehsteig bitte zurück es
ist zu Ihrer eigenen Sicherheit
ja
bitte zurück auf den Gehsteig sie sehen
den Helikopter auch so Abheben der hebt
eh in die Höhe ab zurück bitte auf den
Gehsteig wir brauchen diese diesen Platz
es ist zu Ihrer Sicherheit
alle auf den Gehsteig bitte
bitte es ist nicht so schwierig wir
müssen ja nicht unbedingt die Ketten
nach hinten ziehen bitte um Ihr
Verständnis zurück auf den Gehsteig
please step back everyone we need the
street free it's for your safety
und ein weiteres mal bitte auf den
gesteig
meine Damen und Herren ich habe es
wirklich versucht ich weiß es mag
vielleicht schwierig sein ich darf auch
die hinteren reinbitten noch einmal nach
hinten zu gehen sie sehen den Helikopter
abheben es ist kein Problem
lieber Franz
lieber Rainer wenn ich dich so bei den
koordinierungsarbeiten hier sehe dann
kommen wir doch mal zu was schönes und
zwar vor mir ist eine der Gewinnerinnen
liebe Katharina freust du dich schon auf
den Rundflug sehr sehr bist du denn
schon mal mit einem Hubschrauber
Helikopter mitgeflogen
und wie glaubst du wie wir jetzt was
sind die Vorstellungen
abgehoben und dann fliegen wir nach
langen Leben
also ich merke schon eine der zehn
Gewinnerinnen danke Katharina wir
wünschen dir sehr viel Spaß aber sie
haben schon gehört sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren also es ist kein Spaß hier
vor Ort es wird einen Downwash einen
sogenannten geben ich würde sie auch
bitte dass Sie Ihre Kappen
Kopfbedeckungen Mützen alles was lose
ist oder was sie nicht festhalten können
in ihren Taschen verstauen und diese
auch schließen
und ich darf noch ergänzen Luftballons
bitte halten Sie Luftballons fest
verstauen Sie diese auch das ist ein
Sicherheitsproblem für uns
meine Damen und Herren in der
Zwischenzeit während die Vorbereitungen
laufen haben wir noch die Möglichkeit
an sich den Sport zu präsentieren ich
selber gerade wir haben ein Problem mit
dem Fahrzeug und deshalb haben wir die
Bühne nicht wir sind aber bemüht das
Problem zu lösen
zur kurzen Erklärung die Fahrzeuge
verlegen jetzt weg und sie sind ein
Feuerwehrfahrzeug es gehört noch eine
Lampe gesichert allein eben durch den
starken Druck des Rotors könnte es hier
zu weiteren Beschädigungen oder zu
Gefährdung von Personen kommen und wir
sind mittlerweile dabei die
Vorbereitungen für das Abheben der
Luftfahrzeuge zu treffen danke für ihre
Kooperation danke dass Sie
zurückgegangen sind und für die die noch
herunten stehen darf ich trotzdem bitten
zurück auf den Gehsteig danke für Ihr
Verständnis danke für die Kooperation
für sie nochmal zur Information der
Black Hawk hat am heutigen Tag ein
Abfluggewicht von 8 Tonnen das heißt der
Rotor muss einen Druck von über 8 Tonnen
entwickeln damit der Hubschrauber
überhaupt abheben kann und wenn sie
jetzt überlegen dass ein Stück Metall
eine Getränkedose mit 80
Stundenkilometern hier herum fliegen
würde dann habt ihr schon Sinn warum
jetzt momentan auch der letzte Müll
aufgeklappt wird und warum wir darauf
schauen dass der Abstand auch passt wie
gesagt danke für Verständnis und wir
werden in Kürze dann mit den Staat
Vorbereitungen beginnen danke sehr
für Sie zur Information nach dem Abheben
der Hubschrauber beginnen wir mit der
Aufstellung der Panzer und der
gepanzerten Fahrzeuge die dann auch kurz
darauf abmarschieren werden das heißt
auch hier bitte die Straße dann
entsprechend freizuhalten dazwischen
aber auch natürlich die Möglichkeit dass
die Fahrzeuge entsprechend hier auf die
Straße fahren können darf dann wieder
bitten dass Sie den Anweisungen der
Militärpolizei und der Polizei dann
folge leisten aber wie gesagt Sie haben
dann auch die Möglichkeit natürlich die
Gefechtsfahrzeuge noch beim Abmarsch zu
sehen wie gesagt nach dann dem Abflug
der Hubschrauber
für sie zu Informationen als erstes wird
der oh 58 der von mir aus gesehen beim
Parlament hinten steht also als erstes
abheben danach die Alouette die beim
präsidentschaftsrat steht und als
Letzter Hubschrauber wird der Black Hawk
abheben Reihenfolge oh 58
Alouette 3 und dann der Blackhawk
noch einmal der Hinweis bitte nehmen Sie
Ihre Kopfbedeckungen ab
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren die Triebwerke
werden Kürze angelassen bitte halten sie
ihre Taschen fest halten Sie Kinderwagen
festhalten sie Luftballone fest auch
wenn sie Taschen abgestellt haben ich
sehe zum Beispiel einen Herrn dass eine
Tasche abgestellt hat die müssen sie
festhalten die weht es ihnen sonst davon
Kopfbedeckungen sofern es also Cup oder
Hüte sind und achten Sie bitte darauf
dass Sie Ihre Kinder festhalten auch
Kinder wegen etc wir haben
starke Windgeschwindigkeiten und einen
starken Druck am Boden bis der
Hubschrauber abgehoben hat
meine Damen und Herren danke für
Verständnis das war der Abflug wir
müssen jetzt die Sperre aufrechterhalten
und dürfen sie dann jetzt bitten auch
die Straße langsam aber sicher zu räumen
wir werden in Kürze mit der Aufstellung
der Kampffahrzeuge beginnen und den
abmarschorganisieren darüber hinaus
müssen noch weitere Fahrzeuge den Platz
verlassen bitte folgen Sie wieder den
Anordnungen des Personals der
Militärpolizei und der Polizei damit wir
dann weitermachen können danke für
Verständnis
meine Damen und Herren wir werden in
Kürze beginnen mit der Aufstellung ich
darf sie bieten die Straße frei zu
machen sie sehen dann die Kampffahrzeuge
wenn sie abmarschieren bitte machen Sie
jetzt die Straße frei wir müssen
aufstehen
wer noch über die Straße drüber möchte
kurze Gelegenheit schnell noch aber wir
brauchen entsprechend Platz dankeschön
machen sie den Platz zwischen den
Panzern frei sie hören es werden bereits
Motoren angeworfen
und die Gehsteigkante ist wieder
gefragt bitte zurück auf den Gehsteig
die Fahrer haben eingeschränkt die Sicht
die Fahrzeuge brauchen viel Platz es ist
zu Ihrer eigenen Sicherheit
[Musik]
meine Damen und Herren sie sehen hier
die Fahrzeuge schon in der Reihenfolge
des abmarsches beginnend der Bergepanzer
M88 danach der Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 der
kampfschützenpanzer Olang der
Bergepanzer die Panzer Haubitze das
gepanzerte Transportsystem der Dingo und
nach dem zweiten Dingo der
Transportpanzer Pandur in dieser
Reihenfolge wird in Kürze der Abmarsch
über den Ring erfolgen sie dürfen gerne
wenn die Fahrzeuge dann Abfahrt abfahren
den Besatzungen einen großen Applaus
spenden wenn es Ihnen gefallen hat
die Bundesminister verabschiedet noch
die einzelnen Besatzungen und ab dem
Zeitpunkt beginnt dann der Abmarsch über
den Ring zurück ins Arsenal meine Damen
und Herren ich darf sie noch einmal
Hinweisen heute um 17 Uhr der offizielle
Abschluss der Veranstaltung der
Zapfenstreich geblasen vom soltrompeter
der Garde Musik vom äußeren Burgtor um
17 Uhr
es wird es wird hier vom Fahrrad die
höchste Präzision gefordert der Leo habe
ich mir gerade sagen lassen ist der
Ängste der hier durch muss und auch das
wird wieder wie immer perfekt von der
Grube löst werden dank ausgezeichneter
Ausbildung einem guten Augenmaß und
tollen teamwerk meine Damen und Herren
geben Sie den Besatzungen an kräftigen
Applaus
[Applaus]
nochmals der Hinweis um 17 Uhr ist die
Veranstaltung dann offiziell beendet es
erfolgt dann der Zapfenstreich geblasen
vom solothompeter da Gardemusik
abschließend sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren befindet sich jetzt neben mir der
Militärkommandant von Wien Brigadier
Kurt Wagner Herr Präger dir darf ich um
ein kurzes Resümee des heutigen
beziehungsweise vielleicht auch das
gestrigen Tages bieten
ja ich darf mich gestern beginnen wir
hatten gestern den Tag der Schulen und
und einen eine grandiose Teilnahme von
Schülerinnen und Schülern und und auch
vom sonstigen Publikum das bereits
gestern gekommen ist ich glaube wir
hatten noch nie so viele Schüler wie
gestern und der heutige Tag war wirklich
außerordentlich von der Besucheranzahl
von den Darbietungen die wir insgesamt
gesehen hat haben ich darf es kurz
machen ich werde oft gefragt so ist
alles gut und ich sage meistens naja
alles ist nicht gut heute war alles gut
danke sehr Herr Brigitte dir
Frau Bundesministerin aus ihrer Sicht
die vergangenen beiden Tage und speziell
der heutige Tag ich glaube ein Wort
beschreibt
sensationell und es ist mir wirklich ein
Bedürfnis ein Soldatinnen und Soldaten
den Zivilbediensteten meines Ressorts
alle im Berufsstand in der Miliz ein
ganz großes Dankeschön zu sagen vor
allem aber auch Ihnen den Besucherinnen
und Besuchern sie sind Teil der Mission
vorwärts die unser österreichisches
Bundesheer jetzt wirklich modern und
kampffähig machen wird es war einfach
sensationell danke ihnen allen danke
Frau Bundesminister
und nochmals der Hinweis um 17 Uhr
beenden wir die Veranstaltung offiziell
mit dem Zapfenstreich
noch eine Information der Zapfenstreich
wird vom solothompeter geblasen und
nicht mehr die ganze Garde Musik mit
hier am Platz erscheinen wenn sie dann
ihren Blick auf das Äußere Burgtor
richten in elf Minuten und Punkt 17 Uhr
der Trompeter steht schon oben und um
punkt 17 Uhr wieder die Veranstaltung
mit dem Zapfenstreich beenden
gesucht werden mich mit Zeit und
Vorzimmer seid wenn sie uns hören kommen
Sie bitte hier auf die Mitte der Straße
bei den bei der Bühne wo der ORF heute
gestanden ist bitte kommen Sie zu uns
sie werden hier erwartet
mich mehr Zeit und Verdiener werden
gesucht
wenn sie uns hören möchten mit und
Fatima sie können auch gerne zu einem
Polizisten gehen eine Militärpolizisten
oder einen Polizisten in Blau der wird
sie dann zu uns hier auf die Straße
bringen
noch einmal der Hinweis der Aufrufe
suchen mich mit Zeit und Fatima 14 und 6
Jahre alt wir befinden uns hier in der
Mitte der Straße wenn sie uns hören dann
kommen Sie bitte hierher oder wenden Sie
sich eine Militärpolizisten oder einen
Herrn der Polizei die werden sie dann zu
uns bringen sie werden hier erwartet
die gute Nachricht die beiden wurden
gefunden
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
jeder schöne Tag geht zu Ende wir sind
kurz vor dem offiziellen Ende des
heutigen Tages sondern dieser Stelle
wollen wir beide uns Marcel und ich vor
allem einmal bei der Regie bedanken bei
Peter FEG der entsteht der das minutiös
geplant hat der das seit vielen Jahren
perfekt macht lieber Peter dir ganz ganz
herzlichen Dank einen großen Applaus für
Peter Fake
[Applaus]
uns bleibt nur mehr ich darf mich bei
Dir bedanken Marcel Marcel Hauptmann
Marcel Taschler herzlichen Dank für die
Moderation es war ein gelungener Tag
danke dafür
gehen gleich lieber reiner darf ich mich
bedanken also jederzeit gerne wieder und
ich freue mich schon auf nächstes Jahr
ich hoffe ihnen hat es genauso gefallen
einen recht herzlichen Dank an Herr
Oberst Rainer Radinger danke sehr und
schönen Abend in diesem Sinne danke sehr
in diesem Sinne ersuche ich nun den
Trompeter und das offizielle Ende den
Zapfenstreich
[Musik]
[Applaus]